I WILL GOOD
MORNING LADIES IN GERMAN WE
WELCOME YOU TO THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE- WE ARE GOING TO BE
FOCUSING THIS MORNING'S HEARING
ON CALIFORNIA'S. SALMON
FISHERIES WHICH ARE IN CRISIS
WE'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON THE
HISTORIC DROUGHT LOW FLOWS IN
THE ANTICIPATION OF DEAD FISH
HERE. IN THE COMING WEEKS WE
ARE GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOU
HAVE JOINED US TODAY WE'D LIKE
TO BE A START. TODAY'S HEARING
WITH SOME HOUSEKEEPING FIRST
AND FOREMOST I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR VICE CHAIR
VICE CHAIR STONE FOR. JOINING
US TODAY WE'RE GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM THE VICE CHAIR IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS. IN RESPONSE
TO THE COPING NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATE TAURUS AS WELL AS
EMPLOYEES ARE GONNA HAVE TO
LIMIT. NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES TODAY IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THESE ORDERS THE SENATE
HAS MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO. NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING
TESTIMONY TODAY HERE. IN ROOM
AT FORTY TWO OH THREE IN THE
CAPITAL WE HAVE AN OVERFLOW
ROOM TODAY OF ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
YOUR PARTICIPATION HERE VIA OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO JOIN THE CONVERSATION
HERE TODAY IN OUR HEARING.
PLEASE DIAL TOLL FREE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE AGAIN OUR TOLL
FREE NUMBER TODAY'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE THREE THAT ACCESS CODE IS
GOING TO BE SEVEN ZERO FIVE
SIXTY NINE OH NINE. ALL OF THE
INFORMATION IS ON YOUR SCREEN
RIGHT NOW. BUT WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH WILL BE AT
THE END OF TODAY'S AGENDA.
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION A
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL HAVE. ONE
MINUTE TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE HERE TODAY AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS. WHEN
YOU DO CALL IN WE'RE GOING TO
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE MUTE YOUR
DEVICE. THAT YOU'RE WATCHING
NINE OR HEARING ON. PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY TO BE A LIMIT-
ANY TYPE OF. FEEDBACK AND
DESTRUCTION IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT THAT AN INDIVIDUAL
BECOMES UNRULY WHETHER IT'S
HERE IN PERSON OR ON THE PHONE.
THAT INDIVIDUAL MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEDIAN SERVERS
OR HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
FORTY TWO THREE. OR IN OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM IN THAT IS ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. BUT AGAIN THAT IS
VERY UNLIKELY. I'D LIKE TO BE
TO GET INTO SOME OPENING
COMMENTS IN AND TURNED OVER. TO
OUR FANTASTIC VICE CHAIR VICE
CHAIR STONE. WHO IS
REPRESENTING THE ASSEMBLY HERE
TODAY. LOOK THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT WE NEED TO COME
TOGETHER. AT THIS VERY CRITICAL
TIME BECAUSE IT'S INCREDIBLY
FRAGILE FOR OUR STATE'S ICONIC
SALMON WHO ARE ON THE BRINK OF
TOTAL COLLAPSE. AND IN SOME
WATERSHED HERE IN THE STATE ON
THE BRINK OF TOTAL EXTINCTION.
SALMON HAVE MIGRATED THE
TRADITIONALLY COLD WATERS OF
CALIFORNIA STREAMS AND MUDDY
RIVERS FOR CENTURIES. THEY'RE
INCREDIBLY HARDY SPECIES
OVERCOMING GREAT ODDS TO RETURN
TO THEIR HOMES STREAM THEIR
BIRTH PLACE TO LAY THEIR EGGS
AND START THE PROCESS OF THAT
GREAT ANNUAL MIGRATION OVER
AGAIN. NO SALMON OF INVOLVED TO
LIVE IN THE RUGGED WEST THEY OF
ALL TO A BATTLE RAGING TORRENTS
INTO LEAP OVER ROCKSLIDES
THEY'VE EVOLVED TO WITHSTAND
WILDFIRES. THEIR LEGACY LEGALLY
HELP BUILD THE GOLDEN STATE.
THE CARCASSES OF SPAWNING ADULT
SALMON CREATED TO NOURISH THE
SOILS OF OUR UPSWINGS IN OUR
MOUNTAINS THE GREAT SALMON
MIGRATION ITS STORIED. IN IT
WAS ONCE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
TRANSFER OF ENERGY NUTRIENTS
FROM THE SEA TO THE LAND IN OUR
GEOLOGIC HISTORY. SALMON ALSO
HELP BUILD OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES ADDING TREMENDOUS
VALUE TO OUR COASTAL ENDING A
CONNIE'S THROUGH COMMERCIAL
ENTERPRISE AND RECREATIONAL
ENJOYMENT. THE NEAREST PEOPLE
HERE SINCE PEOPLE STARTED
TAKING STEPS IN WHAT IS NOW
BECOME CALIFORNIA. TODAY THOUGH
THE SAME SALMON BEHIND THEY
HANG ON BY A THREAD. WE'RE
WITNESSING THE COLLAPSE OF THIS
ICONIC SPECIES. RIGHT IN FRONT
OF OUR EYES. NOW THE OVER FUND
OF THIS COMMITTEE SERVICE TO
ENSURE THAT THE OFFICIALS
ENTRUSTED WITH OUR PUBLIC
TRUST. FISHERY AND AQUACULTURE
RESOURCES DO SO TO THE BEST OF
THEIR ABILITY IN COMPLIANCE
WITH SCIENCE AND THE LAW. SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DONE THIS
IMPORTANT WORK. BUT NEVER IN
OUR NEARLY FIFTY YEAR
EXISTENCE. HAS THIS COMMITTEE
CONTINUED WITH SUCH A DIRE
SITUATION. A DIRE SITUATION.
THAT WE'RE SEEING HERE TODAY.
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC DROUGHT.
FOR MAKING HOLD COMMUNITIES
UNLIVABLE. AND WHILE THE PEOPLE
OF THIS GREAT HAVE SHOWN GREAT
AND RESILIENCE AND RESOLVE IN
THE FACE OF DROUGHT. I THINK WE
WORRY AS WELL ABOUT THE SALMON
OR WHETHER SHE WATERSHEDS THAT
BREED LIFE IN WEALTH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR SURE YEARS AGO
THE VICE CHAIR AND I HELD A
HEARING CALLED WHERE OF ALL THE
SALMON GONE. WE HEARD ABOUT THE
PERILOUS STATE OF SALMON
FISHERY AFTER THE LAST DROP
AFTER THE LAST PERIOD A
FEDERALLY DECLARED FISHERIES
DISASTERS. AFTER THE DANGEROUS
GAMBLE THE RUN THE WATER SYSTEM
AND CENTRAL VALLEY TO THE LIMIT.
A REPORT RELEASED AT THAT TIME
BY CALTRANS. CONCLUDED THAT
FIFTY TWO PERCENT. 52% OF THE
SALMON SPECIES IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE WIPED OUT WITHIN FIFTY
YEARS IF SERIOUS MEASURES.
AREN'T TAKEN TO HELP SAM. FOUR
YEARS AGO WE KNEW THAT 81% OF
CALIFORNIA'S REMAINING SALMON.
STEELHEAD AND TROUT WERE
SHOWING SIGNS OF SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE. THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT
REPORT WOULD LOOK LIKE IF IT
WERE UPDATED TODAY. THINK ABOUT
HOW MUCH WORSE IT'S BECOME FOR
FISH YEAR IN CALIFORNIA. ANY
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH BETTER OFF
WE WILL BE IT FOR YEARS A
RELATIVE WATER WEALTH WERE USED
TO. BUILD RESILIENCE INTO OUR
RIVER MANAGEMENT SYSTEM INSTEAD
OF MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S WATER
STORAGE POLICY. THIS YEAR WE
ARE HEARING FROM OUR OWN
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THAT WE COULD SEE A ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. I 1100% DIE OFF OF
WINTER RUN BABY SALMON. KILLED
OFF IN THE SACRAMENTO. WITHIN
THE SACRAMENTO RIVER WATERSHED.
AND JUST BEING HONEST BOUT IT
THIS IS A LEGACY OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP FEDERAL WATER YOUR WATER
POLICIES SHIFTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SHIFTED TO PUSH
WATER THAT WAS ONCE STORED
BEHIND CALIFORNIA'S RESERVOIRS
TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY WITH
LITTLE TO NO REGARD. FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC SALMON
FISHERY THE ADMINISTRATION
IGNORED ITS OWN BIOLOGISTS THEY
IGNORED SCIENTISTS IN THE DUMP
THE NEEDED COLD WATER THAT WAS
STORED IN GOLDEN STATE LAKES.
THAT HELP BALANCE INDEED OF
FARMERS AND RANCHERS ALONG WITH
THE NEED OF OUR ENVIRONMENT IN
FISH. AND EVEN THOUGH PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS NO LONGER IN OFFICE
CALIFORNIA AND CANDIDLY THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION HAS
MAINTAINED THIS ABYSMAL POLICY.
EARLIER AT LAST YEAR FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO SERRA SUE
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION FOR
VIOLATING THE DINING ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT IN ENACTING THE
WATER MANAGEMENT PLAN IT SEEMS
CLEARLY DESIGNED TO FACILITATE
EXTINCTION. ALLOWING THREE
YEARS. ONLY THREE YEARS A TOTAL
SALMON DEATH BEFORE REMEDIAL
ACTION IS TAKEN. INDEED THIS
STATE SAT IDLY BY RUBBER
STAMPING WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS
PROMULGATED UNDER THE VERY PLAN
THAT THE STATE IS LITIGATING.
IT'S IS OUTRAGEOUS THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND NOW BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF ACTION AND THIS
DROUGHT. IT'S LIKELY GOING TO
BE THE DEATH KNELL OF WINTER
RUN CHINOOK IN CALIFORNIA. LOOK
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
DROUGHT IS INCREDIBLY TRAGIC
EIGHT CREATES INCREDIBLE
HARDSHIP IN THE SCIENCE IS
TELLING US THAT WE COULD BE IN
IT FOR A LONG TIME AND WE HAVE
TO DO BETTER AND THAT'S WHY WE
WANTED TO BE A TO BRING THIS
FIFTY YEAR COMMITTEE TOGETHER
TODAY TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING FOM OUR AGENCY LEADERS
ABOUT THIS VERY TOPIC. IN MORE.
WELL HERE A HE CRUCIAL UPDATE
ABOUT THE PROGRESS TOWARDS DAM
REMOVAL ON THE KLAMATH. THE
SILVER LINING COMES AS A RIVER
FACES SOME OF THE MOST.
TERRIBLE CONDITIONS EVER IN
HISTORY. CONDITION SO BAD IN
THE KLAMATH AT NEARLY. EVERY
FISH IS INFECTED WITH HEAT
LOVING PERICYTES. SO HOT THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE TO REST. TOO
RISKY TO LET A SINGLE BABY FISH
SWIM DOWNSTREAM FROM THE IRON
GATE HATCHERY. WE'RE ALSO GOING
HERE FOR SOME. THAT WERE IN
HERE ABOUT SOME DIFFICULT
DECISIONS HAVE BEEN MADE OR
WILL BE MADE TO CURTAIL WATER
USE. IN DELIVERIES ON THE SCOTT
AND SHASTA REVERSED ALONG WITH
IN THE RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED.
OUR NUMBER ONE GOAL AS IT
ALWAYS IS TO HEAR FROM EACH OF
YOU THE PUBLIC AND HEAR FROM
OUR ALL STAR PANEL. OF
DISTINGUISHED PANELISTS BUT
BEFORE WE GET INTO THE REMARKS
I'D LIKE TO TURN THE COMMITTEE
OVER. TO OUR VICE CHAIR VICE
CHAIR STONE WE WELCOME USER
AND- PROVIDE THE FLOOR FOR
OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. ON THE CENTRAL
COAST WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR
YEARS ON AND PROTECTING
PRESERVING THE ANADROMOUS
SALMONID CENTER THERE AND WE'VE
SEEN FOR CERTAIN SPECIES THAT
EXTINCTION LINE MOVED FURTHER
AND FURTHER NORTH SO A LOT OF
EFFORT HAS BEEN DONE ON VERY TO
THE SMALL COASTAL WATERSHEDS TO
TRY AND MITIGATE THE LOSS OF
THE SELMON IT'S AN IN MANAGE
HABITAT IN THE SMARTER AND
BETTER WAY. NOW WE'RE SEEING
THIS ON A GRAND SCALE REALLY
ACROSS THE SIERRA. CAN UP THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER WHERE CLEARLY
FAILED. WATER POLICY ESPECIALLY
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL HAS. COME
TOGETHER WITH THE DROUGHT AND
OTHER EFFECTS TO PROVIDE SOME
REALLY DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON
THE SALMONIDS IN IN CALIFORNIA
SO EVEN AS CLIMATE IS SHIFTING
AND WE'RE HAVING TO DO A BETTER
JOB OF MANAGING WATERSHEDS AND
RETHINK HOW WATER MOVES THROUGH
THE SYSTEM TO PROTECT THE FISH
AS WELL AS PROVIDE WATER FOR
HUMAN USE AND FOR AGRICULTURE
APPROPRIATELY. THESE ARE
DECISIONS THAT WERE BEING
WORKED ON IN BEING MADE AND
THAT WE'VE HAD SOME PRETTY
DEVASTATING CIRCUMSTANCES COME
TOGETHER INCLUDING
MISMANAGEMENT OF FEDERAL
POLICY. TO REALLY DRIVE.
FISHERIES POTENTIALLY TO
EXTINCTION WHICH IS REALLY
FRIGHTENING TO SEE. AND SO A
LOT OF THE STEPS THAT WE'VE
MADE OVER THE YEARS ARE NOW
BEING ANNOUNCED BY THIS POLICY
AND THEN NOT SURE REALLY WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO GO. BUT IT'S A
CRISIS NOW AND IT'S GOING TO BE
A CRISIS CONTINUING INTO THE
FUTURE WHETHER OR NOT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE DROUGHT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE WITH THE
WATER SHOULD HAVE BEEN MANAGED
AND ABUSED AND MISUSED THE DAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE.
BUT FORTUNATELY NOW ON THE
KLAMATH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TAKING OUT BUT MANAGING
UPSTREAM. TO THE WATERSHEDS
WERE THE SOURCE OF THE WATER IS
WHAT WE'VE TRADITIONALLY HAD
COLD WATER COMING DOWN. AND IN
APPROPRIATE VOLUMES COMING DOWN
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
FISHERIES THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
TO. LOOK TO THE FUTURE TO GET
BACK TO YOU SO THAT WE CAN HELP
A FISH THAT HAS BEEN RESILIENT
AND COMING UP AGAINST THE POINT
OF NO LONGER BEING ABLE TO
MANAGE THE- THE CHANGES THAT
ARE MOSTLY MAN MADE THAT OR ARE
COMING DOWN TO THE SAMANIDS. SO
I DON'T THINK THESE REPORTS ARE
GOING TO BE. HI VERY OPTIMISTIC
I'M AFRAID BUT I'M ALSO LOOKING
FOR. OUR EXPERTS TO HELP US
FIGURE OUT WHAT STEPS NEED TO
BE TAKEN AT THE AGENCY LEVEL.
OR AT OUR POLICY LEVEL IN ORDER
TO DO THE BEST WE CAN DO TO
INVEST IN WATERSHEDS FOR OUR
FUTURE AND AGAIN THAT'S FOR.
INVESTING IN HUMANS BUT IT'S
ALSO INVESTING IN THE CELL
MINUS THE WILDLIFE FISHERIES
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
SO HARD TO PROTECT. SO THIS IS
NOT HEARING I'VE BEEN LOOKING
FORWARD TO BUT I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO GETTING SOME GOOD
ADVICE AND- FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CHART THE PATH FORWARD SO THANK
YOU MR. VENTURA SINCERELY
MEANNESS MISTER VICE CHAIR IS
ONE OF THE LEADING ADVOCATES IN
THE STATE ON ALL ISSUES OF
WATERSHED RESTORATION FOCUSING
ON FISHERIES SURVIVAL AND
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP CERTAIN COULD YOU
SEE. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN
MONOGAMY MOVING ON TO OUR FIRST
PANEL OUR FIRST PANEL IS GOING
TO BE COMPRISED OF TWO SALMON
WATER POLICY VETERANS AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT THEY COULD JOIN
US TODAY WERE FIRST GOING TO
HEAR FROM CHUCK BONHAM CHUCK
BONHAM IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. AND I WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO BE ABLE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DIRECTOR WHO'S
MOVED WITH SPEED TO BE ABLE TO
SAVE RUNS OF SALMON HERE
ESPECIALLY HATCHER ON SALMON-
AT THROUGH HIS ROLE AS A
DIRECTOR EFFICIENT WILDLIFE. HE
IS GOING TO BE TALKING TO US
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS
TO CONSERVE SALMON INCLUDING
THE DIRE SITUATION FACING HER
OUR FALL RUN CHINOOK SALMON IN
THE DEVASTATED WHEN AROUND
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO HEAR FROM
HIM ABOUT CENTRAL VALLEY WATER
POLICIES GOING TO TALK TO US
ABOUT. THE AGENCY'S HATCHERY
PROGRAMS ITS ROLE IN MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS CLIMATE DAM
REMOVAL AND OTHER ITEMS
IMPORTANT AT FOR THIS COMMITTEE
TO RECEIVE AN UPDATE ON SO
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO LADIES IN
GERMAN HE'S GONNA BEJOINING
US. VIRTUALLY WE WELCOME AT
DIRECTOR BONHAM HERE TO
COMMITTEE MISTER DIRECTOR YOU
HAVE TEN MINUTES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING TIME IN YOUR
BUSY SCHEDULE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR AND WE'LL HOLD
QUESTIONS UNTIL WE HEAR FROM.
ME SO BACK WHOSE EXACTED RECTOR
AFTER THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. MISTER DIRECTOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
SENATOR LET MR JUST CA. THAT
YOU CAN BOTH HERE AND SEE ME
WELL. YOU'RE COMING IN LOUD AND
CLEAR AND I'M TAKING THOSE
CLASSES. MY SIDE IS GOD WORSE
WITH THE SO MUCH OF OUR WORK
LIFE ON THE COMPUTER SCREEN
COMMITTEE. HEY IT'S TRUE MY
NAME IS CHUCK BONHAM I AM STILL
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK
YOU VICE YOURS BROWN. ALSO WANT
TO THANK OUR TO TRIBAL CHAIRS
THAT ARE JOINING TODAY SURE
JAMES INSURER OTHER VERY- MY
DEPARTMENT'S PARTNERSHIP WITH
THOSE TWO TRIBES AS SOVEREIGNS
IN THE KLAMATH BASIN IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO ME
PERSONALLY AND CO MANAGEMENT
WITH THESE TRIBES IS OUR FUTURE.
ON JULY SIXTEENTH YOU ASKED ME
TO COVER SPECIFIC TOPICS TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO WALK THROUGH THAT
LIST AND LET ME BEGIN WITH AN
OVERALL STATUS. BUT BEFORE I
JUST WANNA KNOW MY ENTIRE
PROFESSIONAL LIFE HAS BEEN AND-
COMMITTED TO SALMON
CONSERVATION IN THE WEST. IN MY
CURRENT JOB IN MY PRIOR ROLES
FOR TROUT UNLIMITED THE
NATION'S OLDEST AND LARGEST
SALMON AND TROUT CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATION. ACTUALLY CHOSE MY
LAW SCHOOL BASED ON THE FACT
THAT THE CURRICULA INCLUDED
SALMON LAW. SO THESE ARE TOPICS
THAT VICE CHAIR ARE DIFFICULT
TO DEAL WITH BECAUSE WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH SUCH BLEAKNESS.
BUT THESE FISH PROVE US IF WE
GIVE A CHANCE TO THEM BILL
SURVIVED THEIR HEARTY AND
THEY'RE RESILIENT. IS THE
OVERALL PICTURE IF YOU TAKE THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS. WHAT YOU'LL
SEE AND TWENTY YEARS OF PRETTY
GRANULAR DATA WE HAVE ACROSS
THE STATE IS A GENERAL STATE OF
DECLINE FOR SAM FISHER. YOU
LOOK BACK TO TWO THOUSAND AND
YOU GO TO TWENTY TWENTY AND YOU
CAN PLOT OUT IN BAR CHARTS. I'M
UP AND DOWN SOME YEARS THE
POPULATIONS HEADING UP SOME
YEARS IT'S HEADING DOWN. BUT
GENERALLY OVER THOSE TWENTY
YEARS IT'S ON A LONG TRAJECTORY
DOWNWARD. AND ACROSS THE TWENTY
YEARS AGAIN IS JUST A SNAPSHOT
THERE'S AN EARLIER RECORD IN
TOWN. BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THE YEARS OF TWO THOUSAND SIX
SEVEN EIGHT NINE IS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THOSE WERE
PARTICULARLY. STRONG FIGURES
FOR THE SALMON FISHER WE HAD A
TWO THOUSAND SIX AND SALMON-CRASH. IT GREATLY AFFECTED OUR
COASTAL COMMERCIAL RECREATIONAL
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. AND WHAT
YOU SEE IN THE DATA
200-011-1213 FOURTEEN WAS THE
BEGINNING OF A REBOUND. BETTER
YEARS ACTUALLY END UP TECH OF
COURSE THAT REBOUND RAN
STRAIGHT INTO OUR LAST ROW
WHICH WAS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT.
INCLUDING FOR WHEN A RUN IN THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER. AND THEN AS
YOU COME OUT OF THAT DROUGHT
YOU SEE A POPULATION DECLINE
AGAIN IN THE DATA SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN. WHICH
YOU ACTUALLY SEE AS WE GET INTO
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
TWENTY UP. AND IN FACT I'LL
TALK ABOUT IN A MOMENT. A LOT
OF THE RETURNS TO OUR RIVERS
THIS YEAR ARE HIGHER. THAN
EXPECTED. BUT OF COURSE THIS
REBOUND HAS RUN INTO THE
CURRENT DROUGHT. AND I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE MAIN MESSAGES
I WOULD ONE UNDERSCORE WHAT
WORRIES ME GREATLY. IS OUR
SPECIES PARTICULARLY AQUATIC
DEPENDENT TRASH BUT THERE ARE
TERRESTRIAL AQUATIC SPECIES.
ARE LOSING THE ABILITY TO
RECOVER THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN
VERY ABILITY IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH OUR HYDRO GRASS BUT ALSO
OUR SPECIES HAD SPACE TO
RECOVER AND REBUILD. AND WHAT I
THINK MAY BE OCCURRING IS THAT
SPACE FOR RECOVERY TO REBALANCE
IS REALLY BEING DRAMATICALLY
ALTER. AND THIS IS WHERE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT BUT- THE
BROADER CONTEXT IN PLAY. DON'T
FORGET WHAT WE ARE LIVING FOR.
THIS IS NOT LIMITED TO
CALIFORNIA SOME ARE SUGGESTING
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A MEGA
DROUGHT WE NEVER LAST LEFT THE
LAST ROUTE. SOME HAVE SAID THE
CURRENT PERIOD OF DRYNESS IN
THE WEST. MAY EVENTUALLY RIVAL
THE DRYNESS OF THE INFAMOUS
SMALL. DROUGHT RIGHT NOW IS
AFFECTING 96% OF SEVEN WESTERN
STATES ARIZONA CALIFORNIA IDAHO
MONTANA NEVADA OREGON
WASHINGTON THAT'S THE HIGHEST
EVER COMBINED PERCENT SINCE
THEY'VE BEEN KEEPING THAT
METRIC. LAKE MEAD AND THE
COLORADO RIVER SYSTEM WHICH IS
THE NATION'S LARGEST RESERVOIR
IS JUST 35% OF CAPACITY WHICH
IS THE LOWEST LEVEL SINCE IT
WAS ORIGINALLY BUILT IN
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE. WE ALL IN
EARLY JULY JUST LIVED THROUGH A
SHE BLOOMED ACROSS THE ENTIRE
WEST. WHICH EXPERTS THIS
EXCEEDED THE STANDARD METHODS
OF EVALUATION. AND ALLOW
PORTLAND WAS A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN DEGREES AND IN THAT
SAME SPACE DEATH VALLEY IT ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY AGAIN WHICH
IS ARGUABLY THE HOTTEST
TEMPERATURE EVER RECORDED ON
THE PLANT. SURE YOU'VE LIVED
THERE WHILE FAR MUCH MORE
PERSONALLY AND DRAMATICALLY
THEN BE. AS YOU KNOW LAST YEAR.
WE FOUGHT FOR FIVE OF OUR
BIGGEST WILDFIRES AT THE SAME
TIME TO DO THIS YEAR WE'VE
ALREADY HAD MORE WILDFIRES THAN
LAST YEAR. SO THE STATISTIC
THAT MOSTLY HAS ALTERED MY OWN
MENTAL CAPACITY TO THINK ABOUT
THE SITUATION RANDY. IS
ACTUALLY RELATED TO A DIFFERENT
VARIABLE. THE DRYNESS OF OUR
STORE. WE ACTUALLY EXPERIENCE
SOMETHING WHICH I THINK IT'S
ACTIVELY WAS OUR SNOWPACK
VANISHING. OVER THE MONTHS OF
APRIL AND MAY. WE WENT INTO
APRIL ONE OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR
LOOKING AT THE DATA ACCUMULATED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES NEBRASKA AGING
NETWORK. THAT MOMENT THE SNOW
PACK IN THE SIERRA WAS WHAT
THEY CALL 59% OF OUR- BY MAY
ONE IT WAS 22% OF AVERAGE. BY
JUNE WANTED WAS ZERO. ALMOST
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE
FEET IN THAT TIME FRAME WHICH
IS N. AS PAUL ROGERS WROTE IN
THE MERCURY NEWS AT THE END OF
JUNE MORE THAN 40% OF THE WATER
THAT LOS ANGELES CITY USES IN A
YEAR. OF THAT IT WENT INTO THE
STORE THE STORE WAS SO DRY IT
NEVER MADE IT INTO OUR MAIN
RESERVOIRS. I THINK. HAVING
LIVED AND WORKED IN THE LAST
ROW. WHAT IS FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT RIGHT NOW IN THIS
EXPERIENCE. IS THE ROOT HEAD ET
AT WHICH THESE EXTREME EVENTS
ARE COMPOUNDING. CREATING
CASCADING AFFECTS A DOMINO
EFFECT WERE ONE EVENTS DRYNESS
IS CONTRIBUTING TO ANOTHER HE
WHICH IS CONTRIBUTING TO
ANOTHER DROUGHT. WHICH THE ROLL
UP OF ALL ARE PRODUCING THE
INABILITY TO SPACE FOR OUR
NATURAL SPECIES TO USE THEIR
RESILIENCY AND REBEL. SO HERE'S
WHAT I THINK WE'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW IN OUR DEPARTMENT ACROSS
WATER SHIFTS SUMMARIZE DOWN OIL
DOWN LAND LANGUAGE. WE SEE LOW
WATER FLOWS IN OUR RIVER AND
ARE CREATES. THOSE LOW FLOWS IN
TURN TRIGGER WARMER WATER
TEMPERATURES. THOSE WARMER
WATER TEMPERATURES INCREASED
DISTRESS THEY ALSO AMPLIFIED
THE RISK AND PREVALENCE OF
PATHOGENS AND DISEASE SPREAD.
THEY CONTRIBUTE TO ELEVATED
LEVELS OF JUVENILE SALMON
MORTALITY. THEY ARE CAUSING
ADULT RESPOND MORTALITY RATES
THAT ARE UNUSUAL. AND THIS IS
LIKELY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
INSTREAM AG LOS. SO WE LEARN
FROM ALL ASTRO. CURRENTLY
OBSERVING IMPACTS BUT THE
REALITY IS A FULL IMPACTS OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REALLY WON'T
BE REALIZED FOR ANOTHER TWO OR
THREE YEARS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
TESE FISH HAVE ABOUT A THREE
YEAR LIFECYCLE. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO TOUCH ON FISHING FOR JUST A
MOMENT WHICH IS ANOTHER. PART
OF OUR DEPARTMENT'S CORE
CONSTITUENCY. GENERALLY
SPEAKING OCEAN SALMON FISHERIES
BOTH SPORT AND COMMERCIAL. OUR
CONTINUING IS APPROVED BY THE
FEDERAL MANAGEMENT COUNCIL THE
PS AND MISSY BUT AS YOU KNOW
THOSE SEASONS ARE SHORTENED
MORE IN SOME PLACES ARE
NONEXISTENT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHICH IS PRIMARILY DUE TO
THE ALREADY LOW ABUNDANCE
FORECAST FOR KLAMATH RIVER FALL
RUN CHINOOK. SO AS AN EXAMPLE
BASICALLY NORTH OF FORT BRAGG
IN WHAT'S CALLED THE KLAMATH
MANAGEMENT'S ON THERE WILL BE
NO COMMERCIAL FISHING ALLOWED
IN TWENTY THREE ONE. WHAT'S
UNIQUE AND I ASK EVERYONE TO
REMEMBER IS WITHIN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS WEEK MASS. THERE ARE
ALSO MOMENTS OF BRIGHTER. NEWS
OR BETTER OUTLOOKS EVEN THOUGH
THERE IS RESTRICTED COMMERCIAL
OR RECREATIONAL FISHING. WHAT
WE'RE ALSO SEEING HAPPEN RIGHT
NOW IS FOR THOSE FISHERIES THAT
ARE OPEN. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CATCHES ARE AS GOOD
OR BETTER THAN THE PRE SEASON
PROJECTIONS SO FAR. AND IN FACT
WE HAVE AN UNUSUALLY HIGH
PROJECTION. FOR RETURNS OF
WINTER RUN THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
AND THAT'S PLAYING AL AS WE'RE
MAKING IN THE FIELD
OBSERVATIONS LOOKING AT. I ALSO
THINK THERE ARE OTHER BRIGHTER
MOMENTS. TO UNDERSCORE HERE WE
LEARNED A LOT FROM LAST ROW. DO
IN THE LEGISLATURE INVESTED IN
OUR DEPARTMENT WE SPENT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS COMING OUT
OF THE LAST ROW. TO IMPROVE OUR
HATCHERY INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL
WITH PASSAGE AT THE JUNE RISKS
WITHIN OUR OWN FACILITIES
REFURBISH AND MODERNIZE OUR
TRUCKING FLEETS. WE WILL LEARN
WHAT WATERSHED IN THE STATE MAY
TURN WORST. THIS MONITORING IN
COLLABORATION WITH ALMOST EVERY
INDIVIDUAL AND ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR PANELS TODAY. SO AS WE
WENT INTO THIS DROUGHT I THINK
WE HAVE BEEN MUCH BETTER
POSITION. HAVE MOVED MUCHFASTER FOR BETTER RESULTS AND
IN FACT YOUR STAFF SUMMARY. FOR
THIS COMMITTEE MEETING SAYS
QUOTE POSITIVE DEVELOPMENTS AN
IMPORTANT DROUGHT RESPONSES ARE
TAKING PLACE HERE ARE SOME OF
THOSE BEGIN WITH YOUR
LEADERSHIP CENTER VICE CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATURE. WITH GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAS RESULTED IN AN
INCREDIBLE INFUSION. OF MONEY
INTO MY DEPARTMENT ABOUT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS EMERGENCY FUNDS
RIGHT NOW TO SUPPORT FIFTY FIVE
POSITIONS TO ENGAGE RAPIDLY
DEALING WITH THIS DROUGHT. NINE
MILLION OF THAT WILL SUPPORT
TWENTY SIX POSITIONS
SPECIFICALLY FOR FISH RESCUE
AND STRESSOR MONITOR. ALMOST
ANOTHER TEN MILLION OF THAT IS
FOR ADDITIONAL HATCHERY
IMPROVEMENTS PURCHASING STATE
OF THE ART TANKER TRUCKS THIS
RESCUE UNITS UV SYSTEMS.
ANOTHER TWO MILLION OF THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR DROUGHT
RELATED PERMITTING TO GET
RESTORATION ANOTHER WATER
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS DONE FASTER.
ALMOST EIGHT MILLION IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR DEALING WITH
MODIFYING INSTREAM FLOW
REQUIREMENTS SEEING AS FARMERS
AND RANCHERS WERE FOR BEAR
THEIR WATER USE SO WE CAN
INCREASE STREAMFLOW. ALL KINDS
OF MINUTES ARE SIMULTANEOUSLY.
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE STATE
WATER BOARD HAVE MOVED FASTER.
WE ARE IN A SPACE TODAY THAT WE
WERE NOT IN LAST DROUGHT AND IT
CANNOT BE OVERLOOKED. OUR STATE
WATER BOARD IS ACTIVELY
PURSUING EMERGENCY REGULATIONS.
AND CURTAILMENTS OF WATER.
THAT'S HIS STORE THAT'S
CHALLENGING IT'S DIFFICULT IT'S
COMPLICATED A CONTROVERSY. MY
DEPARTMENT IS AS WE SPEAK
WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
THE WATER BOARD TO ESTABLISH
MINIMUM INSTREAM FLOWS FOR
SALMON AND MANY OTHER
WATERSHEDS THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY. WE SUBMITTED
FORMAL LETTERS TO THE WATER
BOARD REQUESTING A LONG TERM
SOLUTION FLOWS ON THE SCOTT AND
SHASTA RIVER IN THE KLAMATH
BASIN. THE WATER BOARD IS
LOOKING AT HER TALENTS FOR
WATER USERS AND THE UPPER
RUSSIAN RIVER SYSTEM.
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA.
THINGS THAT DID NOT OCCUR IN
ALASKA. LET ME TURN QUICKLY TO
A COUPLE OF THE SPECIFIC RIVERS
AND THEN GET OUT OF THE WAY.
THE KLAMATH RIVER. IS ONE OF
THE PLACES THAT I CARE ABOUT
THE MOST ON THE ENTIRE PLANET.
NOW WE'VE HAD SOME DIFFICULT
DYNAMICS IN THE MOST RECENT
WEEKS AND MONTHS. WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A VERY HIGH
CONCENTRATION OF A TWO KILLER
FISH DISEASE THAT WE
COLLOQUIALLY SHORTHAND S. C.
SHASTA. IT RESULTS IN HIGHER
THAN AVERAGE RATES OF DISEASE.
AND IT TRANSLATES INTO
INCREASED JUVENILE FISH KILLS.
WE HAD A DIFFICULT SEVERAL
WEEKS WORKING WITH THE RIVER
VALLEY TRIED. AND THE CREW
TRIED TO YOUR ROCK TRIED
COMMERCIAL FISHING AND OUR
FEDERAL AGENCY COUNTERPARTS BUT
MADE THE DIFFERENCE THE HARD
DECISION TO EVACUATE OUR HIGH
TREE ON THE KLAMATH RIVER FROM
THE FISH WE WERE RAISING. AND
MOVE THEM OVER TO OUR FACILITY
ON THE TRINITY RIVER. HOLD THEM
THERE WHILE WE HOPE FOR BETTER
RIVER CONDITIONS IN THE KLAMATH
FALLS TAKE THEM BACK AND IT'S-
IN THE SACRAMENTO RIVER. YES WE
HAVE LOW FLOWS BUT WE ALSO HAVE
RUN INTO. YET AGAIN THE
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGE AROUND THE
REDUCED VOLUME OF WATER IN
CALIFORNIA'S RESERVOIRS LATE TO
COLD WATER POOLS. WE ARE
SEEING. IN THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
WINTER RUN RETURN OF SALMON
WHICH IS GREATER THAN PREDICTED
THAT'S GOOD NEWS BUT THERE IS
ALSO WAY HIGHER THAN HISTORICAL
RESPOND MORTALITY OF FEMALES
HONORS. AND LET ME CLARIFY
SOMETHING WHERE I DISAGREE WITH
YOUR STOCK MODELS NUMBER NEED
TO CONCLUDE ABOUT THIRTY
SECONDS WE'LL COME BACK FOR
QUESTIONS PLEASE DESTRUCTOR
PRISONERS DID YOUR STAFF
ANALYSIS THAT IS SHOCKINGLY
THIS YEAR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. HAS DETERMINED THAT A
100% OF ENDANGERED WINTER RUN
CHINOOK SALMON JUVENILES ARE
LIKELY. TO PERISH IN THE RIVER
YOU TO EXCESSIVE TO THAT'S NOT
ACT. FIRST ALL WHAT WE HAVE
SAID AT THE STAFF LEVEL WHICH I
BELIEVE IS THE SOURCE OF
THE REPORTING. IS WE ARE MORE
LIKELY. TO HAVE. AN EARLIER
LOSS OF ABILITY TO PROVIDE COOL
WATER. AND THAT SUBSEQUENTLY IT
IS POSSIBLE. THAT NEARLY ALL OF
THE AND RIVER JUVENILES WILL
NOT SURVIVE THIS. WE HAVE SAID
THE COLD WATER WILL PROBLEM IS
LIKELY TO BECOME WORSE. WHICH
CREATES THE POSSIBILITY OF THAT
MORTALITY OF THAT WE HAVE NOT
COME OUT AND SAID. THAT THERE
IS A 1100% GUARANTEED CHANCE
ALL OF THESE FISH WILL BE LOST.
IT'S A GRIM SITUATION BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
ACCURATE- THIS SAME DYNAMIC IS
OCCURRING ACROSS COASTAL RIVERS
RUSSIAN RIVER IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE WHERE THE RIVER LEVELS.
ARE AS LOW AS THEY HAVE EVER
BEEN INCLUDING BACK IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. SO WHEN YOU
LOOK ACROSS THE STATE. ONE CAN
LEAVE THIS CONVERSATION
DEPRESSED DEJECTED- FOR
DESPAIR. IT KEPT ME UP LAST
NIGHT THINKING ABOUT TODAY IT
KEEPS ME UP MOST NIGHTS. BUT I
ALSO THINK WITHIN THIS PICTURE
IS THE ABILITY FOR US. TO SAVE
THE SITUATION TO ENSURE THESE
FISH PASS ON TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS LET ME IN THERE AND
I'LL WAIT FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
DIRECTOR WE'RE GONNA BE COMING
BACK FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE IN JUST A
FEW MOMENTS BUT WERE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
TURNING OVER TO EILEEN SO BACK.
MR BACK IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AS SHE
CAN BE MAKING HER FIRST
APPEARANCE AS A PANELIST BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE WE WELCOME HER AS
WELL AS THE STATE BOARD AND
MISSILE BLANK WILL BE PROVIDING
AN UPDATE ON THE STATE WATER
BOARDS REGULATORY ACTIONS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. THIS COTTON
SHASTA WATERSHEDS IN THE
RUSSIAN RIVER SYSTEM WITH A
FOCUS ON HOW THOSE ACTIONS WILL
IMPACT OUR CRITICAL SALMON
FISHERIES I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT- MADAM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TO IGNORE ALL OF YOUR
CHAIR CHAIR ASK ABOUT MR ASK
ABOUT HAS MADE HIMSELF READILY
AVAILABLE TO THOSE IN THE
RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED
ESPECIALLY UPPER RUSSIAN RIVER
WATERSHED. AT TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST IN THIS DIRE TIME- AND I
DID NOT WANT IT TO PASS A
SEDATE WITHOUT SEEKING HIM FOR
HIS DIRECT INVOLVEMENT
INSISTING COMMUNITIES AS WELL
AS THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO GET THROUGH
THIS THAT CHALLENGE THAT IS
CURRENTLY FACING US. MADAM
EXACT ADDRESS OR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE TEN MINUTES I'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
AND WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MISS CHAIR
AND- MISTER VICE CHAIR. CAN YOU
CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT YOU'RE
COMING IN LOUD AND CLEAR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR.
YOUR WARM WELCOME AND FOR YOUR
INVITATION AND I WILL PASS
ALONG YOUR REGARDS TO CHAIR
ESCOBAL. HE SENDS HIS. REGRETS
THAT HE AND I HAVE HAD MANY.
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THESE THESE
TOPICS AS YOU CAN IMAGINE AND
SO I. I HOPE I CAN. FIND
REFLECTING HIS HIS VIEWS ON
MANY OF THESE ISSUES AS WELL AS
THE REST AS WELL AS THE REST OF
OUR BOARD MEMBERS. I'M AND I
WANT TO THINK. DIRECTOR BONHAM
FOR HIS REMARKS- I THINK ONE
THING THAT IS HAS BEEN
REMARKABLE AND DURING THIS
DIFFICULT PERIOD IS THAT. ON
THE STATE. AGENCIES INCLUDING-
OUR TWO AGENCIES OF THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY CALLS
WE'VE ALL BEEN ON ALONG WITH-
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
THE RESOURCES AGENCY OVERALL-
ANOTHER OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE- WE ARE NOT MAKING
ANY OF THESE DECISIONS IN A
VACUUM WE ARE REALLY TRYING TO.
LEVERAGE ALL OF OUR RESOURCES-
AND OUR STATUTORY AND LET'S
JUST LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES ALONG WITH THE- OF.
THE DOLLARS- APPROPRIATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE SPECIFICALLY
FOR DROUGHT FOR OUR PROGRAMS
GENERALLY TO GIVE WHAT WE HOPE
IS THAT. THE MOST ROBUST AND
RESPONSE TO THIS DROUGHT THAT
WE POSSIBLY CAN. SO I DO WANNA-
ONCE THE MOST MY TIME
ELABORATING ON WHAT WHAT THE
STATE WATER BOARD IS WORKING ON
WHAT EMERGENCY ACTIONS WE ARE
TAKING- THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE
WE HOPE SOME- BENEFICIAL
EFFECTS TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS
OF DROUGHT ON ON OUR FISH
SPECIES- WE ARE TAKING AS A
DIRECTOR BONHAM AND MENTIONED-
UNPRECEDENTED REGULATORY STEP
STEPS- AND ALSO WORKING IN
LOOKING FOR CREATIVE I'M
VOLUNTARY SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WORK MORE
FACED WITH- INSTRUCTABLE. I'M
NOTED IT'S NOT JUST CALIFORNIA
IT'S THE ENTIRE WEST- THAT IS-
IS BEING RAPIDLY DEVELOPING
EXTREME HYDROLOGICAL CONDITIONS
IN THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
WATERSHED WE'RE NOW IN THE
THIRD DRIEST YEAR IN THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS. THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WATER YEAR WAS THE
SECOND DRIEST TWO YEAR PERIOD
ON ON RECORD AND WE'RE
EXPERIENCING THE DRIEST
CONDITIONS SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN- IN ADDITION- HAS
ALSO NOTED BY DIRECTOR BOND
AND- THIS SPRING THE SACRAMENTO
SOUTHERN AMERICAN RIVER
WATERSHEDS. WHICH FEED THE
MAJOR- NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESERVOIRS AN EXPERIENCED AN
ACCELERATED RATE OF SNOW MELT
AND ON AN UNPRECEDENTED- OUR
MOTION BY SOILS AND RATHER THAN
FILLING. RESERVOIRS AND AS
PREDICTED SO THESE AND OTHER
FACTORS REDUCED WATER SUPPLIES
FOR TWO MAJOR- STATE AND
FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS BY NEAR
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRE FEET WHICH IS ENOUGH WATER
TO SUPPLY MORE THAN ONE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS FOR A YEAR. SO THIS
WAS A- DRAMATIC. PASSED CHANGES
IN ANTICIPATED- CONDITIONS- AND
AS YOU'VE NOTICED- ARE AT S. AS
OTHERS HAD NOTICED NOTED- IN
THE KLAMATH BASIN- INCLUDING
THE SCOTT SHASTA RIVER-
TRIBUTARIES AND WATERSHEDS.
WHERE THE RIVERS AND SURFACE
WATERS ARE CRITICAL SOURCES OF
WATER FOR. ECONOMIC ECOLOGICAL
AND CULTURAL PURPOSES OF
PRECIPITATION LEVELS ARE HALF
OF NORMAL ACROSS MUCH OF THAT
BASIN THE SCOTT IS EXPERIENCING
ONE OF THE FOUR DRIEST YEARS ON
RECORD WITH FLOWS IN THE LOWEST
5% OF THE HISTORICAL RECORD IN
THE SHASTA THE CURRENT WATER
YEAR IS THE DRIEST ON RECORD
FOR THE RIVER. WHICH IS WITH
FLOWS IN THE LOWEST 1% OF
HISTORICAL RECORDS. THE RUSSIAN
RIVER ANOTHER CRITICAL
WATERSHED THAT IT HAS
EXPERIENCED THE LOWS
PRECIPITATION AMOUNTS AND
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS- LEADING
TO THE LOWEST- STORAGE LEVEL
EVER EXPERIENCED FOR THIS TIME
OF YEAR LAKE MENDOCINO AND LIKE
CINEMA- WHICH PROVIDES CRITICAL
SUPPLIES OF DRINKING WATER FOR
OVER SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND FLOWS FOR
THREATENED AND ENDANGERED FISH.
LAKE MENDOCINO WAS AT RISK FOR
DRAINING COMPLETELY BY THE END
OF THE YEAR- IS THE CURRENT DRY
CONDITIONS- PERSIST WITHOUT
ACTION TAKEN BY. THE WATER. SO
I THINK THAT SUMMER SHOWS THAT
WE'RE FACING SUBSTANTIAL WATER
SUPPLY AND ECOSYSTEM
CHALLENGES. AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT THAT SUCH CONDITIONS CAN
RESULT IN DEGRADED WATER
QUALITY SETBACKS TO BUMP BONOBO
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES. IN
ADDITION TO SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS
ON TRIBAL COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL SALMON FISHERIES
AND DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS TODAY
TO THE ECOSYSTEM. SO IN
RESPONSE TO THESE CONDITIONS.
IN APRIL- GOVERNOR NEWSOM
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
IN MENDOCINO AND SONOMA COUNTY
COUNTIES DUE TO DROUGHT
CONDITIONS IN THE RUSSIAN RIVER
WATERSHED. AND SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO ENABLE-
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO INCREASE
THE STATE'S DROUGHT RESILIENCE
AND TO PREPARE FOR. CURRENT AND
CONTINUE DROUGHT CONDITIONS THE
GOVERNOR SUBSEQUENTLY EXPANDED
THIS PROCLAMATION TO INCLUDE
THE KLAMATH RIVER SACRAMENTO
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA AND TULARE
LAKE WATERSHEDS AND IN JULY THE
GOVERNOR ADDED NINE COUNTIES TO
THE PROCLAMATION WHICH NOW
COVERS. FIFTY TO FIFTY OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
IN THOSE IN THOSE PROCLAMATIONS
OF THE GOVERNOR TASKED. UNDER
BOARD DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT FISHING
WILDLIFE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO WORK
WITH REGIONAL AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- INCLUDING
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES AND CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES. TO COORDINATE
ACTIONS AND BETTER RESPOND TO
OUR PEOPLE NATURAL RESOURCES IN
OUR COMMUNITY. SO GOING INTO A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL IN THE
ACTIONS THAT THE STATE WATER
BOARD. IS HAS OR IS CURRENTLY
UNDERTAKING WHICH YOUR INSIGHT
DESIGNED IN PART. TO ADDRESS
THE EFFECTS OF DROUGHT ON FISH-
WE STARTED- BY ISSUING EARLY.
WARNING NOTICES AND MARCH TO
APPROXIMATELY FORTY THOUSAND
WATER RIGHT HOLDERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE URGING THEM TO PLAN
FOR POTENTIAL SHORTAGES- BY
REDUCING WATER USE IN ADOPTING
PRACTICAL CONSERVATION MEASURES.
THEN IN JUNE WE ALSO SENT
NOTICES ON THE BALLOT
UNAVAILABILITY TO WATER RIGHT
HOLDERS IN THE DELTA THE
RUSSIAN RIVER AND THE SCOTT
RIVER WATERSHED. IN RECENT
MONTHS THE BOARD HAS HELD
PUBLIC DRUG WORKSHOPS ON
VARIOUS TOPICS INCLUDING WATER
DEMAND DATA WATER SUPPLY
VISUALIZATION TOOLS WATER
UNAVAILABILITY UNAVAILABILITY
METHODOLOGY AND PROPOSED
AMERICAN EMERGENCY CURTAILMENT
REGULATIONS. LET ME TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THOSE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF THOSE ACTIONS- IN
VARIOUS STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT
OR IMPLEMENTATION- IN THE
FIRST- ADDRESSED. THE CRISIS ON
THE RUSSIAN RIVER OF THE STATE
WATER BOARD ADOPTED AN
EMERGENCY REGULATION IN JUNE.
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE BOARD TO
CURTAIL WATER RIGHT DIVERSIONS
IN THE RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED.
THIS STORY WILL SAFEGUARD
STORMWATER WHEN CERTAIN
THRESHOLDS- IN THE RESERVOIRS
ARE REACHED. THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO PROTECT DRINKING
WATER AND FISHERIES. ON THE
BOARD ALSO APPROVED A TEMPORARY
URGENCY CHANGE- TO MODIFY
REQUIREMENTS FOR FISHERIES AND
IN LIKE. LIKE MENDOCINO LAKE-
CINEMA TO PROTECT THE STORM
WATER LEVELS. WE IN THE BAY
DELTA WATERSHED WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION- AND ALL OF OUR
SISTER AGENCIES TO PROTECT-
THIS MUCH WATER STORAGE IN OUR
CRITICAL RESERVOIRS AS POSSIBLE
AND COLD WATER SUPPLY IN SHASTA
RESERVOIR. THE BOARD ALSO
ISSUED A TEMPORARY ABOUT
RELAXATION OF WATER QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE STATE AND
FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS- AN
EXPEDITED- CONSTRUCTION ADDRESS
SALINITY INTRUSION BARRIER IN
THE DELTA TO HELP THEM MAINTAIN
A STRING STORAGE LEVELS
SALINITY CONTROL. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY JUST THIS PAST-
FRIDAY THE BOARD ISSUED THE
DRAFT- EMERGENCY CURTAILMENT
REGULATIONS- FOR THAT THEY
DON'T TO WATERSHED- AN
ADDITIONAL WATER NOTICES OF
WATER UNAVAILABILITY OF THOSE
DROPPED EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
ARE NOW OPEN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A PUBLIC
WORKSHOP THIS AFTERNOON. AND
THOSE REGULATIONS WILL BE
CONSIDERED FOR ADOPTION BY THE
BY THE BOARD ON AUGUST THIRD.
WITH REGARD TO THE KLAMATH
WATERSHED IN THE SCOTT SHASTA.
THE STATE WATER BOARD IS ON OUR
STAFF HAS HELD A PUBLIC MEETING
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION AND TO
SOLICIT INPUT ON POTENTIAL.
DROUGHT VOLUNTARY AND
REGULATORY OPTIONS THAT COULD
BE IMPLEMENTED IN SCOTT SHASTA
WATERSHEDS AND AN INFORMAL
DRAFT EMERGENCY REGULATION
WHICH INCORPORATES THE MINIMUM
FLOW REQUIREMENT RECOMMENDED
BY- INEFFICIENT AND WILDLIFE AS
NOTED BY DR BONHAM- THAT WAS
RELEASED FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
JULY SIXTEENTH- IN THE COMING
PERIOD- JUST CLOSE THIS PAST
FRIDAY. WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE
BOARD WILL ACT ON TIME AND
CONSIDER THESE EMERGENCY
MEASURES EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
SOMETIME IN AUGUST AND THEN
LASTLY AND ALL THREE OF THESE
EMERGENCY- CURTAILMENT
REGULATIONS EITHER BEING
ADOPTED OR CONSIDERED- HAS
STRICTER BONTA NOTED- OUR OUR
PRESIDENTIAL AND THEY WERE
ACTIONS THAT WERE NOT TAKEN
DURING THE LAST DROUGHT. AND WE
ARE TRYING TO MOVE AS QUICKLY
AS OUR EMERGENCY PROCEDURES I'M
ALLOW WELL ALSO AND TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS ADEQUATE
TIME FOR- FOR. PUBLIC INPUT-
BECAUSE WE DON'T TAKE THESE
ACTIONS LATELY CURTAILING- AND-
THE GOAL WATER RATES WITH THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE IN TOWN FOR
ENTITLED PARTIES TO DIVERT AND
USE- USE THEIR WATER RIGHTS IS
HIS- A DIFFICULT DECISION TO
MAKE- AND- WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE IN
MAKING THOSE DETERMINATIONS.
ANOTHER ELEMENT OF OUR
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS IS THAT
WE'RE REQUIRING WATER USERS TO
REPORT ON THE PAST AND FUTURE
AND TO FORECAST THEIR FUTURE
WATER USE- THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT INFORMATION GAP
THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO FILL
HERE WHICH WILL ALLOW- ALLOW US
TO IMPROVE OUR PREDICTIONS AND
TO MANAGE- SUPPLIES THROUGHOUT
THE ON GOING DROUGHT. ON SHOULD
IT- CONTINUES NOT JUST THROUGH
THIS YEAR BUT IN TWO YEARS
BEYOND. TWO MINUTES- THE
BOARD'S ADOPTION OF THESE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS ARE MEANT
TO SAFEGUARD THE DRINKING WATER
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE. SUPPLY FOR OVER
THREE MILLION DOLLARS OF YOUR
GET IT FARM FARMLAND. AND TO.
PROTECT AGAINST THE LOSS OF
STORAGE AND SUPPLY THAT
THREATENS SALMON SPECIES AND
CRITICAL ECOSYSTEMS. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD. WE DO
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR EVEN
EARLIER PLANNING AND ACTION ON
BETTER TOOLS AND INFORMATION
WE'VE ALSO RECEIVED ON TIME
FUNDING IN IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET FOR. IMPROVING OUR
COLLECTION AND MANAGEMENT AND
USE OF- WATER RIGHTS DATA WE
ALL NEED TO I'M- TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ARE
CONSERVATIVE ASSUMPTIONS THAT
WE USE IN MAKING PREDICTIONS TO
REGARDING MANAGEMENT OPERATIONS
HAVE NOT BEEN- CONSERVATIVE
ENOUGH. TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
DROUGHT SITUATIONS I'M IN THE
RAPID CHANGES IN HYDROLOGY THAT
WE ARE FACING BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. WE AT THE BOARD
ARE OPEN TO SUGGESTIONS AND
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
FIND THE BEST VOLUNTARY AND
REGULATORY OPTIONS AVAILABLE.
TO PROTECT FISH AND THEIR
HABITAT ANOTHER CRITICAL
BENEFICIAL USES OF WATER AND I
WILL STOP THEIR STELLAR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WE'RE GRATEFUL HERE
WITH US TODAY WHAT WE LIKE TO
DO FOR THE DIRECTOR OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE THE EXECUTOR IS ACTIVE
DIRECTED STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN UP. FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TODAY
TO SEE IF THE VICE CHAIR. HAS
ANY ITEMS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
ADVANCE OUR- I WOULD DIRECT
BOTTOM LINE LIKE TO EXPLORE
THAT COMMENT THAT YOU MADE
ABOUT THE JUVENILE FISH IN THE
SACRAMENTO. AND THE- CERTAINTY
WHETHER OR NOT THAT THERE YOU
ARE EXPECTING A DIE OFTEN IN
YOUR SAID THE YOU DISAGREE WITH
STATUS RCOMMENDATION BUT
CLEARLY. GIVEN LOW FLOWS AND
LOW FLOWS AND SLOWER FLOWS
DEFINITELY MEAN WARMER WATER
WHICH ARE DANGEROUS TO THE
JUVENILE CENTER THERE WILL WHAT
IS. I KNOW THIS IS A DIFFICULT
QUESTION AND SIR. WHAT IS WHAT
ARE YOU EXPECTING. TO SEE
WHAT'S MOST LIKELY TO HAPPEN IN
THIS RIVER SYSTEM. THEN WITH
THE THIS RUN OF CHINOOK AND
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
THEY ARECURRENTLY FINDING WITH
SUCH LOW FLOWS IN THE- THE
SITUATION IN THE RIVER. THANK
YOU VICE CHAIRMAN AGAIN. FOR
THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE I
REFERRED TO AND THE STAFF
ANALYSIS. WAS THE ASSERTION
THAT OUR DEPARTMENT HAS
DETERMINED THAT A 100% OF THESE
PARTICULAR SALMON JUVENILES ARE
LIKELY TO PERISH. YEAH I DID
AND I'M I'M NOT QUIBBLING THE
DIFFERENCES HERE BUT I'M JUST
TRYING TO SEE WHAT YOU THINK
WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT FEELS IS
THE MOST LIKELY. SCENARIO AND
I'M I'M I'M ANSWERING I REALIZE
I'M A SLOW TALKER. AND I THINK
THAT REFERENCE BY STAFF IS TO
OUR TECHNICAL STAFF- HAVING
CONCLUDED. IN AN EXCEL
SPREADSHEET WHICH IS A DATABASE
SHARED AMONGST ALL THE MANAGERS.
THAT WHAT IS SLIGHTLY. IS R.
ONE. AN EARLIER LOSS OF THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE COOL WATER
SO WE THINK THAT'S LIKELY. AND
THAT EARLIER LOSS OF YOU KNOW
MANAGING COOL WATER MAKES IT
POSSIBLE. WE MAY FACE- WELL YOU
KNOW I'M- NEARLY ALL OF LOS SO
IT'S NOT AN EVENTUALITY IT'S A
POSSIBILITY. FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
IN PUBLIC FORUM WE'VE ALSO BEEN
NOTING. THAT THE STATISTICAL
MODELING WE ARE RUNNING WITH
OUR FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS IT-
NATIONAL REVIEW FISHERIES
SERVICE SOUTHWEST SCIENCE
CENTER. IS PREDICTING. THE
POTENTIAL FOR AN 80% PLUS
WHAT'S CALLED TEMPERATURE
DEPENDENT MORTALITY LOSS SO
VICE CHAIR I'M NOT TELLING YOU
WE'RE SAYING IT'S A 100% LOS
IT'S GUARANTEED IT'S A 100%
LOSS I THINK WE'RE IN THE SPACE
OF A VERY SIGNIFICANT
SUBSTANTIAL LOSS TO RISK. AND
IT RELATES TO THIS DYNAMIC
AROUND LOW FLOW TEMPERATURE IN
COLD WATER. ALSO SAY THAT WE
HEARD FRAMING EARLIER AND I'VE
SEEN IT REPORTED ELSEWHERE.
THAT THIS IS LARGELY DRIVEN BY
MANAGEMENT POLICIES ADOPTED BY
THE LAST FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION.
THE CHAIRMAN MENTIONED IN HIS
REMARKS THAT DAN ATTORNEY
GENERAL BECERRA DID TO. THE
PRIOR FEDERAL MINISTRATION
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT OF
CALIFORNIA SUED GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S ADMINISTRATION THROUGH
ITS- MARMARA PROTECTION AGENCY
AND ITS NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY OUR LEAD AGAINST.
CATALYTIC ISSUE WAS BROUGHT IN
PART BECAUSE OF OUR JUDGMENT OF
THE SALMON PROTECTIONS IN THE
FEDERAL APPROACH WERE
INSUFFICIENT. ALSO REMIND FOLKS
THAT I THINK YES. LAST WEEK
MAYBE TEN DAYS AGO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID TELL THE FEDERAL
COURT QUOTE. RECLAMATION WHICH
IS THE NEAREST OF RECLAMATION
QUOTE HAS COMMITTED TO RE
INITIATE CONSULTATION UNDER THE
FEDERAL ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT.
ON THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS BY OCTOBER
ONE. OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH
WILL RESULT IN NEW OR AMENDED
BIOLOGICAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU
MISTER DIRECTOR MISTER DIRECTOR
I JUST HAVE A FEW ITEMS IN IN
LOOK I DON'T WANT TO TILT AT
WINDMILLS ON THIS BUT- BACK IN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN WE
HAD- THE LAST DROUGHT- AND
NINETY FIVE PERCENT. OF WINTER
RUN SALMON- DIED ON THE
SACRAMENTO. IN IN YOUR OWN
DEPARTMENT AND AGAIN I THINK
WELL. MAYBE I WAS STATE MORE-
BOLDLY AT THIS POINT BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU'RE STILL LOOKING AT
WANTING TO BE A TO CONFIRM THE
NUMBERS TO YOUR OWN DEPARTMENT
TOLD SEEN IN LAST WEEK THAT
THERE AND QUOTE AND- THERE
COULD BE A NEAR CUP COMPLETE
CALL COMPLETE LOSS OF THE YOUNG
ENDANGERED SPECIES OF SALMON
BECAUSE TEMPERATURES ABOVE A
HUNDRED DEGREES. FOR EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME. ARE
OVERHEATING THE RIVER MAKING IT
UNINHABITABLE FOR THE FISH TO
GROW BEYOND THE EGG STAGE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE CONFIRMED TO CNN.
SO LOOK WE CAN. ADD TO IT HAVE
THE NASCENT MACHINATIONS HERE
TODAY BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS. IN A DROUGHT THAT WAS NOT
AS SEVERE AS WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW WE HAD A 95% DIE OFF. AND I
GET THAT. MAYBE WE DON'T WANT
TO CONFIRM THAT NOW. BUT THE
FEDS ARE THE SAME THERE'S GOING
TO BE AN 80% WE KNOW THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE WORSE YOUR OWN
DEPARTMENT IS SAYING IT IS
GOING TO BE A NEAR COMPLETE
LOSS- AND- IT IS. IN PART AS
YOU SAID CLIMATE CHANGE BUT
IT'S ALSO IN PART THAT WE STILL
HAVE THE HOLDOVER. WATER POLICY
FROM THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WHERE WE HAVE LITERALLY PUT THE
PEDAL TO THE METAL. RELEASE OUR
COLD WATER STORAGE. RIGHT DOWN
TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND NOW
WE ARE IN A WORSE WATER.
CONDITION YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND WE WERE IN FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN. IN THE SUPPLY SIMPLY
IS NOT THERE TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
THOSE JUVENILE SALMON. FOR FROM
DYING OFF AND THAT'S JUST NOT I
SEEN THAT THAT'S- ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE FOCUSING ON FISHERIES
AND AQUACULTURE AND THAT'S A
100% OF WHAT THEY DO. AT THE
COLD WATER POOL IN LAKE SHASTA
SIMPLY ISN'T GOING TO BE THERE
THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF THAT
FEDERAL POLICY. I THAT AGAIN
HAS THE FEDS. THIS CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION IT'S CARRIED
OVER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
POLICY AND PUT THE PEDAL TO
METAL TO GET THAT. WATER DOWN
TO THE CENTER VALLEY RATHER
THAN FINDING THAT BALANCE
BETWEEN FISHERIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL AS FARMERS
AND RANCHERS. SO MISTER MISTER
DIRECTOR LET YOU COMMENT ON
THAT BUT I THINK WE MAY BE
SAYING THE SAME THING IN AB I.
HAVE MY SKI A LITTLE FOR YOURS
AT THIS POINT BUT- UNDERSTAND.
THAT THERE IS NO WAY THAT THIS
YEAR ISN'T GOING TO BE WORSE
THAN IT WAS IN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
WE SIGNED 95% DIE OFF. IT LOOKS
CENTER I AGREE WITH YOU ON.
MANY RESPECTS. AND I DON'T MEAN
TO ARGUE. THESE SEEMINGLY
BIZARRE NUANCES. I PERSONALLY
IN OUR DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN
HITTING THE BALL HERE. WE THINK
THIS IS A SUPER SERIOUS AND
BLEAK SITUATION FOR SALMON
ACROSS THE STATE. IN PARTICULAR
IN THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
RELATIVE TO WIN OR RUN. ALSO
FALL RUN. WE'VE BEEN OPEN ABOUT
THAT FOR SEVERAL MONTHS. IN
MANY PUBLIC VENUES AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
RISK OF LOSS IN THIS DYNAMIC OF
THOSE FINISHES LIFECYCLE-
WHETHER IT'S 80% 90% R. PERCENT.
ANY OF THOSE PERCENTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT FOR THESE FISH IN
PART. BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T HAD
THAT FULL OPPORTUNITY TO
REBOUND AS I WAS DISCUSSING IN
MY OPENING REMARKS SO I'M
WORRIED. I THINK WE HAVE A
SIMILAR SITUATION ON THE
AMERICAN RIVER I THINK WE HAVE
A SIMILAR SITUATION ON THE
KLAMATH. I'M ALSO MORE WORRIED
TO BE HONEST. AS WE HEAD INTO
NEXT YEAR. OUR STANDARD METHODS
OF EVALUATION AREN'T KEEPING UP
WITH. THESE CASCADING CLIMATE
EFFECTS SO I AM VERY FOCUSED ON.
NOT ONLY WHAT I CAN DO TO
MEDICAID AS AN EXAMPLE WE
SUCCESSFULLY MOVE SEVENTEEN
MILLION SALMON FISH. AT OUR
CENTRAL VALLEY HATCHERIES DOWN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY SAN PABLO
DAY COASTAL MET PENS WITH A
PRETTY HIGH SUCCESS RATE SO FAR.
THAT'S A MITIGATING ACTION I'M
FOCUSED ON THAT FOR THE COMING
DAYS AND WEEKS WE JUST HAVE
RESCUED I THINK ALMOST THREE
THOUSAND COHO IN THE RUSSIAN
RIVER WATERSHED ANOTHER
MITIGATING EXAMPLE. BUT I'M
ALSO VERY MUCH STARTING TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE GET TO OCTOBER ONE OF THIS
COMING YEAR. AND WHAT IS IT'S
AS DRY OR DRIER THAN THIS
CURRENT YEAR. AND THESE ARE
GONNA BE SUPER EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS UNDER THOSE
SCENARIOS. THAT'S WHY MY
DEPARTMENT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES IN THE STATE
PERMIT FOR THE STATE WATER
PROJECT HAS MUCH MORE SPECIFIC
SALMON TRIGGERS THAT ARE MORE
PROTECTIVE. OR THE SALMON RUNS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
TRUMP OPINION APPROACH TO
SALMON UNDER THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN OPINION. AND I AND I
GOTTA SAY INDIA WITH FULL
DISCLOSURE. DIRECTOR BONHAM WE
OWE HIM CREDIT FOR MOVING ON.
MOVING IT TO GET THE FISH
EITHER KEEPING FISHING
HATCHERIES OR MOVING FISH
AROUND TO ENSURE THE LONG TERM
LONGEVITY OF THE SPECIES I'M
NOT. DISPUTING THAT AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THANK YOU TO
DIRECTOR BONHAM AND CALIFORNIA
PARDON FISH AND WILDLIFE I
GUESS MY PIECES THIS FOR US NOT
TO COME TO CONCLUSION THAT THIS
YEAR IS GOING TO BE WORSE THAN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN WHERE WE SAW
95% DIE OFF. IN BECAUSE WE MAY
FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT SAYING
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
ME WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS EVEN IF
THOSE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN-
SALMON MAKE IT BACK UP THE
SPONDYLUS EGGS ARE GONNA BE
COOKED BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THAT COLD WATER POOL. AND
THAT'S WHY I AM DEEPLY
CONCERNED BOTH ON THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WATER POLICY
THAT IS A HOLDOVER NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO WE HAVE A WORST
DROUGHT IN THE NUMBER THREE
MMHM WE HAVE THE CLIMATE
IMPACTS OF THE DIRECTOR SPOKE
INCREDIBLY ELOQUENT. ON SO
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE DIRECTOR CHUCK
BONHAM FOR TAKING EMERGENCY
ACTION TO TRUCK ALL STATE
HATCHERY S. SALMON. THIS YEAR
BECAUSE RELEASING THEM INTO THE
RIVERS WOULD HAVE MOST LIKELY
MEANT 1100% MORTALITY IN ME
SENATOR YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE GLIMMER OF HOPE SO INNOCENT
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
SACRAMENTO. THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER DYNAMIC. OF ALL OF
THEM. SO OUR DEPARTMENT IN THE
STATE YOUR LEADERSHIP WE HAVE
FUNDED A LOT OF. REMOVAL OF
BARRIERS. AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
FISH PASSAGE AND WHAT'S CALLED
BATTLE CREEK. IS A TRIBUTARY TO
THE UPPER SACRAMENTO. AND WE
HAVE RELEASED JUVENILE WINNER
RUN INTO BATTLE CREEK AFTER ALL
OF THAT WORK. AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN BATTLE CREEK LAST
YEAR. THIS YEAR'S WE'RE GETTING
RETURNING CHINOOK ADULTS OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. AND
WE'RE ALMOST DONE WITH FULL
BARRIER REMOVAL AND THEN
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY SURRENDERS THEIR HYDRO
LICENSE AND BATTLE CREEK IS ON
THE BRINK OF BECOMING A LISTS
FREE FLOWING STREAM. IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE UPPER
SACRAMENTO WHY IS THAT
IMPORTANT. IT IS A CORE
POTENTIAL REFUGIA FOR WINTER
RUN AND SPRING RUN TO MAKE A
HOME IN A PLACE WHERE THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO COOL COLD WATER. AND
GET OUT OF THAT STRETCH OF THE
UPPER SACRAMENTO AND ALL ME
LITERALLY GET OUT WE NEED TO
MANAGE THAT AS WELL. BUT HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL HABITAT RESOURCE
FOR THE SPANISH WE ARE NOT
GOING TO GET THE RECOVERY WILL
REBOUND UNLESS WE'RE DEALING
WITH THESE DIFFICULT WATER
MANAGEMENT ISSUES. THIS UPPER
SACRAMENTO DYNAMIC BUT ALSO
DOING THINGS LIKE BATTLE CREEK
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
ALSO TRYING TO DO IN THE
KLAMATH. GIVING FISH ACCESS TO
COOL COLD HABITAT OUT OF THE
HOT CENTRAL VALLEY RIVERS IS
ITSELF THE SALMON RESILIENCY
CLIMATE ADAPTATION STRATEGY. SO
IT'S GRAHAM I AGREE WITH YOU
I'M NOT READY TO CALL IT AS BAD
AS LAST DROUGHT IT MAY BE AND
I'M WILLING TO SAY THAT. I'D
LIKE TO SEE THE DATA WHEN WE'RE
DONE WE COULD BE IN THAT SAME
OR WORSE STATISTICAL SITUATION.
BUT THEIR WITNESS MOMENTS OF
HOPE LIKE BATTLE CREEK. THANK
YOU MISTER I'M GONNA TO THE
EXIT DIRECTOR THAT MADAM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE FEDERAL BUREAU
OF RECLAMATION'S WATER POLICY
FOR A MOMENT. FISHERY
BIOLOGISTS AND SCIENTISTS SAY
THAT THAT HOLD OVER FEDERAL
WATER POLICY IS BAD FOR FISH IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT IN THE CONCERN IS THAT
THE FISH KILLS CAN BE WORSE
WHETHER IT'S JUVENILE FORM OR
COOKING THE EGGS THAT ARE IN
THAT OVER HEATED WATER
ESPECIALLY IN THE SACRAMENTO.
RIVER CAN YOU GIVE US YOUR
THOUGHTS THE BOARD STOCK ON.
THE PLAN TO BE ABLE TO WHETHER
IT'S TO CHALLENGE THIS FEDERAL
POLICY IN DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
IT'S MAKING IT WORSE. FOR THOSE
ALREADY IMPAIRED WATERSHEDS. HI
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I HAVING- THE REVISED
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS DURING THE
LAST ADMINISTRATION- CERTAINLY-
CHANGED THE COACH UNDER THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT- IN THE
WAY THE FEDERAL PROJECTS WERE
WERE MANAGED ON ON ON THE OTHER
HAND WE HAVE CONTINUED TO HAVE
A DIALOGUE WITH THE BUREAU-
THEY DO- COME WITHIN THE
REGULATORY PURVIEW. THE BOARD-
IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES AND-
WE HAVE OUR OWN- STATE- LAWS
AND REGULATIONS SOME OF THEM
ADMINISTERED BY- DR BONHAM AND
SOME OF THEM ADMINISTERED BY
THE BOARD AND WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO USE THOSE STORIES
TO APPROPRIATELY- CONDITION-
THE BUREAU'S- WATER RIGHTS. AND
WE WORKS THIS YEAR VERY
CAREFULLY WITH US- WITH THE
BUREAU AND ALSO WITH OUR STATE
PARTNERS BECAUSE THE STATE AND
FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS AND- ARE
OPERATED IN VERY CLOSE
COORDINATION AND WE- THE BOARD.
FELT THAT IT DID THAT THE BEST
THAT IT COULD I'M WORKING WITH
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION AND- NEW
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION OF BOTH
ON THE WILDLIFE AGENCIES AND
THE BUREAU- TO COME UP WITH
WITH WHAT IT- WHAT WOULD BE A-
NON. INAPPROPRIATE CARRYOVER
TARGET THAT OUT SHASTA TO
PROVIDE. THEM SOURCE OF COLD
WATER THAT WOULD BENEFIT FISH
AND ALSO CARRY OVER STORAGE FOR
NEXT YEAR- AND- IN CASE IT WORK
WAS ALSO A DRYER CRITICALLY
DRY- HERE AND- WE ARE HAVE AND
WE'VE BEEN SOMEWHAT
DISAPPOINTED- THAT AGAIN THE
PREDICTIONS ABOUT- OPERATIONS
AND DRY CONDITIONS HAVE BEEN
EVEN WORSE THAN OUR
CONSERVATIVE PREDICTIONS BUT-
WE DID WORK IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH ALL OF THE
STATE AGENCIES AND THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES- UNDER THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION SO AGAIN WE OF
COURSE ARE WORKING WITH THAT
THE LEGACY FROM THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION IT TAKES A LOT
TO TRANSITION. BUT I THINK THAT
WE- HOW TO POSITIVE SEVEN
INTERACTIONS AND WHEN HE- YOU
KNOW LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED-
CONTINUE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE BUREAU- WHEN
CONSULTATIONS ARE. INITIATED
THE SMALL. MAKING AN EXECUTOR
LOOK AT MANAGING DIRECTOR NOW
I'M NOT GONNA PUT WORDS INTO
HER MOUTH WHATSOEVER AND I'M
JUST GONNA SAY. MY OWN OPINION
AND I THINK THE OPINION OF.
BIOLOGISTS AND SCIENTISTS
AROUND- WHO ARE FOCUSED ON THE
SURVIVAL OF THE SPECIES THE
CURRENT BIOLOGICAL OPINION.
THAT IS GOOD FOR AGRICULTURE
BAD FOR FISHING BAD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT JUST BEING CANDID
ABOUT IT. AND IF WE WERE
SERIOUS. ABOUT BRINGING BALANCE
BACK TO THOSE MOST IMPAIRED
WATERSHEDS WE LOOK BACK TO THAT
TWO THOUSAND NINE BIOLOGICAL
PENNY THAT WAS IN PLACE- THAT
WAS SET ASIDE RAMROD- IN WITH A
NEW POLICY THAT WAS FROM THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION RAM
ROUTED THROUGH. THAT MADE IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR THIS
SPECIES TO BETTER SURVIVE A
PRETTY BAD YEAR. LET ALONE IN
DIRE YEAR IN WHICH WERE SEEN SO
I UNDERSTAND THAT- THE BOARD IS
IN A VERY. CHALLENGING POSITION
IN NEEDING TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND AGAIN I CAN'T
SAY ENOUGH GOOD THINGS. ABOUT
YOUR ASK ABOUT WHO'S MADE
HIMSELF AVAILABLE MORNING NOON
AND NIGHT FOR COMMUNITIES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS FOR
AGRICULTURAL GROUPS ACTIVE HERE
TO MEET WITH TO TRY TO FIND A
BALANCE BUT- AS LONG AS WE HAVE
THIS. DARK CLOUD HANGING OVER
US THERE IS NO CHANCE FOR THE
SURVIVAL OF THE SALMON SPECIES
ESPECIALLY IN THE SACRAMENTO IT
IS MAKING MATTERS. WORSE IN THE
STATE I AND IT IS COMPOUNDING
THE DIRE SITUATION WE HAVE
BECAUSE OF THIS HISTORIC
DROUGHT SO ON THAT I JUST HAVE
A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS AND GO
BACK TO DIRECTOR BONHAM. CARTER
BONHAM IN YOUR OPENING REMARKS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT LOOKING AHEAD
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO. THAT LET'S
TAKE A WORST CASE SCENARIO- IF
IT IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU
MISTER DIRECTOR TALK ABOUT YOUR
SITES THAT SAY WE FACE A
SIMILAR. DROUGHT CONDITION NEXT
YEAR. WHAT WILL THE DEPARTMENT
NEED TO DO TO MOBILIZE AND GIVE
US YOUR THOUGHTS IF WE SEE
SIMILAR CONDITIONS NEXT YEAR I
TO SAVE THE SPECIES. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. I ALSO
JUST WANNA SAY BOTH TO YOU AND
THE VICE CHAIR I CHERISH AND
REALLY RESPECT THE
RELATIONSHIPS WE BUILD TOGETHER
OVER TIME. SO EVEN THOUGH FOR
THE PUBLIC WATCHING IT MAY FEEL
LIKE WE'RE ARGUING I APPRECIATE
THE HELP THE EXCHANGE OF.
INPUTS I VALUE THE ROLE OF THIS
COMMITTEE. SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES IT'S BEEN ONE OF OUR
KEY JOINT COMMITTEES FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT SO THANK YOU. I AM
THINKING ABOUT THREE AREAS IF I
LOOK INTO TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
I ASSUME. YEAH IT'S ASTROTURF
FIRST I AM THINKING ABOUT OUR
DEPARTMENTS ON CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. I THINK WE'RE
DOING BETTER IN THAT REGARD WE
HAVE A GREATER INFUSION OF
MONEY FOR THIS EMERGENCY IN
PART BECAUSE YOUR LEADERSHIP.
WE HAD SO WE HAVEN'T SOONER.
AND IT'S IN ONE KIND OF
DISTRIBUTION SO WE'RE BETTER
PREPARED. BUT IN THIS SPACE
WHAT HAS ME WORRIED IS OUR
HATCHERY INFRASTRUCTURE. IT IS
REALLY NOT SET UP FOR. THIS
DYNAMIC ALLIES HATCHERIES WE ON
AN OPERATOR BELOW THE DAMS THEY
GET THE COOL WATER FROM THE
DAMS RESERVOIR THEY WERE SET UP
TO MITIGATE THE LOSS OF HABITAT
WHEN THE DAMS WERE CONSTRUCTED
BACK IN THE FORTIES AND FIFTIES.
SO RIGHT NOW WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH OUR FACILITIES IS WE CAN'T
KEEP COOL WATER COMING INTO.
THE BEST EXAMPLE OF THAT
DYNAMIC IS ARGUABLY WARM
SPRINGS HATCHERY ON THE RUSSIAN
RIVER RIGHT NOW WHICH MR MACK
AND HELP MY TALK ABOUT. WORKING
WITH THE US ARMY CORPS'S INS
THEIR FACILITY WE CAN RUN IT
CAN'T KEEP ENOUGH COOL WATER
COMING INTO IT BECAUSE THE
RESERVOIRS MENDOCINO CINEMA.
DON'T HAVE. TO WORK WITH FORCED
WHEN AND WHERE DO WE MOVE THE
FISH TOO. AND AS WE'RE MOVING
FISH ACROSS OUR FACILITIES
SUMMER FILLING UP THERE'S NO
MORE CAPACITY. THAT'S GOING TO
BE AN EVEN MORE TRICKY
DIFFICULT DYNAMIC IF WE GET
INTO TWENTY TWENTY TWO LIKE IT
IS. I ALSO THINK IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SECOND AREA. WE'RE
VERY FOCUSED ON IS IF IT'S THE
SAME OR WORSE. BE READY TO MOVE
FISH LIKE WE DID THE SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOWN INTO THE BAY IN
THE ESTUARY. I'M WILLING FOR US
TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT AS IT'S
NEEDED IN THESE DARK
CONDITIONS. BUT I'M ALSO
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT IF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND ARE WE GETTING OURSELVES IN
A POSITION OF EVERY YEAR.
LIVING DATA ANALYSIS I'M NOT
SURE THAT'S THE SOUNDEST
STRATEGY EITHER IT HAS ME
CONCERNED. THIRD AREA. YES NEXT
YEAR ASSUMPTION YOU YOUR FRIEND
IS AS DRYER DRYER WE HAVE A-
HELLO GENTLEMEN SHADOW OF
ALMOST- NO WAY OUT DECISIONS WE
WOULD ENTER NEXT YEAR WITH
FULSOME OR THEY'LL- AND- SHASTA
AND HISTORICAL LOWS. WE WOULD
BE ASSUMING NO INCREASE CAUSES
AS DRYER DRYER WHAT DO WE DO
NOW IS TO COLD WATER. AND I
THINK THAT SCENARIO PUTS US AND
PARTICULARLY THE WATER BOARD.
IN A PLACE NONE OF US EVER
AGAIN WHAT'S IT LIKE TO HAVE
BARE MINIMUM FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY. AND NOT MUCH ELSE
WATER FOR ANYTHING. TO BE OPEN
ABOUT IT AND THAT THAT IS.
THAT'S OUTSIDE ANY. INDIVIDUAL
ON THIS PHONE CALLER PANELS
EXPERIENCE. YEAH I THINK THAT'S
THE MENTALITY WE HAVE TO HAVE
AS WE'RE THINKING ABOUT WHAT'S
AHEAD AND WHILE IT'S MIGHT
SOUND TRITE. I ALSO THINK IT'S
ANOTHER REASON WHY EVERY DROP
OF WATER YOU NEED CALIFORNIANS
CAN SAY. IS GOOD FOR US IS
CALIFORNIANS IS PEOPLE. BUT
THAT DROP WATER WE CAN SAY
RIGHT NOW WILL ALSO HELP OUR
ANIMALS PLANTS AND ONE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT'S HAPPENED ON
THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT FISHING WILDLIFE AND
DON'T WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD I MEAN SO BACK. I THINK
AT MADAME EXECUTOR YOU'RE
FACING THAT ISSUE RIGHT NOW-
FIFTY FOUR TO FIFTY GALLONS PER
DAY ON THE UPPER RUSSIAN RIVER
WATERSHED THAT'S A- REALITY
THAT WE MAY SEE ACROSS THE
STATE I WANT TO SAY. THANK YOU
TO BOTH OF YOU FOR JOINING US
HERE TODAY MADAM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR- WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
THE ABILITY FOR CLOSING
COMMENTS IF YOU'D LIKE- AS MR
BYNUM JUST GAVE THAT RESPONSE
THAT FOR SIXTY SECONDS PLEASE
AND WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING TO
OUR NEXT PANEL. THAT EXECUTOR
ACTOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER CHAIR WE REALLY
APPRECIATE- ARE. ARE YOUR YOUR
INVITATION TO COME HERE AND
TALK ABOUT WHAT ACTIONS THE
BORDER IS TAKING. I WOULD JUST
URGE EVERYBODY TO. CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US TO BRING YOUR
INPUT TO US WE ARE. IN SOMEWHAT
UNCHARTED. REGULATORY LAND AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE-
WE- DEVELOP AND ADOPT- WORKABLE
REGULATIONS THAT- SHEETS
PURPOSES OF. CURTAILING WATER
USE BUT IN ORDER TO SAVE AND
PROTECT- WATER FOR ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL USES AND ONE THING WE
WILL- YOU KNOW. PLAYING OFF A
LITTLE OF WHAT DIRECTOR BONHAM
SAID WHAT WE WILL BE FOCUSING
IN THE FUTURE- IN CASE THAT
THERE IS- CONTINUED OR
WORSENING DROUGHT IS WORKING
THROUGH HOW TO MAKE-
CURTAILMENT REGULATIONS MORE
WORKABLE HOW TO MONITOR IN REAL
TIME HOW TO REALLY UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WATER IS BEING DIVERTED
AND USED FOR WHAT PURPOSES AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE WORKABLE
ENFORCEMENT. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE DIVERTING ARE NOT SO THAT
THE ESSENTIAL WATER USE IS THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO PROTECT-
INCLUDING- INSTREAM FLOW FOR
FISH- THAT DOES ACTUALLY. DO
COME TO PASS SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY IT WAS SUN
HUNG. A USEFUL AND INTERCHANGE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGING
DIRECTOR MISTER DIRECTOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND IS THAT
DIRECTOR OFFICIAL WHILE I SAID
THAT THERE IS NO ARGUMENT HERE
I THINK THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE.
THAT THAT WE ARE IN A DIRE
SITUATION. UNCHARTED TERRITORY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION I THINK WHERE
WE MAY DIFFER IN THAT'S FINE I
AND I AGREE WITH THE DIRECTOR
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE LOOK
DIRECTOR- MISTER BONHAM AND I
HAVE HAD BACK AND FORTH. FOR
THE LAST SIX AND A HALF YEARS
AND I DEEPLY VALUE OUR
RELATIONSHIP WHETHER IT'S
ISSUES ON CRAP. ON ISSUES OF
SQUID ON ISSUES- SALMON. AND
WHILE WE MAY NOT ALWAYS COME TO
THE SAME CONCLUSION I KNOW THAT
OUR HEARTS AREIN THE SAME SPOT
ABOUT. HOW WE CAN BETTER
PROTECT EACH AND EVERY SPECIE
IN THE STATE- AND GREATLY VALUE
THE RELATIONSHIP AND KNOW THAT
WE HAVE SOME REAL CHALLENGES
HEAD ESPECIALLY WITH HIS HOLD
OVER POLICY. AND WHAT IT MEANS
FOR THE OUTCOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
ICONIC AND ENDANGERED SALMON
FISHERY WHICH IS ON THE BRINK
OF EXTINCTION SOME WATERSHEDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
DIRECTOR MADAM EECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON IN APPRECIATE AT THE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE HERE TO
HEAR FROM- TO DISTINGUISH
CHAIRMAN WE'RE GONNA FIRST HERE
FROM JOSEPH JAMES HE IS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE YUROK TRIBE.
CHAIRMAN JANE JAMES IS GONNA BE
SHARING HIS EXPERIENCE OF THE
IRAQI PEOPLE AND COME TO
DROUGHT THE LOSSES SALMON IN
THE KLAMATH IN THE CRITICAL
WORK THE TRIBE IS DOING TO
PROTECT. ITS TERRITORY IN OF
COURSE ITS WAY OF LIFE RENDON
HERE FROM CHAIRMAN ADDERBURY
CHAIRMAN ADDERBURY IS CHAIR OF
THE KARUK TRIBE. CHAIRMAN
ADDERBURY IS GONNA TELL US
ABOUT THE IMPACTS THAT AT THE
DROUGHT DE WATERING IN NORTH
COAST REVERSING THE LEGACY THE
CLAIM IS DAMS HAVE HAD ON THE
CROOK FOLK PEOPLE. AND THE
IMPACT IT HAS HAD ON SALMON AS
WELL AS THE CEREMONIES IN THE
SUBSTANCE THAT. THE CREW PEOPLE
DEPEND ON SO WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO WE'RE GOING TO TURN. IT
OVER FIRST AND FOREMOST THE
CHAIRMAN JANE. HE'S TO BE GIVEN
AS- FIVE TO MINUTE BREAK. FROM
THE YUROK THEN WILL TURN IT
OVER. TO CHAIR AT A VERY GIVES
OF DISC MINUTE READ. I'LL GIVE
EACH OF YOU GENTLEMEN A THIRD
SECOND. AS WE'RE GONNA NEED YOU
TO WRAP UP ALL RIGHT. THAT
JAMES WE WELCOME YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHAIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS- THANK YOU. OR IN
WORKSHOPS MOUNTAIN BY LEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING TODAY MY NAME IS
JOSEPH JAMES ON SHERMAN HERE
TRY. TODAY WE TALK ABOUT THE
DROUGHT CLANGER. ROLE THE STATE
CALIFORNIA CAN HELP ALL PLAY IN
HELPING PEOPLE THROUGH THIS.
RIGHT YOU KNOW NO DOUBT AWARE
YOU'RE TRYING TO LARGE TRYING
CALIFORNIANS OVER SIX THOUSAND
MITCHELL CITIZENS X. SHARE.
SURE TO HELP THE WELL BEING OF
YOUR PEOPLE THAT MEANS SECURING
THE LONG TERM FUTURE THE SENATE
AND THE CLIMATE STRICTURES. BY
NOW EVERYBODY KNOWS THE CLIMATE
IS IN TROUBLE WE ARE NOT CRISIS
WE'RE IN A FULL BLOWN EMERGENCY.
THIS YEAR WE EXPERIENCE EVERY
DEATH IN THE MAINSTREAM THE
DEADLY DISEASE HE STOPS AND NO
WATER WAS AVAILABLE TO HELP.
EVEN FARMERS IN THE UPPER CLASS
BASIS SHOT NEARLY ENTIRELY.
FROM SERVICE WATER VERSIONS ON
THE SHASTA'S. WATER VERSIONS
DROP AND- COMBINED DRESS OF THE-
AND LOSSES X. BE HAPPY. AGAIN
WE ARE IS NOT FULL COOL BLOWN.
HERE ON THE CLOUDBASE PLAN FOR.
WE LOSING OUR SENATE. WE CANNOT
LOSE OUR SAM THERE EVERYTHING
TO OUR CHILDREN'S FUTURE
DEPENDS ON. ENSURING THAT FISH
NOT ONLY SURVIVE. BUT THEY
THRIVE FOR THAT THANK YOU
CHANGE OUR CULTURAL. COMING
HAVE BEEN IN BY THE LOSS OF
FISH. ARE RIVERS NOT PLEASANT
TOXICOLOGY FATHERS MOTHERS
CASTLEMAN ALTERCATION WITH
OUTPATIENT CLINIC RIVERS. YOUR
PEOPLE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN GUIDED
BY OUR CULTURE VALUES SCIENCE
AND FACTS APPROACH THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES. WE HAVE NEVER
SHIED AWAY FROM ADDRESSING THE
PANAMA COURT ISSUES THAT ARE
CAUSING OUR- HERE TO THE SALAS
LOOKS LIKE LARGE SCALE RESEARCH
CENTERS SUCH AS GENERAL. IN
RESTORATION EFFORTS HELLO IN
THE LOWER KLAMATH MAINSTREAM.
SUGAR WE GET IN THERE AND DO
THE WORK. HELLO ARE YOU. HELLO
OF COURSE AND FOR THE LEVEL
DOOR. THE KLAMATH RIVER IS TO
WE ARE THAT IS LIFELINE LED THE
SYSTEM TOP DOWN A THIS WAY THE
FISHING FROM MARK FROM HER
OLDER. GRANDPARENTS IT IS OUR
STORE. TO LIVE OFF. HERE ARE
TRAVIS A RECORD RIGHT TO NOT
CONFIDENT RESEARCH SHEARWATER.
IT WAS GONNA QUITE AND TITLES.
ANY TIME ORDER QUALITY WATER
NAY SERVICE WORKERS REACHED.
THIS EXTENDS TO THE BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THE FISH. WHAT PROCESS.
IN THE WORLD ONE TRACK WITH
FINAL FOUNDATIONALWATER.
ROOFLESS BOOK WHAT MAKES OR
BREAK FISHER NO MATTER REGISTRY
CAN MAKE UP A ROOM. WHATEVER
FLOWS PARTISAN. FOR EXAMPLE.
THE BASE FLOWS THE KLAMATH
RIVER WHICH STARTS WORKING WITH
NO A THREAT AS A STATE WORKER
MAKES SENSE ALLOCATE ALL WATER
IN THE RELEASED FROM CLASS LET
SUCH TO OREGON LAW. EVEN AS A
INTEREST OF COMMA CORRECT
IMPACTED. WE WANT TO THANK
STATE COLLEGE. FOR STEPPING UP
TO HELP ADDRESS THE- THANK YOU.
YOUR TRUCK WHAT STATE CALIBER
STUFF SHASTA SCOTT RITTER WE
DEPARTURES GAME WHILE AT
FORMALLY TRY CAR FLOWS STATE
WATER IS THOSE NUMBERS INTO
NEATLY. THIS CANNOT. REALLY
FAST FIVE YEAR PAUL RICHARD OUT
HAD ABLE TO HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO MAKE IT PAST LITTLE
BLUEBERRY ACCESS THE SPAWNING
GROUNDS THIS IS A PATH TO
EXTENSION. ACCEPTABLE TO THE
IRAQI PEOPLE. DASCHLE'S
RELATIONAL- THE LONG WAY
TOWARDS ENSURING FUTURE SENATE
BASED. THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THE FACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ARE
BEING FELT. PEOPLE RESTRICTING
THE WATER INSIDE THEIR HOMES
AND BUSINESSES. IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THEIR LARGE SCALE
ATTACKS NO CLIENT BASE LOOKS
FOUNDER SEEMS YOUR WATER THIS
YEAR. KRYCEK ON THE SURFACE AND
GROUNDWATER VERSION IN THE
CHASSIS CAR SHOPPERS
FUNDAMENTAL FAIR FAIR WAY. TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY'S DOING
APART. WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT
YOU AT THE MERCY REGULATION. OF
COURSE OF THE BE ISSUE.
FORCINGS KEY BYLA. WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT LARGE SCALE ALONG
IN YOUR UNLESS WE PER SONG THE
BILL TO TRACK FORCE ANY RIGHT.
DIRECT ADOPT AND RAISE YOUR
RIGHT LEG ON THIS SCOTT PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY RETIRED.
INITIAL DEDICATION OF WATER FOR
WITH WOMEN'S. TO SHASTA SABAR.
YOU CAN GO BACK INTO THE ME
STEP. PROVIDE RESEARCH FIRMS
BEFORE REGULATE. ATHLETE
PROTECT FLOWS ON LINE FOR ME
STILL. INCREASE FUNDING TO REST
MARKET SCAMMER INDUSTRIES IN
THE SHASTA AND SCOTT REVERSED.
WMH TOOL. THIS WILL BE A MAJOR
FACTOR WILL BE PARBOILED THIS
DANCE TO LIVE LIMB CATASTROPHIC
LIFE RIGHT BUT THE WATER TO TRY
TO COME ON. ON OTHER HAND FIRES.
OFFICIALS TO THE TRIBE. WE CAN
LOW INTENSITY FIRES FUEL LOW IN
MAY ME SAY THIS IMPORTANT. IN
YOUR COUNTRY WHAT FEATURES
NARAL SHORTHANDED ROADS WITH
LIMITED ESCAPE OPTIONS. THIRTY
SECONDS. WEEK STATUS THIS YEAR
THANK YOU STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR THE STREAMING IS LEADERSHIP
ROLE AND HELMUT GAMBLE FOR
ALTHOUGH IT APPEARS TO BE ON A
SOLID PATH TOWARD COMMITTEE
RECREATION ONCE AGAIN
FREDRIKSTAD THE TIMELINE OVER
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FOUR THIS THIS MUST NOT HAPPEN.
THIS PROJECT. HAS BEEN STUDIED
FOR NEARLY TWENTY YEARS. IN
THIS TIME FOR ACTS WE- EXTRA
ALL RIGHTPERMITTING. FOLLOWING
TO KEEP THE PROCESS ON TIME AND
WITHIN BUDGET. IN CLOSING YOUR
TRIBE HAS A LONG CONTINUOUS
HISTORY STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
CANNOT OVERLOOK THAT BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD. TO FORGE A NEW
PATH FORWARD THAT BEGINS TO
ADDRESS THE MANY WRONGS THAT
WERE HARMFUL TO TRY TO PASS.
WITH THAT ON BEHALF OF THE EURO
TRIBAL COUNCIL EUROPE TROUBLED
GOVERNMENT. MYSELF AS YOUR
TRIBAL CHAIRMAN THANK YOU THIS
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDER TESLA
GARDEN IF SUPPORTERS. OF THE
RIVER THE FISH FOR US THE
PEOPLE THANK YOU WHAT CLOUT.
TIM JEAN THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU WAS ABLE TO
VISIT WITH CHAIRMAN JAMES SAID
THIS PAST WEEK- IN GRATEFUL
THAT WE SPENT SOME TIME OUT ON
THE CLAIM IT TAKING A LOOK AT
THE IMPACTS THAT. THE IRAQI
PEOPLE ARE SEEN AT BASED OFF OF
THIS EXTREME DROUGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO CHAIRMAN ADDERBURY
HE IS CHAIR OF THE CREW TRIED.
MISTER CHAIR WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP I CHAIR AT A
BERRIES BEEN A CHAMPION ON ALL
ISSUES OF TRIBAL WILDFIRE IN
SECURING RESOURCES FOR
CALIFORNIA TRIBES. IS AT A VERY
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THAT WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU A FIVE TO
SEVEN MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU.
THIRTY SECONDS ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR. YOUR THANK. I FEEL
GERMAN MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. AMBASSADOR AT A
VERY AND I HAVE THE BROWN'S.
SERVING AS CHAIRMAN FOR THE
BROOK DRIVE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. THE GROUP TRIED HAS
ALMOST THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
ROLE MEMBERS AND FOUR FIVE
THOUSAND ENROLLED SENTIMENTS
ARE ABORIGINAL TERRITORY
ENCOMPASSES OVER ONE MILLION
ACRES. ALONG THE MIDDLE KLAMATH
BASIN INCLUDING PORTIONS OF SIX
YEAR AND ON BOTH COUNTS. AMONG
THE MANY GOALS IS DRIVING IS TO
PROTECTION AND RESTORATION OF
OUR ABORIGINAL HOMELANDS. AND
THE MULTITUDE OF PLANT AND
ANIMAL SPECIES. THAT WE HAVE
DEPENDED ON AND- I MIGHT ADD
THAT THEY DEPEND ON US- FOR
COUNTLESS GENERATIONS OF
CULTURAL RELIGIOUS AND
SUBSTANCE USES. TODAY I HOPE WE
CAN FOCUS ON IT THE ATTENTION
ON THE VARIOUS SPECIES OF FISH.
THAT HAVE THE CORRECT TRIBAL
SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL. BUT I
WILL NOTE THAT THE ACORNS BEAR
GRASS HAZEL WILL L. DEAR. AND
HUNDREDS OF OTHER PLANT AND
ANIMAL SPECIES- ARE ALSO PART
OF OUR CULTURAL IDENTITY. IN
DESERVE SIMILAR ATTENTION FROM
LAWMAKERS BUT WE WILL. WE'LL
SAVE THAT FOR ANOTHER DAY-
SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL THE GROUP
TRIED HAVE RELIED ON FISH SUCH
AS SALMON LAMPREY MUSCLES FEEL
IN. IN STURGEON FOR SURVIVAL.
OVER TIME THE GROUP TRIED BELT
STRATEGIES MANAGING ENHANCE
POPULATIONS OF THE SPECIES CARE
ACT THERE. MANAGEMENT
TECHNIQUES MANY OF WHICH ARE
INCORPORATED INTO RELIGIOUS.
CEREMONIAL PRACTICES. IN FACT
ARE UP SLOW LAND MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND THE USE OF FIRE
AS A MANAGEMENT TOOL. PLAYS AS
MUCH AS A ROLE IN FISHERIES
MANAGEMENT AS IT DOESN'T FORCED
MARRIAGE. HOWEVER THE ARRIVAL
OF THEIR EUROPEAN SETTLERS OUR
ABILITY TO ACTIVELY MANAGE OUR
OWN RESOURCES. THE RESOURCES
THAT THAT OUR ANCESTORS THE
RESOURCES THAT TOGETHER DEFINE
OUR CULTURE AND THE HAS BEEN
TAKEN AWAY FROM US. AND THE
RESULT HAS BEEN CAB
CATASTROPHIC. IN RECENT YEARS.
NOW WHAT JOHN SALMON PINK
SALMON CAMERAS ARE ALREADY. IN
A LOSS TO EXTINCTION. IN RECENT
YEARS SPRING CHINOOK COHO
SALMON AND SUMMERS AND- HAVE
CREPT CLOSER TO EXTINCTION. AND
TODAY WE HEAR THAT THE CYNICAL
GREEN STURGEON AND FALL CHINOOK
ARE QUICKLY MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION- WELL WE EXPERIENCE
DURING THE GROUND CONDITIONS.
IN MANY YEARS THIS YEAR IS THE
MOST DISASTERS. I'VE EVER
EXPERIENCED IN MY LIFETIME. YES
THERE ARE CLOSE COUPLE WAS
HISTORIC HIGH TEMPERATURES LOW
IN THE MASSIVE. JUVENILE FISH
KILL THIS SPRING AS YOU HAVE
HEARD. ESTIMATES VARY BUT BUT
THAT EVERYONE AGREES THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF JUVENILE
SALMON TRYING TO- MIGRATE OUT
OF THE SEAT DIED BASED ZINES.
THIS DISEASE SPREADS RETIRING
TEMPERATURES ARE HIGH AND LOWS
ARE FLOW HELLO. MAKE NO MISTAKE
WE CAN'T APPEAR IN ALL THE
BLAME ON MOTHER NATURE YOU
GLOBAL WARMING THIS MAN OF OUR
RIVER AND THE LANDSCAPE JUST AS
MUCH. OR MORE TO BLAME. THE
KLAMATH BASIN IS OVER ALLOCATED
THAT FEDERAL. KLAMATH
IRRIGATION PROJECT OVER
ALLOCATED WATER IN THE EARLY
TWENTIETH CENTURY THINKING THAT
THE WEATHER. PATTERNS OF THAT
WOULD PROCESS. NOW WE ALL KNOW
THAT WAS A FAULTY ASSUMPTION.
AND THAT THERE IS NO ANALYST
WATER SUPPLY. M. WE HAVE TO
CHANGE OUR WATER MANAGEMENT AND
FOREST MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES
REFLECT THAT FACT THEY THE
CLAMOR. MASON PROJECT IS SIMPLY
OVER ALLOCATED THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH WATER TO GO AROUND.
SIMILARLY CUBASE ARE. KEYS
SUBBASIN IT'S SUCH AS JASMINE
SCOTT IN STUDENT COUNCIL. ARE
BEING SYSTEMATICALLY BE WATER
OVER HALF OF THE WILD CHINOOK
THAT ARE BORN IN THE PLAN WITH
ORIGINATE IN THIS SHASTA
SUBBASIN PERHAPS YOU THIRDS OF
THE COLLAPSE. IN THE KLAMATH
BASIN SPEND PART OF THEIR LIVES
IN THE SCOTT SPIKE THE
FUNDAMENTAL ROLE THE STREAMS
WHY IN A KIND OF BASE VICTORY
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES HAVE
FAILED TO ESTABLISH. A MINIMUM
INSTREAM FLOW NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THE FISHERS. STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES HAVE FAILED TO
REGULATE GROUNDWATER PUMPING.
THAT STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES
HAVE FAILED TO ENFORCE EXISTING
LAWS WRITTEN ACCESSORIES. STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES HAVE
FAILED TO PROTECT OUR TRIBAL
CULTURE. WE DO HAVE GOOD NEWS-
THINGS ARE CHANGING WORKING
WITH THAT DOWNSTREAM NEIGHBORS
NEAR OUR- CALIFORNIA OREGON AND
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION WE ARE
ABLE TO STAY. AT THE KLAMATH
BASIN HYDROELECTRIC SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT LAST YEAR. THANKS IN
PART YOU LEADERSHIP AND
GOVERNANCE AREN'T OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. WE ABLE TO FORGE A
NEW MEMORANDUM OF AGREEMENT WAS
BURKE SHIRE ENERGY WHICH BUT-
PLANS TO REMOVE THE LOWER OR
KLAMATH DAMS ON FIRM FOOTING.
EARLIER THIS SUMMER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
LISTEN TO THE CURRENT TRIBES
CONCERN REGARDING OPERATION OF
IRANGATE ANSWERED. WE URGE YOU
TO PARK TO ALTER ITS TYPICAL
MAJOR PRACTICE. THIS IS NOT
RELEASED MILLIONS OF JUVENILE
SALMON ENGINE OR RIVER
CONDITIONS WHICH WOULD LIKELY
HAD. SERVED TWO X. ARE
INCREASED THE DISEASE ISSUES
THE DEPARTMENT WORK WITH US. TO
FOCUS ON REPAIRING THE SPANISH
DURING THE SUMMER OR FALL
RELEASE WHEN RIVER CONDITIONS
IMPROVED. THESE FIRST WILL HAVE
A GREATER CHANCE FOR SURVIVAL
WE APPRECIATE OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. WHAT DEPARTMENTAL
STAFF THIRTY SECONDS OUT OKAY
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO IN RESPONSE
TO THE PETITIONER GROUP TRIED
FISHING GAME QUESTION ADDED TO
THE- AGREED TO ADD COMMAS
SPRING CHINOOK THE STATES AND
AGENCIES TO REST. THE MOST
RECENTLY IN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT THIS MORAL AND
LEADERSHIP ON CHUCK BONHAM. AND
THE CALIFORNIA WATER RESOURCES
BOARD UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
WALKING AS WELL. AS MUCH AS THE
REGULATORY PROCESS THAT WILL
ESTABLISH MINIMUM CLOSE FOR
STARTERS GAS CHEST RIVERS AND
PUT IN PLACE TO TOOLS REGULATE
WATER. AT TO MEET THESE MINIMUM
FLOWS. THANK GOVERNOR AND FOR
THE HELP BUT THERE'S MORE TO DO.
WE MUST CAN'T TO WORK GET
TOGETHER TO SEE DEMOCRATS THE
FINISH LINE. SINGLE THING WE
CAN DO TO BASS FISHERIES. REST
IN THE CAR. I'M WE AGREE THAT
THAT THE CONSULTATION PROCESS
IS GREAT- BUT WE UNDERSTAND
PLEASE THAT WHEN WE HAVE THESE
CONSTRUCTS BUS THAT DRIVES NEED
TO BE A CLINTON. I LOVE FACT
BASED CONVERSATIONS. I THINK
IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED THAT THAT
TRAVEL ECOLOGICAL KNOWLEDGE IS
FACT BASED BASED ON THOUSANDS
OF YEARS OF BEST PRACTICES. OUR
PASSED DOWN FROM GENERATION TO
GENERATION AND THOSE. WHEN WE
HAVE THOSE CONSULTATIONS WE
HAVE TO ENTER INTO THE ROOM
WITH THE IDEA THAT WE'RE GONNA
I'LL LEAVE ALL PARTIES WITH ON
CONSENT ON HER HAND HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD. THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GOING TO GET MEANINGFUL
CONCENTRATION. AND I RESPECT
FOR TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AGAIN I
THINK WE TIME THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE'RE GRATEFUL CHIP FOR
CHAIRMAN JAMES TESTIMONY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO THE
VICE CHAIR CHAIR STONE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. HINTING
NINE- WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
CHECK IN WITH CHAIR AT A VERY
CHAIR FOR THE KARUK. IF YOU CAN
GIVE US YOUR PERSPECTIVE. HOW
DOES THIS DROUGHT COMPARED TO
CONDITIONS IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
IN THE KLAMATH. I BASED OFF OF
WHAT YOU SEE HOW BAD YOU THINK
IT'S GOING TO GET IN IN TALK
WITH US ABOUT YOUR PLANS FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IF WE SEE
CONDITIONS PERSIST AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO CHAIRMAN
JAMES BUT CHAIR AT A VERY
PLEASED TO FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU I'M SO MOVING FORWARD
I JUST SAID I'M PROBABLY
PROVIDING THAT YEARS NOW THAT
WE'RE WE'RE OUT OF TIME. THE
FACT THAT- YOU TALK ABOUT THE
DROUGHTS IN THEM FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN. AND WE'RE HAVING MORE
DROUGHTS NOW THE CONDITIONS
THEIR ROLL OVER FROM OTHER
CONDITIONS MAKE IT EVEN WORSE
REGARD THAT. THAT TO BE A FACT
THAT WE NEED TO DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL LIKENESS WHAT WORDS
FORCE. IT ENVIRONMENTAL THE
TECHNICIAN THIS MEANS
LEGISLATORS MUST ADEQUATELY
FUND THESE ANGELS CARRY OUT
THEIR MISSION- N. M. N. AGAIN
HAVING THE TRIBES GIVEN THE
TRIBES THE TABLE SO WE CAN
BRING IN TROUBLE A CO OPTING
IT'S ALL DOCUMENTED IN OUR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLAN WE HAVE
REVEALS REDUCTION PLANS. THAT
WE HAVE TRICKS PROGRAMS THAT-
WHAT TEACH OTHER AID ON HOW TO
USE. FIRE TO. REDUCE THE BILLS
OUT THERE- YEAH WE NEED TO BUY
IT SO MY COMMENT IS FORCING IN
SIX EXISTING ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
TO PROTECT THEIR FISHERIES. AND
TO GIVE US A SEAT AT THE TABLE
BUT THE IDEA WHEN WE WALK AWAY
FROM THE TABLE WE WILL HAVE
MUTUAL CONSENT ON HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIS GO TO CHAIRMAN JAMES
AT SAME QUESTION MISTER CHAIR.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS IS THIS
DROUGHT COMPARES WITH TWO
THOUSAND TWO. WHAT IS YOUR
GUIDE ON DIOS I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE SAYING YOU SEEN. REAL
IMPACT ON JUVENILE SALMON IN
YOUR THOUGHTS AND THE TRIBES
PLANS FOR TWENTY TWENTY TO
DROUGHT CONDITIONS PERSIST AT
YOUR JAMES. THANK YOU GERMAN
CAR. YOU KNOW ALL HANDS ON DECK
FOR US IN THE- PRICES STATE IN
RECEIPT FONG YOU KNOW THE
PATHWAY THINKING IT'S GOT TO
CHANGE. WELL FLOWS FROM THE
TRINITY RIVER IN FORCE IN THE
RANKS IN REGULATIONS. WELL
ABOVE THE WATER DIVERTED
ANYTHING TO KEEP WATER BUT IN
PLACE THAT MEANS THAT THE MAIN
SURPLUS AS THEY ARE YOU KNOW
CHANGE POLICY ON THROUGH THE
STATE SIDE THE FEDERAL SIDE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT A DRESSING ON. YOU KNOW IT'S
A- YOU KNOW IT WE DO A LOT OF
TRADE WE ARE IS YOUR PEOPLE TO
BALANCE ACTUALLY WHAT WE DO
GIVE THANKS FOR THE CREATOR
PROVIDING EVERYTHING. FOR US
YOU OF THE NATURISM FISHERIES
BROKEN ALL ONE FISH TOO MANY.
WE'VE ALREADY HAD OUR YOUNG
JUVENILES FOR READY AND WITH A
LITTLE AMOUNT OF THE RIVER THAT
RECEIPT NOW THE STREAMS. YOU
KNOW IT CAN WHERE IT'S A BIT
WORRYING NOT CRISIS NOW I'M OUR
LIVELIHOODS OUR CULTURE TO
LABEL. THIS IS YOUR PEOPLE NEXT
DOOR TO THE LANCE'S FIRST
PEOPLE OF THIS AREA. WE HAVE
DID MANY GREAT THINGS WE
RESPECTIVELY TOOK CARE OF
MOTHER EARTH AND CONTINUE TO DO
THAT SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO OUR REGION SHOULD IMPORTANCE
OF THE CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN. ON
YOU KNOW AGAIN CHECK THE WELL
OF OUR CENTER KLAMATH RIVER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- AND FINAL
QUESTION WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO CHEER AT A VERY CHAIR. HOW
DO YOU BELIEVE WILDFIRES ARE
EXACERBATING IMPACTS TO- WATER
QUALITY A AND M. POTENTIAL
SEDIMENT ASH EXEDRA. CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT ARE YOU SEEN
RIGHT ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES
BASED OFF OF WILDFIRE. ON
CROOKLYN. YES ABSOLUTELY- IT NO
THE DROUGHT TAKES ITS TOLL AND
THE- THE FIRES ARE AS YOU
CENTER THE TERM THE- ALL THE
SETTLEMENT ON GROUND THE- ACTS.
EXACTLY THE CREEK SINCE- THE R.
RETARDANTS THAT SPRAYED THEY
ALL OF YOU KNOW BIG PART IN IN
THE- IN WATER QUALITY- AND I'M
WE PROBABLY HAVEN'T TALKED
NOTHING ABOUT THE WATER QUALITY-
WAS THAT WAS THE DAM YOU
COMBINE THAT WITH THE-
BLUEGREEN ALGAE THAT'S ARTS
RELEASED. IT THE COMBINATION
JUST BE OVERWHELMING FOR THE
HEALTH OF OUR OUR RIVERS AND IN
REAL QUICK I MIGHT ADD THAT
THEM ONLY WEEKS WE HOLD TRUE
THE CURRENT TRIED IS ALWAYS
SAID THAT. WE WANT TO SEE. GET
TOGETHER AND PROVIDE SOLUTIONS
WE WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONSULTATION WE WERE. OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ASSEMBLY AT
FARMERS- COUNTY WHOEVER AND
HAVE THOSE MEETINGS AND COME UP
WAS BOTH LONG. AND SHORT TERM
SOLUTIONS. AND I THINK THERE'S
SOME IDEAS FROM ALL PARTIES
THAT WE CAN DO THAT ON IT WILL
COME UP WITH SOME SOLUTIONS OR-
SHORT AND LONG TERM- A PROJECTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU'RE A BURYING AGAIN CHAD
VERSION VERY FOCUS ON SECURING
ANY INDEPENDENT RESOURCES
FINANCIAL RESOURCES FOR TRIBES
TO BE A DO UPSTREAM INVESTING
WHEN IT COMES TO VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT DIDN'T ENTRY MORE
WORK CENTER AND APPRECIATED HIS
LEADERSHIP. IN FINAL QUESTION
HERE COMING TO CHAIRMAN JAMES
CHAIRMAN JAMES. THE IMPACT ON
SALMON FISHERIES IT IS A
MASSIVE. IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO ON THE
NORTH COAST ECONOMY IN DEBT
MISTER CHAIR A LOT OF WHAT THE
TRIBE HAS BEEN DOING IS WORKING
WITH THE LAND IN EXPOSING FOLKS
WHO. MAYBE FROM OTHER AREAS OF
THE STATE THE COUNTRY FROM
AROUND THE WORLD TO THE KLAMATH
INTO THE LAND THAT. YOU SO
PROUDLY LIVE ON IN WITH- BUT
THERE'S ALSO ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DROUGHT AND IT'S IMPACTING THE
ROCK PEOPLE CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT GERMAN JAMES. YEAH I'LL
TALK ABOUT THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
YOU KNOW. WE HAVE A- IN
RESOURCES FROM STRUGGLES FROM
SPORTS GUYS THAT RELYING ON
THEIR LIVELIHOOD. DURING
FISHING PERSONAL FICTION PACKS
ALL OF US NOT JUST. OUR OUR
TRUCK GUIDE BUT OUR LOW
BUSINESS HERE ARE THE REST OF.
GAS TELL IT'S A COMMON YOU KNOW
THE NEW COAST BEAUTIFUL WHICH
THE CLAMOR RIVER- YOU KNOW WHAT
TO. WHO EVER TRADITIONAL IRAQ
RIGHT DOES NOT CONTAIN TOWARDS
THE CLIMB RIVER YOU MIGHT
SUPPORT TO SUCH A CULTURAL
LANGUAGE I THINK. ONLY JUST- I
CAN WAS IN CALL. FISHING RIVERS.
ARE OR WOMEN. ARTICLES
YESTERDAY TAX THEIR TRADITION
IT'S NOT LIKE WHAT IS YOUR- ON
ANY GIVEN EXPERIENCE TO US OUR
OUR- OUR OUR CULTURE ENERGY. WE
AGREE INGREDIENTS BY BY THE
DROUGHT IN THE LOW FLOW BEGIN
SO I KNOW WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT TWO. FORTY MINUTES
THAT'S FIVE ONE FROM NOW YOU
KNOW POSTMASTER BE IN PLACE-RIGHT NOW IN A NICE NO ON MY
VERY PASSION. ABOUT WHAT I DO
AND HOW HARD IT WERE. ALL MY
ACCOUNTS STAFF FROM PEOPLE
WE'RE WE'RE VERY HARD WORKING-
PEOPLE THAT SMOKE WORKING IT
DONE. GIVE US A WE ARE IN A NOW
UNTIL TWENTY TWO THOUSAND TWO
IS HERE. IS HERE NOW. ACTION
NEEDED TAKEN NOW. RIBE CHAIRMAN
ALBURY FROM THE CREW TRIED
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US TODAY FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. IN A GERMAN JEWS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE THERE
ARE SEVERAL BILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING THAT IS NOW MOVING.
THANKS TO THE FOCUS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR NEWSOM AS
WELL- MOVING NEEDS DROUGHT
DOLLARS WHETHER IT'S INTO
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES
IN. SANTA CRUZ COUNTY- OUR DOWN
SOUTH IN L. A. COUNTY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO THERE
IS SOME RELIEF ON THE WAY AND I
WANT TO SAY. THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF VICE YOUR STONE
MYSELF. THANK YOU TEACHER AND
BURY INTERCHANGE FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY. ALRIGHT LADIES IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO OUR THIRD PANEL-
IN THAT'S DROUGHT IN IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL. FISHERIES WE HAVE
AN ALL STAR PANEL WITH US FIRST
AND FOREMOST WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING BUT MEAN JAMES STONE MR
STONE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NOR CAL GUIDES AND SPORTSMEN'S
ASSOCIATION. WITHIN GET A
WELCOME TO THE HEARING BARRY
NELSON. HE IS FOCUS ON ALL
ISSUES OF POLICY FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE SALMON ASSOCIATION. AND
MIKE CONROY HE'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AGAIN GIVING US A
PERSPECTIVE AS WHAT WE SAID IN
THE BEGINNING- SALMON HELP
BUILD OUR ECONOMY. THE WEALTH
OF THIS STATE IN EACH OF THESE
REPRESENTATIVES ARE GOING TO BE
SPEAKING TO THAT AN IMPACT.
THAT DISTRAUGHT AND- THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION'S WATER POLICIES
HAD ON THE SALMON FISHERY SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'RE GOING
TO OPEN IT UP TO MR STONE. AND
MR STONE WE WELCOME YOU SIR YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES WE'LL GIVE
YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT YOU
NOW IN COMMITTEE THE FLOOR. IS
YOURS GOOD MORNING MR STONE. IN
CENTER I'M GONNA SHOW MY SISTER.
WILL DO. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU MISTER SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JIM STONE
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION I
CURRENTLY SELDOM REWARDED
COMMITTEES ON THE SLIDE THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO
PRESENT TO YOU THIS MORNING ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SALMON
INDUSTRY MY COMMENTS THIS
MORNING WILL BE TAILORED FOR
PROVIDING YOU KNOW VOICES ON
THOUSANDS OF RECREATIONAL AND
WHEN ANGLERS AND HUNTERS ARE
RIVER GUIDES. I AM IN A
RECREATIONAL INLAND SALMON
FISHING GUIDE FOR OVER TEN
YEARS MYSELF MY MEMBERS AND I
MAYOR RATIONAL HOMES ON THE
WATER WE COLLECTIVELY. SPEND
MORE TIME ON THE WATER. SYSTEMS
AND ANY. STATE OR- PUBLIC STOCK.
WE ARE INTIMATELY FROM WITH OUR
SYSTEM TO HELP ISSUE REASON CAN.
TO YOU INDEED WE ARE WITNESSING
EVERY DAY ON THE WATER. TODAY'S
SAM RUNS AND NEVER READ. SINCE
THE LAST. AND THOUSAND IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN. OR ARE LISTED NOW
AND WHEN THE LADY VOLS SLIDE IN
THE NEXT. NATIONAL TREE SERVICE
SCALING IN MESILLA. FOR YEARS.
HATCHERY MANAGER PLANS ARE NOT
WORK. ACTUALLY THE ONLY MAN
FOR. JIM NUMBER ENOUGH. THIS
SINGLE SPECIES. MAINLY IMPACTS
ON THE RUN ALREADY WATER.
INLAND FISHING OPPORTUNITIES
INSTEAD DECLINE SINCE TWO SEVEN
GUYS THE ANGLER ARE LEAD AND
NOT. AND ECONOMIC INJURE IN THE
AND OR IS BECAUSE- WHY A
GRAPHICAL AND OF ALL SONOMA
SALMON IN THIS SYSTEM SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE. ADELINE AND A
MINIMUM X. HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
DOLLARS STRONG REQUIRE BY
NATIONAL RESEARCH RESEARCH.
THAT NUMBER COMPRISE TWENTY TWO
DOLLAR ALL THREE TURN TO PASS
REASON HOW THOUSAND THE
NATIONAL AREAS AS YOU CAN SEE.
NOT ONLY HOW TOTAL NUMBER
DECLINE SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWO
WE'RE NOT EVEN MEET OR MIDDLE
STAFF SCHOOLS AND FOURTEEN YEAR.
IT ONE THING I FROM J. DAYS S.
NOT IN OFFICE RETURNING REVERSE
THANKSCASE WALLS TOO LOUD AND
MODELING IS. AND IN TO
ACCURATELY. SOLUTION RENDON'S
MAY BE LEADING TO OSHA. OVER
HARVEST AND LIMITING RETURN.
DATA COLLECTION AND LINDA FOR.
HER AND RELIES ON INTERNALLY.
REAL SURVEYS AN EXTRA TO
DETERMINE AN RUN WHICH IS OFTEN
AT. WE WERE ELECTRONIC LOGBOOKS
REAL TIME HONOR TODAY THIS WHEN
AROUND THE THEY WILL MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY ARE NAY HURT FALL RUN
SAY AFTER SPAWNING ANNUALLY AS
MUCH AS. FORTY BUT- WOULDN'T
SAY HOW OR AS INTENDED. BY THE
NUMBERS INDICATE THIS IS FAR
FROM THE TREE. WE NOW HAVE A
TAKES WE ARE GET OUT WHAT WE
PUT IN TRUST SESSIONS US ALL
THE ILLUSION OF THE SENATE
INDUSTRY IS OKAY. MEASURED AS-
OCEAN. MEANWHILE IN THE RETURN
CONTINUE MEET. CONDITIONS IN
YOUR TOTAL COLLAPSE. HATCHERIES
ARE YOU. PERFECT HEALTHY ADULTS.
TREASON WHOLESALE WHOLESALE
SEAFOOD COMPANY THAT HOLDS THE
ON. WASHINGTON STATE FOR SALE
ACTUALLY SHOULD ONLY FISH
SPAWNING RAISING FISH. AS
TEMPERATURES INCREASE COAL AND
OUT QUESTIONS OF CONTINUING TO
RAISE FEWER LARGER. AS OPPOSED
TO SMALLER FISH FRY. THINGS GET
WORSE LIKE WE USED TO ONLY
NATURAL FISH LONGER TO GROW
MEANS SUBJECT THEM HEART RIVERS
MANAGERS AND LOCAL TO
BURGEONING AND- WE SHOULD REACH
TO PRODUCING HIGHER NUMBERS
RYAN. THE SYSTEM WITH THEM AND
WE EARLIER RELEASED UNDER.
SINCE AND TO USE TO READ AND I
OUR NATIONAL CORNERS AS AN
EXAMPLE COLEMAN YOU TO RAISE
MILLION FOR THEN WENT TO FOUR
MILLION FOR AND NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT NOW WE ALL REYES MILLION
SOULS STATE HATCHERIES RECALL A
FEW. WITH REDUCE PRODUCTION
SINCE. TWO THOUSAND. TRUCKING
SALMON IS NOT A COMPLETE FULL.
TRACKING THE OCEAN REAL ON
FUNCTIONING. RESULT RETURN
THREE RANGE. ISSUE I THRILLED
SYSTEM. MOST HATCHERIES MAKES
RETURN RESULT TOO MANY ON THE
RELEASE LOCATE TIME. BUT SOME.
ALEX DEVASTATING. THANKS ARE
ONLY WORSE BETTER SPRINGER
CHINOOK ON THE CLAIM SYSTEM
JUST LIST AND YOU TWENTY ONE.
MISSION NO ACTUALLY FISH WERE
RELEASED ON THE OF THIS YEAR
TEMPERATURES. HAVE REPRODUCTION
CAN. IS MISSING EXPECT TARGET.
TRANSACTION IN ONE. ANGLING IS.
IN ONE ROOM- RECREATION FISHING
IS RISKING NO. IN THE ARE SORRY
FEATHER RIVER NEVER MISS AN
YUBA. VIRTUALLY NO NASH SIGNING
SACRAMENTO FISH LAUGHED IN ONE
ST AQUACULTURE ISN'T. THERE IS
A WERE ECONOMIC IN OF THIS THIS
VALLEY DISH IS NOT FROM OVER
NINETY MILLION. ANNUAL INTO
INTO THOUSAND TWO DOWN AND
JUST. TWO MILLION DOLLARS LAST
YEAR FROM READY TO SACRAMENTO
IN THE PAST TWENTY YEARS
FINALLY REDUCTIONS IN SALMON
ABUNDANCE ARE IMPACTING THE ESA
LISTED SOUTHERN RESIDENT KILLER
WHALES. CALIFORNIA STAMINA. TWO
SOURCES. LAST SLIDE LET FRIENDS
DAMAGE WE NEED TO INVEST
MODERNIZE OR HAS AND BUILDING A
NEW HOUSE ST NEW INCREASE
HATCHERY AND WAS SAYING. MORE
HATCHER FISH AND DO WE NEED TO
STOP KILLING ON SMALL.
COMMANDERS THANKS IS LIKE A
SEPARATE WE'RE ON RIVER AND
FUNCTIONAL HAS LATTER GANESAN'S
HSR HE CALL. COULD REDUCE THESE.
WE A LEGISLATURE MAN.
CONSISTENT WATER FLOW TO AVOID
NATIONALS TAX ARBITRAGE
RESPONSE SHOULD BE RE AND I
**** SPAWNING AREAS AND RIVER
WITH HATCHERY FRY TO START THE
PROCESS OF REBUILDING OUR-
FINANCIAL IS NEEDED FOR WONDER
JACKSON'S IMMEDIATELY. AND FOR
THIS YOU TWENTY ONE THIS WOULD
INCLUDE RELIEF FOR. LICENSED
WHO MAKE THEIR LIVINGS ON
REVERSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I'M AVAIL FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MY HAVE. THIS A
GREAT PICTURE WHEN I TO SOME
GALA AND HIS LAST YEAR OUT SHE
AND AS CAUGHT. ALL STAR
REVERTING SAY. THIS IS ALL A
SLIDE WARMING J. LEGISLATOR
AIDES FISHING FROM MY DIFFERENT
OFFICES AND THEY CAME EXPIRY
ISSUE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
PRIOR TO COMING. AND I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THE TIMES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER THAT AS- MR VICE THAT
MAY GALLAGHER WAS. LOOKS LIKE
PART WAY ALL THAT IS A- SAM-
GOODNESS. NICE JOB STONE WE'RE
GRATEFUL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE NOR CAL GUIDES IN SPORTSMAN
ASSOCIATION. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT PANELIST
AND AGAIN WE'LL DO QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS HERE AT THE END OF
THIS PANEL. WE'RE GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO BURY NELSON HE'S
POLICY REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE SALMON
ASSOCIATION. MISTER NELSON WE
TALKING TO THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
REALLY THE CHALLENGING IMPACTS
THAT WERE SEEN WITH SO MUCH
WATER FLOWING TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- IN HOW REPEATING THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST. COULD%
LEAD TO SAM IN EXTENSION
ESPECIALLY ON THE SACRAMENTO.
HE'S ALSO GOING TO PROVIDING US
WITH SOME POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
SITUATION MISTER NELSON WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES I DON'T GIVE
YOU. THIRTY SECOND PROMPT GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU CHAIR OF
MCGUIRE I AM SHE- THE- MY
SCREEN TO START SLIDE. SALAMI
THANK YOU UP AND RUNNING. AT
THAT HEARING YOU ARE LOOKING
GOOD WE GOT IT LOUD AND CLEAR
THANK YOU SO MUCH HEY. WE GO
BACK TO THE START OF THE SITE
OF PRESENTATION- THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN- MCGUIRE MR STONE
JERRY NELSON WITH THE GOLDEN
STATE SALMON ASSOCIATION THIS
IS A REPRESENTS THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA'S SALMON FISHING
INDUSTRY THAT WHEN HEALTHY
SUPPORTS ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND JOBS. WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU NOT
JUST FOR THIS HEARING BUT FOR
YOUR HELP OVER MANY YEARS ON A
RANGE OF SALMON ISSUES THIS IS
A PHOTO OF THERMAL AFTER BEING
ON THE FEATHER RIVER. WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS ON SOLVING THE
THERMAL POLLUTION PROBLEM HELLO
THIS AFTEREFFECTS TO YOUR
INVOLVEMENT. THANKS ALSO BY THE
WAY FOR YOUR GREAT STAFF TOM
LOW WESSEL OF CONSISTENTLY
OFFERS WISE COUNSEL TO OUR
COMMUNITY. JAPON OF MENTION
DIRECTOR BONTA MENTIONED THE
LONG TERM DECLINE OF SALMON
THIS IS A OF THE SHOWS THAT
DECLINE DRAMATICALLY WE NEED
YOUR HELP MORE THAN EVER. AND
JUST A REMINDER- THE SALMON DIE
OFF THIS YEAR ON THE SECOND
RIVER IS NOT CAUSED BY DROUGHT
IT'S NOT CAUSED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE. IS CAUSED BY WATER
MANAGEMENT OF THIS IS A PHOTO
OF THE DRY SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
WASN'T DROUGHT OR WATER OR- LET
ME CHANGE THE DRIED. UP THIS
RIVER IT WAS WATER MANAGEMENT-
ALL FORTY THERE ARE WE DO A
THIS. SUITS SITUATION AND A
PRESENT FOR RECOMMENDATIONS AT
THE END OF MY TESTIMONY. YOU
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THE
ANTICIPATED FISH KILL IN THE
SECOND RIVER FOR WINTER RUN
SALMON. AS DIRECTOR BONTA
MENTIONED THAT KILL IS ALREADY
WELL UNDER WAY ADULT WHEN
AROUND HOLDING BELOW THE DAM
ALL OF THE REST OF OR ARE
ALREADY DYING. OF THIS FISH
KILL IS NOT BEING CAUSED BY
DROUGHT IT'S BEING BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF EXCESSIVE WATER
DELIVERIES THAT ARE DRAINING
SHASTA DAM- AND CAPEL MAY
DISCUSS THAT MORE DETAILS BUT
I'D BE HAPPY TO AS WELL. JUST A
REMINDER OF WHAT THOSE FISH
KILLS CAN LOOK LIKE THESE ARE
ADULT OF SALMON KILLED ON THE
KLAMATH IN TWO THOUSAND TWO. IN
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
BUREAU'S ACTION ON THE SECOND
RIVER WAS PROHIBITED UNDER THE
PREVIOUS BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS-
BUT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
THROUGHOUT THOSE BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS. REPLACE THEM WITH
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS THAT SHARES
YOU POINT OUT. LITERALLY
AUTHORIZES THE EXTINCTION OF
WINTER RUN SALMON. OF THE
BUREAU IS IMPLEMENTING THAT
EXTINCTION PLAN. AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD STOP IT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE STATE WATER
BOARD HAS PERMITTED THE
BUREAU'S FISH KILL THIS YEAR.
RECENTLY THE BUREAU HAS
CONFIRMED THAT IT'S PLANNING TO
HOLD EVEN LESS COLD WATER FOR
SPAWNING THE SPAWNING SEASON
THIS YEAR THAN IT ANTICIPATED.
THIS THIS- REMINDS US OF
EXACTLY WHAT WE HEARD IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY FIFTEEN. WE
FEAR THAT THE BOARD HASN'T
LEARNED A LESSON OF THOSE FISH
KILLS IN THOSE YEARS. AT THE
TIME THE BOARD'S EXECUTIVE
OPPOSITION THOSE DECISIONS WERE
A MISTAKE. BUT THE BOARD
FRANKLY APPEARS TO BE TREATING
THESE FISH KILLS ALMOST AS
BUSINESS AS USUAL THIS YEAR.
THIS WILL BE THE THIRD YEAR OF
NEAR TOTAL LOSS OF. WILD FISH
ON THE SACRAMENTO IN EIGHT
YEARS THAT'S CLEARLY
UNSUSTAINABLE. WE'RE NOT JUST
RISKING THE EXTENSION OF THE
WINTER RUN YOU ALSO HAVE HEARD
ABOUT IMPACTS TO THE TRIBAL TO
TRIBAL CULTURES THE DEPEND ON
SALMON. OF THE FISHING
COMMUNITIES ALSO HIGHLY
REGULATED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO NOT ACTUALLY RUN FISH. ON
THAT MEANS THAT THIS WINTER RUN
FISH KILL IS GOING TO RESULT IN
MORE RESTRICTIONS ON FISHING
DOWN THE ROAD. FONG ALSO
IMPORTANT REMEMBER THAT WOULD
RUN IS NOT THE ONLY SPECIES IN
JEOPARDY YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
IMPACTS TO KLAMATH FISH. THOUGH
THE FALL RUN FISH ALL ON THE
SACRAMENTO OR AND IN DANGER OF
BEING. VIRTUALLY ENTIRELY WIPED
OUT. AND THESE ARE SPRING RUN
CHINOOK ON BUTTE CREEK WHERE
WERE ALREADY BEGINNING TO LOSE
SPAWNING ADULTS. AND FISHERMEN
REMEMBER THE SHUTDOWN. OF
SALMON FISHING IN. 200-082-0009
WE KNOW THAT EACH ONE ONE OF
THOSE TO CALL. IS IN MORRIS FOR
OUR COMMUNITY DOWN THE ROAD. SO
THAT COMES TO SALMON YES YEARS
LOOKING LIKE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER IN ECONOMIC DISASTER
PROFESSIONAL AND A TRUE RED
DISASTER TRIBAL CULTURES AS
WELL SO WHAT TO DO ABOUT THAT-
YOU HEARD ABOUT OF TRUCKING
TRUCK ON A MENTION THAT ALL MY
OF THE CDFW SHOULD COMMIT TO
TRUCKING OVER THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HATCHELL HATCHERY
JUVENILES NEXT YEAR. AS THEY
DID THIS YEAR- AND RELEASING
THOSE JUVENILES IN THE WEST
FARE IN THE OCEAN THESE ARE
OUR- A NET PEN HE'S OUR OUR OF
FISH AT FOR BIGGER MARIN COUNTY
PREPARING TO RELEASE FISH.
HERE'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN-THEY'RE RELEASED INTO A NET FAN
THIS ONE IS IN HALF MOON BAY
AND WE'VE LEARNED THAT WEST BAY
RELEASE SITES SHOWN HERE IN
ORANGE AND OCEAN WE SITES OF
THE PRODUCER RIVAL AT MUCH
HIGHER RATES THAN TRADITIONAL
RECEIPTS RELEASED CITING GREEN
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
ALSO LEARNED THAT FOR SOME
FISH. THE AMERICAN FEDERAL
PARTICULAR THESE REALLY SITES.
DO NOT INCREASE STRAIGHT RATES.
THE SALMON CAUGHT THIS YEAR IN
THE OCEAN OUR LARGELY FROM
THESE HATCHERY RELEASES OF THEY
SHOW THAT THESE RELEASES ARE
WORKING. OF THE FLEET HAS LOST
ABOUT 60% THE OCEAN FLEET ABOUT
60% OF A NORMAL SEASON THEY'RE
STILL CATCHING FISH AND THAT'S
OUR RESERVE RESULT OF.
NATURALLY'S POLICIES. FINALLY
ON THIS ISSUE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO
SELL WE ARE SHOWN ON THE MAP.
IS LIKELY BECAUSE OF THE WAY
FISH MOVE IN THE OCEAN TO BE
LESS RESTRICTED PROFESSION THAN
THE OTHER THAN THE NORTH COAST
FOR MONTEREY BAY TO THE SOUTH.
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE A HATCHERY
RELEASES TO THE BAY A LIFELINE
FOR THE OCEAN FISHERY. FOR THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS UNTIL WE
RESTORE HEALTHY RIVERS. SO WHAT
ELSE CAN WE DO. MENTION THE
HATCHERY RELEASES SECOND THE
STATE BOARD SHOULD TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AGAINST- THE
SHASTA AGAINST THE BUREAU FOR
SHASTA DAM OPERATIONS THIS
YEAR. THIRD THE STATE PORTION
UP WOMEN IN EMPLOYMENT UPDATE
AND IMPLEMENT A BAIT OUT OF A
PLAN OF. FLOW REQUIREMENTS THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS PROCESS
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO SUBSTITUTE
FOR THAT PROCESS HAS FAILED-
FOURTH. THE STATE SHOULD
IMMEDIATELY NOT IN OCTOBER AS
CHUCK AS MR BONTA MENTION BUT
TODAY THE STATE SHOULD CALL FOR
THE STATE TO THE FEDS TO
IMMEDIATELY. BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF RE WRITING THE TRUMP
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS WHAT WE
CALL THE TRUMP EXTINCTION. PLAN
FRANKLY. THIS CHAIR MISSED
STONE- WE CAN LET KILLS A- AND
RESTRICTIONS ON SALMON FISHING
BECOME BUSINESS AS USUAL IN
CALIFORNIA. THE IMPACTS TO
SALMON SALMON COMMUNITY OF THE-
THE ENVIRONMENT THE TRIBES AND
BUSINESSES IS SIMPLY TOO GREAT.
OUR STATE AGENCIES CAN AND MUST
DO BETTER AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU. IMPLEMENT
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
MAINTAIN A HEALTHY BAY DELTA
SYSTEM- HEALTH EXAMINER RUNS
AND HEALTHY HEALTHY FISHING
INDUSTRY THANK YOU. MISTER
JOHNSON THANK YOU SO MUCH
pMISTER NELSON CONCERT SEVEN
ASSOCIATION ARMY HEARING BACK
FROM MISTER NELSON MR STONE IN
JUST A BIT. BUT FIRST AND
FOREMOST WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE
COMMITTEE OVER TO MIKE CONROY
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST. FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION MR
CONROY IS GOING TO GIVE US AN
UPDATE ON THE STATUS OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMERCIAL SALMON
FISHERY. IN IMPACTS THAT THE
DROUGHT IN WATER POLICIES HAVE
ON HIS MEMBERS AS WELL AS OUR
OVERALL WHILE THE SEAFOOD
SUPPLY. IN THEN ALSO HE'S GONNA
TELL US THE LESSONS WE CAN
LEARN FROM DROUGHT. THAT WE HAD
JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS AGO MR
CONROY WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE YOU ARE AT NOW IN
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
SOME GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT. PLEASE PRECEDING GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR. THANK YOU I JUST
CAN NUMBER ONE YOU HEAR ME
NUMBER TO YOU CAN MY SCHOOL. WE
GET JUST UP IN YOUR COMING IN
LATIN MISTER CONROY. WELL
FANTASTIC. GOOD MORNING SHERMAN
WIRE CHAIR STONY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AND MY CALL IN RADIO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS. THE
CFA IS THE LARGEST ORGANIZATION
OF COMMERCIAL HARVESTERS ON THE
WEST COAST. WITH COMMERCIAL
SALMON TROLLERS BANNING THE
STATE FROM SAN DIEGO TO
CRESCENT CITY. OUR MEMBERS
PROVIDE YEARS SUSTAINABLE
HOOKED ONLINE TROLL CAUGHT
SALMON CAUGHT OFF AND LANDED IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR MEMBERS
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF PACIFIC SALMON.
AND UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF HEALTHY SALMON STOCKS FOR
THEIR FUTURES. THE LONG TERM
VIABILITY IN THE STATE'S
COMMERCIAL FISHERIES. THE LOCAL
SEAFOOD ECONOMY AND THE STATE'S
FOOD SECURITY WE ARE HERE TODAY
TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP CONCERN FOR
THE FUTURE CALIFORNIA'S SALMON.
CALIFORNIA SALMON FISHERY. AND
ALL PEOPLE DEPENDENT ON THEM.
FIRST SOME GOOD NEWS. WELL
PRESEASON. DEVOTION ABUNDANCE.
IN REDUCED OPPORTUNITY. THE
DEPARTMENT IS ESTIMATED THE
FISHERIES ARMS IN JUST UNDER A
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
FISH THUS FAR WHICH FAR EXCEEDS
EXPECTATIONS. PRICES HAVE
GENERALLY BEEN GOOD. THUS FAR
WHICH IS A MUCH NEEDED SHOT IN
THE ARM FOR THOSE SALMON
HARVESTERS WHO SUFFERED THROUGH
A CHALLENGING CRAB SEASON. I
WANT TO TALK A MINUTE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF SALMON FISHERIES
TO THE PORTS UP AND DOWN THE
COAST. THIS SLIDE SHOWS THE
DEPENDENCE OF CALIFORNIA PORTS
AND HARBORS ABOVE SANTA BARBARA
ON THE COMMERCIAL SALMON
FISHERY FOR EXAMPLE IN. PARTS
IN AROUND MORAL BAY IN 201940%
OF ALL ITS SPECIAL FISHING
REVENUES WERE DERIVED FROM THE
SALMON FISHERY. THIS IS
IMPORTANT AND TWENTY NINETEEN
IS USED BECAUSE THAT'S THE LAST
YEAR UPON WHICH DATA IS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE FACT BUT EXTRA
VESSEL FISHING REVENUES ARE
THOSE ARE AMOUNTS PAID TO
HARVESTERS IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE DOWNSTREAM ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF THOSE FISH. MEMBERS A LARGER
FISHING COMMUNITY BUYERS
PROCESSORS FUEL DOCKS AND
FEDERAL ALL DRIVE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS FROM OUR OPERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA'S SAUDI SECRET
CONSUMERS WHO DEMAND LOCAL
SUSTAINABLY SOURCED SEAFOOD.
AND WHO WANT TO KNOW THE
HARVESTER DERIVE INTRINSIC
BENEFITS. WHAT ABOUT CLAN THE
STOCK. AS WELL. THIS IS WHAT
THE IMPACT CLIMATE STOCKS SHOWN
BY ONE ABSENCE THE EVERY REGION
ON THE SLIDE THAT NUMBER TO THE
LOWELL PORTENTS OF SALMON TO
FORT BRAGG FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
FORT BRAGG HISTORICALLY IS NEAR
THE TOP OF CALIFORNIA'S SALMON
LANDINGS THE 201-900-1000
POUNDS WERE LANDED INTO FORT
BRAGG REGION WELL ONE MILLION
POUNDS WERE LANDED IN SAN
FRANCISCO AREA. COASTAL PORTS
IN THE REGION AND FORT BRAGG
REGIONS HAVE EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS TO THEIR
COMMERCIAL FLEETS IN PRODUCTION
SUPPORTING THOSE FLEETS AND
LOTS OF SUPPORTING SERVICES DUE
LARGELY TO SALMON WATER
MISMANAGEMENT. THE SUBPART
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DUNGEONS CRAB
SEASON WILL LIKELY RESULT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DATA SHOWING
EVEN GREATER AND IT'S ON THE
SENATE JUDICIARY. ON JULY SIXTH
THE DEPARTMENT KNOWLEDGE THE
POSSIBILITY THAT NEARLY ALL IN
RIVERINE RIVER JUVENILE SALMON
WILL NOT SURVIVE THIS SEASON
THE HEAT WAVE IS A CONVENIENT
CULPRIT AND MAY HAVE
EXACERBATED THE PROBLEM. BUT
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED
BUT FOR FAILED WATER POLICIES.
WELL BLAME FALLS ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOT ALL THE PLANS
STATE OWNS THIS AS WELL. WELL
SEVEN DIED TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
FORECAST TO BE THE SECOND HIS
ALMOND HARBORS IN HISTORY WE
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR WE ARE
CALLING SAID THE MANY FAMILY
RUN FARMS ARE SUFFERING WHEN
EQUITY NEEDS TO PLAY A ROLE IN
STATE WATER POLICY. THIS POLICY
ALSO RAISE SOCIAL JUSTICE
CONCERNS. MY SMALL FAMILY RUN
FARMERS. SENATE DEPENDENT
PEOPLES LIVING IN RURAL COASTAL
COMMUNITIES ARE BEARING A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
IMPACT OF THOSE POLICIES.
WARNING LESSONS FROM THE PAST
IN EIGHTY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
ISSUED ROUGHLY FIVE THOUSAND
COMMERCIAL SEVEN PERMITS. BY
TWENTY TWENTY THEY'RE A BIT
OVER THOUSAND PERMITS OF THOSE
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO MADE
AT LEAST ONE LANDING. AND SIXTY
FOUR VESSELS ACCOUNTED FOR HALF
OF THE TOTAL AND IT'S- LESS
THAN 10% OF THE ORIGINAL FLEET
THERE'S LESS FISHING IN
CALIFORNIA AFTER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. UNLESS THIS TREND IS
REVERSED THERE WILL BE FEWER
HARVESTERS AND SO FEW HAMID
SALMON TO HARVEST OF THE
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN NO LONGER
BE VIABLE. THE HOUSE OF CARDS
WILL BEGIN TO CRUMBLE. IN
THINKING ABOUT WHAT ACTIONS WE
TAKE TODAY AND TOMORROW WE NEED
TO THINK LONG TERM. THE NEXT
THREE TO FIVE YEARS WILL BE
CRITICAL FOR CALIFORNIA'S
COMMERCIAL FISHING INDUSTRY. WE
BELIEVE THE FOLLOWING ACTIONS
WILL BE HELPFUL IN MAXIMIZING
THE CHANCES OF A VIABLE FISHERY
IN YEARS TO COME. WE FULLY
SUPPORT SUGGESTED NAY BY THE
TRIBAL LEADERS. ENVELOPED IN MY
FELLOW PANEL MEMBERS. WE NEED
FLEXIBILITY IN HATCHERY
OPERATIONS TO ENSURE MAXIMUM
CHANCES OF SURVIVAL. WE APPLAUD
THE DEPARTMENT'S ACTIONS IN
HOLDING OFF RELEASING IRON GATE
SESSION TO THE KLAMATH. IN MAY
OR JUNE WHEN RIVER CONDITIONS
WHAT OF ALL BUT ASSURED
UNACCEPTABLE LEVELS OF
MORTALITY. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT GIVEN THIS YEAR'S
JUVENILES ARE EXPECTED TO BE
THE FIRST. TO RETURN TO A
KLAMATH FREE OF DOWNS. YOU TOO
CAN TO TRUCKING. JUVENILES PART
GOALS TO RELEASED WITH HIGHER
SURVIVED. I THINK VERY OUTLINED
THAT. VERY EFFECTIVELY. WE NEED
TO CONSIDER SOLAR PANELS THE
TECHNOLOGY WHICH COULD BENEFIT
SALMON. A RECENT UC SANTA CRUZ
STUDY ESTIMATED THAT COVERING
CALIFORNIA'S IRRIGATION CANALS
OF SOLAR PANELS. COULD SAVE SIX
POINT THREE FIVE BILLION
GALLONS OF WATER FROM
EVAPORATION ANNUALLY WHILE ALSO
GENERATING SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY. WE NEED TO
CONSIDER PROGRAM WHICH
ENCOURAGE FARMERS WHOSE LANDS
OTHERWISE SUBJECT BEING FILED
UNDER STATE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT. TO COVER THAT
LAND TO SOLAR POWER GENERATION.
IN CONCLUSION. WE HOPE THIS
HEARING RESULTS IN ACTIONS.
WITHOUT MEANINGFUL ACTIONS IT
IS NOT OUTSIDE THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY THAT WE MAY LOSE
ICONIC SALMON RUNS. NON TRIBAL
COMMERCIAL SALMON HARVESTERS
HAVE OPERATED IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE THE EARLY EIGHTEEN
FIFTIES. ABSENT NECESSARY AND
MEANINGFUL ACTIONS THIS FISHERY
MAY NOT. SEE THE LATTER PART OF
TWENTY TWENTY. THANK YOU. HIS
ACCOUNT THANK YOU SO MUCH. MIKE
THE EXIT DIRECTOR THE PACIFIC
FEDERATION FISHERMAN'S. WE LIKE
TO BE TO OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
COMMITTEE AND LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO MISTER NELSON- MISTER
ISSUE OF THE SHASTA TEMPERATURE
MANAGEMENT PLAN- LOOK. I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE IN THIS
HISTORIC DROUGHT BUT IT'S BEING
MADE WORSE IN ONE OF THE MAIN
DRIVERS OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WERE SEEN AS POTENTIAL
EXTINCTION EVENT. ON THE
SACRAMENTO IS BASED OFF THOSE
POLICIES IN THE PRIOR FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION SO TALK TO US
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME DISAGREEMENT.
ON THAT BUT IF YOU DON'T MIND
GIVE US A TWO MINUTE DEEP DIVE
TWO MINUTE DEEP DIVE. ON WHY IT
IS SO DIZZY DISASTERS IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE SACRAMENTO.
A COUPLE OF REASONS FIRST THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION CHAIRMAN
OF FIRST THE YOUR RECOGNITION
RUN SHASTA DAM THE CONTROLS
FLOWS ON THE SACRAMENTO RIVER.
UNDER THE PREVIOUS BIOLOGICAL
OPINION THERE WAS A REQUIREMENT
THAT- THAT THE BUREAU HOLD
ENOUGH COLD WATER IN STORAGE AT
SHASTA DAM TO PROVIDE COLD
WATER FOR OF FOR SPAWNING FISH
IN THE FALL ALSO TO PROVIDE A
RESERVE SO THAT THERE'S WATER
SUPPLY AVAILABLE AND IN IN CASE
THE FOLLOWING YEAR'S DRY. BUT
THOSE THINGS HAVE CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY THIS THIS CURRENT
BIOLOGICAL OPINION BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION- HAS ELIMINATED
A COUPLE THINGS COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED THE COURT KERRY
RESTORED REQUIREMENTS SO
INSTEAD OF ONE POINT NINE
MILLION ACRE FEET OF WATER IN
STORAGE. THIS YEAR THE BUREAU
MAY HAVE A MILLION MAY HAVE
LESS THAN A MILLION ACRE FEET
OF WATER ALMOST HALF OF WHAT
WAS REQUIRED PREVIOUSLY THAT'S
THE REASON. THERE IS AN
ADEQUATE COLD WATER- AND
THEY'RE RELEASING MORE WATER WE
BELIEVE THEN IS- THAN SHOULD BE
ALLOWED UNDER STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WATER USE
LAWS HAPPY TO EXPLAIN THAT IN
ADDITION SECOND. THE NEW TRUMP
POLICY DOESN'T JUST ELIMINATE
THE CARRYOVER STORAGE
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN LEGALIZES
THE FISHKILL. OF THE IN THE AND
YOU MENTION THIS BRIEFLY OF
THIS BIOLOGICAL OPINION ALLOWS
THE BUREAU TO KILL IT'S NOT
EXAGGERATION. EVERY SINGLE
ENDANGERED WINTER RUN SALMON
BELOW SHASTA DAM FOR THREE
YEARS RUNNING WHAT HAPPENED
WHAT HAPPENED THEN. IS
RENEGOTIATION OF MULTI YEAR
INITIATION PROCESS WOULD BEGIN
THAT'S A PLAN FOR EXTINCTION-
THE NEXT THING IT SEEMS VERY
ONE GIVEN INTENSELY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT THE
BIOLOGICAL OPINION ESTABLISHES
THE BUREAU WAS THE FINAL
DECISION MAKER OF THEIR
OPERATIONS. ACTUALLY DOESN'T
GIVE FEDERAL BIOLOGISTS AT THE
NATIONAL FISHERIES SERVICE THE
ABILITY TO SAY THAT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH YOU CAN'T IMPLEMENT THAT
PLAN YOU HAVE TO BETTER FOR
SALMON THOSE ENDANGERED SALMON
PARTICULAR YOU HAVE THOSE THREE
THINGS TOGETHER AND IT REALLY
IS AN EXTENSION PLAN. WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED- MR BOTTOMS
RIGHT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID SAY WILL BEGIN
CONSULTATION IN OCTOBER FRANKLY
THAT'S TOO LATE. WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CITED ONE REASON FOR
DELAYING RE CONSULTATION. IS A
CALL VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
PROCESS THE PROCESS THAT HAS
FAILED FOR YEARS IT'S FAILED
FOR TO GET FOUR CONSECUTIVE
DEADLINES ABOUT TO FEEL THE HIT
ITS FIFTH DEADLINE- SO WE'RE
DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT THOSE.
ANTIQUATED ANTI ENVIRONMENTAL
ANTI SALMON ANTI TRIBAL ALL OF
TRUMP. WATER POLICIES ARE STILL
IN PLACE AND THE PROCESS OF RE
WRITE THOSE FOLLOW. IS MOVING
VERY SLOW NO THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND FOR THE DEEP DIVE AT BURY
NELSON GOLDEN STATE SENATE SO.
AND MR AND I'M GONNA GO TO MR
CONROY- IS WELL HI. IN THE
CONCERN IS WHILE WE MAY BE SEEN
A GOOD YEAR THIS YEAR RIGHT-
IT'S BASED OFF OF. PREVIOUS
YEARS IN EVEN IF WE WENT WHEN.
THE SALMON GO TO SPAWN IN THEIR
HOME STREAM THOSE AIDES VERY
LIKELY TO BE COOKED BASED OFF
OF THE CHALLENGE WATER
CONDITIONS THAT WE HAVE. SO
WHILE WE SEE A GOOD YEAR-
MISTER NELSON FIRST- THOSE EGGS
THAT. MAY BE COMING- WILL MOST
LIKELY BE COOKED HERE. IN THE
CONDITIONS THAT WERE SEEN WHICH
IS GOING TO. EXACERBATE THE
ISSUE OF- BAD STOCK HERE IN
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS MR
NELSON IN A NO GO TO MR CONROY.
E. L. FIRST I WANT TO MAKE SURE
I KNOW IN MY COUNTER WILL WILL
UPDATE THIS EVEN MORE. ON THAT
THIS YEAR IS IN A GOOD YEAR THE
FLEET BECAUSE OF THE STATE OF
THE RUNS. ARE IN THE ADULT
POPULATION OF THE OCEAN AND
THIS IS THE FLEE THE SAME
COMMERCIAL FLEE THE SCENE IT'S-
IT'S- TIME ON THE WATER
FISHING. CUT BY ALMOST TWO
THIRDS THIS YEAR AND IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF STATE SHUT
DOWN ENTIRELY BUT BUT IT IS
TRUE THAT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
FISHING IS GOOD OUT THERE.
THAT'S ENTIRELY BECAUSE OF
HATCHERY PRODUCTION AND-
TRUCKING OF FISH WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT RETURNS AS MR
STONE MANSION- AND- AND- AND
THE AGENCIES FACE A REALLY.
DISMAL PROSPECT THIS YEAR HAVE
FACED THIS YEAR ALL THEY COULD
EITHER TRUCK FISH- WHICH NONE
OF US OF. WHAT WE ALL OF US
WOULD LIKE TO SEE HEALTHY. IN
RIVER RUNS AND REDUCED AND
RELEASES IN THE RIVER FOR
HATCHERIES- BUT THEY'LL TURN IT
WAS TO RELEASE THOSE FISH THE
TO THE RIVERS AND SIMPLY LET
THEM DIE- SO WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THE FISH. THAT
ESCAPED TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THIS YEAR AND WE HOPE THIS YEAR
WE GET OUR ESCAPEMENT TARGET-
OF FACE REALLY DIRE CONDITIONS
THIS YEAR AND WE COULD FACE.
SIMILAR HATCHERY CONDITIONS
NEXT YEAR AND UNTIL HIS TRUCK
BOTTOM SET UNTIL WE REBUILD OF
THOSE WILD RUNS UNTIL WE DECIDE
TO PROTECT OUR RIVERS. WE THINK
WE DON'T HAVE MUCH CHOICE THE
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE
FISHERY BUT CERTAIN- BUT- DRUG.
SUMMER FISHING IT'S IMPORTANT
ALSO THAT WE WERE M. THAT ALL
OF OUR HANDS AND OTHER SAME
HAVE. THAT SOME OF OUR- CAN BE
TRIED IN TRUCK TO THOSE WEST
LOCATION WITHOUT WITHOUT
INCREASING STRAIGHT RIGHTS.
COMMISSION ASSEN THAT'S GONNA
MISTER CONROY. WHAT I'M TRYING
TO THINK OF A SOMETHING TO ADD
TO THAT THAT. STUPID IS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT VERY SAID-
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK
THE HIGH LIKELIHOOD OF EGGS
PRODUCED IN RIVER THIS YEAR. I
HAVE NO CHANCE OF SURVIVING AND
WE'RE NOT GONNA SEE THOSE
IMPACTS FOR AS YOU NOTED IN
YOUR IN YOUR OPENING REMARKS
FOR TWO TO TWO TO THREE YEARS.
SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO TAKE
WHAT ACTUALLY CHEN TODAY EITHER
BY TRUCK AND THE DEPARTMENT'S
DOING THAT BY TRUCKING AND
SACRAMENTO IN THE KLAMATH BY
HOLDING THOSE FISH OVER UNTIL
THE RIVER CONDITIONS ARE SUCH
THAT RELEASES MAKES SENSE IN A-
REDUCE THE MORTALITY THAT WE
NEED TO DO THAT THIS YEAR AND
LIKELY NEXT YEAR AS WELL. I
MEAN IT'S GOING TO TOUGH TIMES
THE NEXT THREE YEARS UNLESS WE
ARE PROACTIVE TAKE MEASURES AND
ENSURE THAT THAT WE'RE TAKING.
IT YEAH ACTION IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE NUMBER ONE SURVIVAL THE
STOCK NUMBER TWO THAT THE- THAT
OUR FISHERIES BOTH. COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL AND RIVER ARE ARE
ABLE TO SURVIVE THIS. THANK YOU
MISTER KHAN RIGHT IT'S GOING TO
MISTER STONE FOR OUR FINAL
QUESTION FOR THE PANEL MR
STONE. THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
THIS- IS BEING FELT THIS YEAR
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE FELT HERE
IN THE COMING TWO TO THREE
YEARS IN PARTICULAR. TALK TO US
ABOUT THIS I EVEN YOU CITED
SOME NUMBERS- THE CHALLENGE
THAT THE INDUSTRY SEEN RIGHT
NOW ON THE RECREATIONAL SIDE.
BUT REALLY THE WORST IS YET TO
COME FOR THOSE RECREATIONAL
GUIDES MR STONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MISTER SHARE- YEAH
SWEAR OR FACING AN ECONOMIC
COLLAPSE IN THE INLAND RIGHT
NOW THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE SINCE THE LAST CRISIS
LAST CLOSURE ACTUALLY- WE'VE
BEEN REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
TRYING TO GET THESE RUNS RE.
ESTABLISH AND GET PROPER FLOWS
IMPROPER PRODUCTION DONE AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE INDUSTRY. I
HAVE TAKEN IT. JUST KEEPS
GETTING HIT DROUGHT. FOURTEEN
AND- FOR. AND SIXTEEN THEN I
WILL STILL WAKE RIGHT SINCE-
FIRES IN EIGHTEEN AND- THAT HAS
LIMON. PEOPLE FROM TO OUR AREAS
FROM REAL THIS THE WAY UP TO
READ TO COME IS IT NOW WE LAS
AND- OF. THAT COME FROM OUT OF
STATE. INCOME FOR THE MAYOR SO
FOR LA THEY FLY IN ON JETS THAT
OUT ON COMMERCE AIRLINES THEY
DRY. ALL OF THAT ISN'T DRIVER
IN AS I'M IN MY- TATIAN. OUR
INDUSTRY AND SHE TWELVE. RUN IN
THE SAN VALLEY AT SEVEN AND
SEVEN NINE THOUSAND AND ALL SAN.
I SAW A NINETY MILLION DOLLARS.
IMPACT TO OUR. SACRAMENTO AND-
THE BLOOD WORK HISTORY AND I
LIVE. A LOT OF SHOPS AND
PRIMARY NOW WE'RE LOSING GUIDE
CONSTANTLY- I HAD MY OWN FOR
SAY THAT SHE ONE OF MY LARGEST
DOES BECAUSE OF THE CRISIS IN
BECAUSE I. TRYING TO STILL BY
AND YOU AND HOW WHEN IT COMES
JUST AND I JUST WANT SAY YOU
KNOW THE DROUGHT OUT IN AND IS
HER STAFF AND A LOT OF MY NINE
ARE IN A LOT RIGHT I MEAN I'M
JUST TRYING PAY YOUR MORTGAGE
TRYING DO ANY THEY CAN OR WAY
THERE. I THEY ARE UNABLE TO
FINISH AND OUR LOW WATER
BECAUSE OF THE WATER CONDITION
AND BECAUSE THE FISH RETURN
THAT ARE COMING BACK AND SO WE
ARE IN DIRE NEED OF ASSISTANCE
AND- WERE IN DIRE NEED IF WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO TAKE
FAMILIES AND TAKE CHILDREN AND
REINTRODUCE THEM TO SIXTEEN
THROUGH THE R. THREE PROGRAM
WHICH I'M INVOLVED IN WHICH IS
TO RECRUIT REACTIVATING RETAIN.
OUR FISHERMEN MEN AND WOMEN IN
ANGLERS CALIFORNIA AND FOR
TOURISM IN THE CALIFORNIA IF WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO TEACH OUR
NEXT GENERATION SUFFICIENT
EVERYTHING WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT TO SAVE OUR
FISHING BECAUSE WE ARE THE
TEACHERS ON THE RIVER OR THE
ONE TO TEACH PEOPLE HOW TO ACT
AND HOW TO RESPECT AND HOW TO
ENJOY WHAT WE ALL LOVE KNOWN AS
SAM THANK YOU. EXCHANGE STONE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE NOR CAL
GUIDES AND SPORTSMEN
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MR STONE VERY
NELSON OF THE GOLDEN STATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION MIKE CONROY
AT THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION
OF FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY THEIR ADVOCACY
THEIR HARD WORK AND LEADERSHIP
ESPECIALLY IN THESE CHALLENGING
TIMES IVING US A STATUS REPORT
DROUGHT IN THE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL. FISHERIES
GENTLEMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TODAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WERE NOW
COULD MEAN MOVING ON TO OUR
FINAL PANEL TODAY OUR FINAL
PANEL IS A GROUP OF EXPERTS WHO
HAVE SPENT LITERALLY DECADES
COMBINED IN DISTINGUISHED ROLES
WORKING ON WATER SAY WATERSHED
CONSERVATION. ON BEHALF OF FISH
THE ENVIRONMENT AND OF COURSE
THE GOOD PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WERE FIRST CAN HEAR FROM MARK
BRANSON CEO OF THE KLAMATH
RIVER CORPORATION THEN WE'RE
GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
KEEP COOL SHE'S A SENIOR
ATTORNEY. FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE CANCEL HEAR
FROM PATRICK'S. FROM THE AREA
REALLY TODAY AREA REACH
DIRECTOR. COUNTER OUT IN OF
COURSE THE ONLY MAC HILLS THE
EXACT ADDRESS. OF RIVERKEEPER
TO LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. WERE
HEAR FROM FOR. PANELISTS THEN
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
PHONE LINES. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
JOIN THIS YEAR AFTER THIS FINAL
PANEL. FEEL FREE TO HIT ASAP AT
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE AGAIN
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. PUBLIC TESTIMONY
AFTER OUR FINAL IN PANEL HERE.
TOLL FREE NUMBER. 877-692-8953
ALL RIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING TO
HEAR FROM MARK BRANSON
MISBRANDING AND PROVIDE US.
WITH A CRITICAL IN TIME THE
UPDATE AND STAND AS THE STATUS
AND PROGRESS OF CLIMATE DAM
REMOVAL. FROM THE FEDERALLY
FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION TODAY CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
ACROSS ALL STAKEHOLDERS. HE'S
GONNA HAVE AN EXHAUSTIVE UPDATE
PRICED AT MISTER RANSOM WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE
YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
WORKS OR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M MARK BRANSON
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
KLAMATH RIVER RENEWAL
CORPORATION. I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN REQUIRED VICE CHAIR
STONE BURKE CONVENING THIS
HEARING. AND INVITING THE
RENEWAL CORPORATION TO APPEAR.
I ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION PRETTY INSIGHTFUL
COMMENTS OFFERED BY ALL THE
PANELISTS THUS FAR. AND I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE RENEWAL
CORPORATION IS BUILDING ON THE
GOOD WORK DONE BY THE TRIBES
AND MANY OTHERS OVER MANY MANY
YEARS. THE REAL CORPORATION IS
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
FORMALLY TASKED WITH REMOVING
THE FOR LOWER KLAMATH RIVER
DAMS. AND IMPLEMENTING REQUIRED
REQUIRED MITIGATION MEASURES.
THE NONPROFIT WAS FORMED BASED
ON THE PROVISIONS OF THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN KLAMATH HYDROELECTRIC
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. EXECUTED
BY SIGNATORIES REPRESENTING
DIVERSE INTERESTS AND RESTORING
THE KLAMATH RIVER. THE OREGON
IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITY
MISSIONS AUTHORIZE RAPER. IN
THE STATE OF. PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL BOND FUNDS TO
IMPLEMENT DAM REMOVAL AS
PROPOSED IN THAT SETTLEMENT.
THE RENEWAL CORPORATION IS
HIGHLY SENSITIVE TO THE
CHALLENGING CONDITIONS FACED BY
THE MANY COMMUNITIES IN THE
KLAMATH RIVER BASIN WHO WERE
RELY ON THE RESOURCES OF THE
RIVER. THOSE COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
IMPACTS RESULTING FROM THE
DEEPENING DROUGHT AND RESULTING
REDUCED WATER SUPPLY AND
DEGRADED WATER QUALITY IN LIGHT
OF THESE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
BECAUSE IT'S GENERALLY ACCEPTED
THAT DAM REMOVAL ISONE
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT CAN BE
TAKEN TO REDUCE SOME OF THE
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES.
THE RENEWAL CORPORATION
CONTINUES TO DO ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR CONTROL
TO UNDERTAKE DAM REMOVAL IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE REMAIN
SIGNIFICANT REGULATORY MEASURES
THAT MUST BE COMPLETED BEFORE
WE CAN BEGIN WORK AND THAT SOME
RISK OF DELAY EXISTS. BUT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO POSITION
US TO BEGIN DAM REMOVAL AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME. IN SOME
WE PROPOSED TO REMOVE THE FOUR
DAMS OF THE LOWER KLAMATH
HYDROELECTRIC PROJECT J. C.
BOYLE COPCO NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO AND RON GATE DOWN.
ALONG WITH POWER HOUSES AND
OTHER PERTINENT FACILITIES TO
RESTORE FREE FLOWING CONDITIONS
AND VOLITIONAL FISH PASSAGE IN
THE KLAMATH RIVER. WE WILL ALSO
IMPLEMENT OTHER MEASURES TO
RESTORE FISH AND WILDLIFE
HABITAT IN THE D. WATER
RESERVOIR FOOTPRINTS AND
ELSEWHERE IN THE PROJECT
BOUNDARY. OUR WORK INCLUDES
PERFORMING VARIOUS FORMS OF
MITIGATION AND RESTORATION ON
NEARLY EIGHT THOUSAND ACRES OF
LANDS WHICH MAKE UP THE PROJECT
AREA. IN PREPARATION FOR DAM
REMOVAL THE RENEWAL CORPORATION
IN OUR CONTRACTORS HAVE
DESIGNED A ROBUST RISK
MANAGEMENT PLAN. OUR RISK
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY INCLUDES A
PACKAGE OF TANGIBLE ASSETS THAT
INCLUDES BONDING INSURANCE
GUARANTEED MAXIMUM PRICING
CONTRACTS IN SIGNIFICANT
CONTINGENCY PLANS. WE HAVE
NEGOTIATED CAPS ON ESCALATION
COSTS WITH OUR MAJOR
CONTRACTORS TO LIMIT IMPACTS OF
INFLATION OR OTHER UPWARD
ECONOMIC PRESSURES ON PRICES.
ARE BUDGET OF ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDING APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
CONTINGENCY FUNDS HELD BY THE
RENEWAL CORPORATION IN OUR
CONTRACTORS. REMAINS SUFFICIENT
TO COMPLETE THE PROJECT
ACCORDING TO OUR CURRENT PLANS
AND SCHEDULES REDUCING
LIKELIHOOD THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDS WILL BE REQUIRED. BASED
ON A THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF OUR
QUALIFICATIONS ON JUNE
SEVENTEENTH OF THIS YEAR THE
FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION APPROVED OUR
APPLICATION TO TRANSFER THE
OPERATING LICENSE FROM
PACIFICORP TO THE RENEWAL
CORPORATION IN THE STATE'S A
CALIFORNIA AND OREGON. THAT
ACTION WAS A MAJOR REGULATORY
MILESTONE AND AN ENDORSEMENT AT
THE PARTY'S POSSESSED ALL THE
CAPACITY NECESSARY TO BECOME
COAL LICENSEES FOR PURPOSES OF
DAM REMOVAL. THAT SAME DAY IN
THE LICENSE RENDER PROCEEDING
FIRST PUBLISHED ITS NOTICE OF
INTENT TO COMPLY WITH THE
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ACT AND LAID OUT ITS APPROACH
IN SCHEDULE FOR CONDUCTING
COMPREHENSIVE NEED A
VALUATIONS. IN ADDITION TO
FIRST PREPARATION OF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT STATEMENT
THE PROJECT REQUIRES BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS FROM THE US FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE AND THE
NATIONAL MARINE FISHERIES
SERVICE. THE CLEAN WATER ACT
PERMIT FROM THE US ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS AND AUTHORIZATION
UNDER THE NATIONAL HISTORIC
PRESERVATION ACT. EACH OF THOSE
AUTHORIZATIONS IS CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY THE RENEWAL
CORPORATION IS HOPEFUL THESE
AGENCIES WILL MAINTAIN
AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULES FOR
COMPLETION OF THESE APPROVALS
AND THAT FOR WILL ISSUE A
LICENSE SURRENDER ORDER IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND OREGON HAVE
PREVIOUSLY ISSUED WATER QUALITY
CERTIFICATIONS AND OTHER
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR THE PROJECT.
IN ADDITION THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
RECENTLY APPROVED PACIFICORP TO
REQUEST TO TRANSFER THE ASSETS
OF THE LOWER KLAMATH PROJECT TO
THE RENEWAL CORPORATION. THE
OREGON PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION IS EXPECTED TO TAKE
UP THIS MATTER AT TODAY'S
COMMISSION MEETING. OUR
PROPOSED PROJECT INCLUDES A
SEQUENCE OF ACTIVITIES LEADING
TO DAM REMOVAL. WE WILL IMPROVE
COUNTY ROADS AND BRIDGES TO
ENHANCE SAFETY AND SUPPORT
HEAVY CONSTRUCTION VEHICLES. WE
WILL RELOCATE THE CITY OF WHY
BECAUSE WATER LINE WHICH WOULD
OTHERWISE BE EXPOSED WHEN IRON
GATE RESERVOIR IS THE WATER.
AND MAKE OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS. ARE SCHEDULE
CALLS FOR ROUGHLY SIX MONTHS OF
PREPARATORY WORK FOLLOWING THAT
WORK RESERVOIR DRAWDOWN WILL
OCCUR BETWEEN JANUARY AND JUNE
WITH DAM REMOVAL AND EARLY
RESTORATION IMMEDIATELY
THEREAFTER. THE FOLLOWING YEAR
RESTORATION ACTIVITIES WILL BE
UNDERTAKEN TO PLANT NATIVE
VEGETATION CONSTRUCT HABITAT
IMPROVEMENTS ENSURE TRIBUTARY
ACCESSIBILITY CONSTRUCT
RECREATION FACILITIES AND
IMPLEMENT OUR WILDFIRE
MANAGEMENT PLAN WHICH IN WHICH
INCLUDES A SERIES OF MEASURES
TO OFFSET LOSS OF RESERVOIRS.
AND GIVE FIRE MANAGEMENT
AGENCIES ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR EARLY DETECTION AND
MONITORING AS WELL AS ENHANCED
FIREFIGHTING CAPABILITIES.
MONITORING AND ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
MEASURES WILL CONTINUE FOR A
PERIOD OF YEARS AFTER THAT OUR
MANAGEMENT PLANS ARE DESIGNED
TO ACHIEVE PERFORMANCE METRICS
IN COMPLIANCE WITH APPLICABLE
REQUIREMENTS IN A PERIOD OF SIX
YEARS OR SO. IN SUMMARY WE'VE
MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
TOWARD ESTABLISHING FREE
FLOWING CONDITIONS ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER AND IMPROVING
CONDITIONS TO SUPPORT RETURNING
HEALTHY RUNS OF SALMON AND TO
RESTORE AND SUSTAIN OTHER
IMPORTANT WATERSHED VALUES. AND
YET MUCH MORE WORK LIES AHEAD
DURING A TIME OF EXTRAORDINARY
STRESS AND STRAIN ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER AND THE MANY
COMMUNITIES WHO RELY ON ITS
RESOURCES. THE RENEWAL
CORPORATION AND OUR PARTNERS
WILL CONTINUE TO DO ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR CONTROL
TO BEGIN EARLY CONSTRUCTION
WORK IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
EXCUSE ME IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND DAM REMOVAL IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AGAIN I THINK
SENATE SENATOR MCGUIRE CHAIR
MCGUIRE VICE CHAIR STONE IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE INVITATION TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
RANSOM AND WE NEED THAT SAY HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE TO MISTER
RANSOM- IN THE ENTIRE. TEAM FOR
YOUR TREMENDOUS WORK IN
PROGRESS IT'S HISTORIC- IT
WOULD NOT HAPPEN WITHOUT JUNE
THANK YOU TO THE KLAMATH RIVER
RENEWAL CORPORATION- FOR ALL OF
THEIR EFFORTS THAT IS IN
GERMANY COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO HEAR FROM
KEEP POOL. SENIOR ATTORNEY FOR
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
SHE'S RETURNING BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON CALIFORNIA'S SIEMENS
SITUATION. AND SHE'S ALSO GOING
TO VIED A BRIEF ABOUT HOW
ENVIRONMENT OUR WATER
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. HAS
WITHSTOOD THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND ITS
CONTINUING IMPACTS ARE GOING TO
HEAR BOTH SIDES MS POOLE IT'S
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU SORRY IT IS
NOT IN PERSON THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY- IN YOUR PARTNERSHIP.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU ARE NOW
IN COMMITTEE YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT. THANK YOU TERM
REQUIRE CAN YOU HEAR ME AND
SEEN OKAY YOU'RE COMING IN LOUD
AND CLEAR WELCOME THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR AFFECT WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BYRON VICE
CHAIR STONE. AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY.
AS YOU HEARD IN THIS SECOND
YEAR OF DRY CONDITIONS IN
CALIFORNIA SALMON RUNS ALL OVER
THE STATE. ARE SUFFERING HIGH
RATES OF MORTALITY. PLEASE
LEGAL WATER TEMPERATURES LIKELY
TO CAROL NEARLY ALL OF THE EXAM
PRIOR BEEN DANGER TO WINTER RUN
SALMON. AND THE COMMERCIAL
IMPORTANT FALL RUN CHINOOK
SALMON THAT SPAWN IN THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER. THIS HIGH
DEATH RATE IS NOT INEVITABLE
NOR THE RESULT OF A NATURAL
DISASTER THAT CAUGHT US BY
SURPRISE. INSTEAD PRIMARILY DUE
TO MISMANAGEMENT OF OUR WATER
SYSTEM INCLUDING A FAILURE TO
PLAN OR PREDICTABLE AND
RECURRING DROUGHTS. AS WELL AS
THE CHOICE TO PRIORITIZE WATER
DELIVERIES TO BIG AGRIBUSINESS
OVER PROTECTING SALMON IN
CALIFORNIA'S NATIONAL WILDLIFE.
THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO FIX THESE PROBLEMS.
COULD HE NOW GRAYSON TO PROTECT
THE COMMERCIALLY IMPORTANT FALL
RUNS. UNFORTUNATELY THE BOARD
HAS DONE LITTLE TO EXERCISE ITS
CONSIDERABLE AUTHORITY TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS FOR SALMON
THIS YEAR. AS WE HEARD FROM THE
SO BACK. SHE STATED THAT THE
STATE BOARD HAS WORKED TO
PROTECT TO THE COLD WATER POOL
ENTRANCE TO THIS YEAR. WELL YOU
KNOW AS WE CAN ALL SEE FROM THE
SORRY STATE OF THE COLD WATER
PULLING SHOTS DOWN. ABOUT HALF
HEARTED EFFORT AS BAIL. AND AS
A RESULT FISHING COMMUNITIES
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND EVERYONE
ELSE WHO CARE ABOUT SALMON AND
HEALTHY ECOSYSTEMS THEY
NURTURE. WILL SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE BOARD'S
INACTION FOR YEARS TO COME.
GENERALLY ON THE SACRAMENTO
TEMPERATURES ABOVE FIFTY SIX
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT. OUR LEAD
OFFER SHINNOK EGGS AND FRY AND
WATER TEMPERATURES ABOUT FIFTY
THREE POINT FIVE DEGREES ARE
LETHAL TO ENDANGERED WINTER RUN
CHINOOK SALMON X. THIS YEAR AT
THE BUREAU OF RECLAMATION WHICH
OPERATES SHASTA DAM IS ON TRACK
TO EXCEED THOSE TEMPERATURE
THRESHOLDS. ON THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER. STARTING NEXT MONTH AND-
ARE CONTINUING TO EXCEED THEM
THROUGH NOVEMBER. THAT IS THE
PERIOD WHEN- THE EX OF BOTH
WINTER RUN AND FALL RUN CHINOOK
NEED COLD WATER TO SURVIVE. THE
SALMON DOESN'T HIGH
TEMPERATURES COULD BE AVOIDED
IF RECLAMATION REDUCED WATER
DELIVERIES TO THEIR CONTRACTORS
MAINTAIN A HIGHER LEVEL OF
WATER STORAGE IN CHASTAIN
CONSERVED MORE COLD WATER IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE RESERVOIR.
RECLAMATION IS LARGELY DRAIN
THE RESERVOIR IN ORDER TO
MAXIMIZE WATER DELIVERIES TO
ITS CONTRACT. THOSE DELIVERIES
ARE ON TRACK TO EXCEED THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRE FEET
THIS YEAR MOSTLY TO
AGRIBUSINESS. THAT BRINGS US
BACK TO THE STATE WATER BOARD
WHICH HAS TO OUR REVIEW AND
APPROVE RECLAMATION'S
TEMPERATURE MANAGEMENT PLAN FOR
SHASTA EVERY YEAR UNDER
RECLAMATION STATE WATER RATES
PERMITS. BECAUSE OF BAD
AUTHORITY THE STATE WATER BOARD
KIND OF REQUIRED RECLAMATION TO
OPERATE SHASTA VERY DIFFERENTLY
THIS YEAR. TO REDUCE RELEASES
OVER THE SUMMER AND INCREASE
THE SIZE OF THE COLD WATER POOL.
IN FACT THE WATER BOARD HAD
EXTENSIVE INFORMATION FROM THE
NATIONAL MARINE FISHERIES
SERVICE MUCHEARLIER THIS YEAR
CHINA COULD HAVE SAVED 50% OF
THE WINNER RUN X. AND FRIED.
AND INCREASED FOREIGN SURVIVAL
IF IT FOLLOWED THIS PROTOCOL.
BUT INSTEAD OF THE WATER BOARD
CHOSE TO ALLOW RECLAMATION TO
OPERATE SHASTA IN A WAY THAT'S
LIKELY TO WIPE OUT THE ENTIRE
RUN. EVEN WORSE THE BUREAU IS
FAILING TO MEET THE PLAN. THAT
THE BOARD APPROVED IN JUNE.
DRAINING THE RESERVOIR EVEN
FURTHER AND THREATENING TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
ADEQUATE WATER FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY IF NEXT YEAR IS STRONG.
ASSEMBLY NONE OF THIS IS A
SURPRISE WE SAW SIMILAR
MISMANAGEMENT DURING THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY FIFTEEN
DROUGHT WHEN RECLAMATION
OPERATED SHASTA TO DRAIN ITS
COLD WATER POOL. LEADING TO
NEAR TOTAL MORTALITY OF WINTER
RUN IN BOTH OF THOSE YEAR. AND
AGAIN THIS IS NOT AN INEVITABLE
FUNCTION OF HYDROLOGY AND
TEMPERATURE. THIS WAS THE
CHOICE THAT STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES MADE FOLLOWING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS WHICH
LEGALIZED KILLING 1100% OF THE
ENDANGERED SALMON IN THE
SACRAMENTO. THIS YEAR SOUNDS
WATER IS ALSO A SYMPTOM OF THE
ON GOING FAILURE OF THE STATE
WATER BOARD. SIX STANDARDS
WHICH HAVEN'T BEEN MEANINGFULLY
UPDATED SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE AND ARE WOEFULLY OUT OF
DATE. THE STATE KIND OF WIND
THIS RECURRING DROUGHT CRISIS
IN THE FUTURE BY UPDATING THOSE
WATER QUALITY STANDARDS TO
REFLECT CURRENT INVEST NOBLE
SCIENCE AND TO ACTUALLY PLAN
FOR DROUGHT MAKING SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE WAY SHASTA IS
MANAGED TO ACCOUNT FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE AND PREVENT THE
EXTINCTION OF OUR SALMON RUNS.
AND FINALLY I WANT TO COMMENT
ON SOMETHING THAT I DIRECTOR
BONHAM SAID- BECAUSE HE
INDICATED THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOW ON TRACK TO
WITHDRAW THESE FROM BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS AND REWRITE- AND
THAT'S NOT REALLY ACCURATE-
WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
SADDENED. IS THAT THEY WILL-
START THE PROCESS IN A FEW
MONTHS. TO DEVELOP NEW OR
AMENDED BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS ARE AMENDED
ALL OF THE TIME AND TWEAKING
AROUND THE EDGES THIS IS NOT
GOING TO SOLVE THE WHOLESALE
ABDICATION OF SCIENCE EMBEDDED
IN THESE TRUMP BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS. WE NEED A COMMITMENT
TO DROPPED ENTIRELY NEW
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS THAT ARE
BASED ON SOUND SCIENCE AND WE
NEED THE STATE TO INCEST. BUT
THE BUREAU AGREED TO BE COVERED
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT. THE STATE HAS A
PRIORITY TO PROTECT ITS OWN
NATIVE SPECIES WHICH IT
CURRENTLY IS NOT EXERCISING-
WITH REGARD TO WINTER AND BLOW
SHASTA THIRTY SECONDS.
AWESTRUCK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COOL THANK YOU SO MUCH A VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY WE SO APPRECIATE YOUR
ADVOCACY ONE REMIND FOLKS IF
YOU THAT TO BE A TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMING HERE TODAY THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE OPENING UP. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT AFTER THIS
FINAL PANEL THE PHONE NUMBER IF
YOU'D LIKE TO COMMENT TODAY'S.
877-692-8953 YOU CAN FOLLOW THE
CODE. THAT IS ON YOUR SCREEN IS
WELL. 877-692-8953 THOUSAND
GENTLEMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO PATRICK SAMUEL
HE'S A VERY REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR CAL TROUT THE SYSTEM IS
GOING TO SPEAK. TO HOW THE
ALARMS BEEN REYES IN THE
IMPORTANT TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN STATED SOMEONE IS
REPORT- AND HOW THOSE ALARMS
CONTINUE TO BE COMMONPLACE HERE
TODAY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHICH IS SEMI WE WLCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH THIS YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES. IN WILL GIVE YOU
A TO ASK YOU SEE A THIRTY
SECOND PROP WHICH IS. SIMILAR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR. THANK YOU. CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK IF YOU'RE COMING
IN LOUD AND CLEAR WE SEE AT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HANGING
WITH US VIRTUALLY TODAY. THANK
YOU CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
IMPORTANT MEETING AND TRAFFIC
EXPECT. I'M PATRICK SAMUEL I'M
THE BAY AREA REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA TROUT AND I'M
ONE OF THE CO AUTHORS OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN STATE THE
SELMON ITS REPORT WHICH UPDATED
THE STATUS OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S TROUT SALMON AND
STEELHEAD. ON THE TAIL OF OUR
LAST DROUGHT. TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN. TODAY
COVER RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
PROVIDING ADEQUATE STREAM FLOWS
FOR SALMON DURING THIS CURRENT
DROUGHT AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
CHANGING CLIMATE CALIFORNIA AND
BEYOND. FIRST OFF CALTRANS
STATEWIDE CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH DIVERSE PARTNERS
FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS TO ENSURE
THAT RESILIENT WILD FISH THRIVE
IN HEALTHY WATERS FOR A BETTER
CALIFORNIA. YOU'VE HEARD TODAY
THAT EXTREME DROUGHT AND LOW
FLOW CONDITIONS COUPLED WITH
OUTDATED AND INFLEXIBLE WATER
MANAGEMENT. AVXS CONSPIRED TO
NEARLY WIPED OUT COHORTS OF
SEVERAL LISTED RUNS OF COHO
CHINOOK SALMON IN THE KLAMATH
TRIBUTARIES SACRAMENTO RIVER
AND IT ALSO WATERSHEDS IN
NORTHERN AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
AS WELL. WE WERE HERE BEFORE
AND OUR LAST DROUGHT AND WE'RE
WOEFULLY UNPREPARED AT THAT
TIME NEARLY LOSING ENTIRE YOUR
CLASSES OF CRITICALLY
ENDANGERED WINTER RUN CHINOOK
AS WELL AS OTHER SEVEN ROUNDS.
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE PERIODS OF EXTREME
DROUGHT IT WILL DEGRADE OUR
ECOSYSTEM AND THREATENED OUR
COLD WATER FISHES LIKE SALMON
WITHOUT CONCERTED ACTION TO
CHANGE HOW WE PREPARE FOR. AND
PREPARE FOR DROUGHT AND ALSO
MANAGE OUR WATER SYSTEMS. HELP
AVOID CATASTROPHIC LOSSES OF
SALMON MOVING FORWARD WE
RECOMMEND FIVE SPECIFIC ACTIONS.
FIRST FUNCTIONAL FLOATS CAL
TROUT SUPPORTS DEVELOPMENT OF A
DROUGHT EMERGENCY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE SHASTA
AND SCOTT RIVERS BUT MORE IS
NEEDED STATEWIDE WE ENCOURAGE
THE CALIFORNIA EPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
TO CONSIDER LONG TERM
MANAGEMENT OF PROTECTIONS FOR
SOME ON ITS BY IMPLEMENTING
TARGET FUNCTIONAL FLOW REGIMES
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA. BETTER
BASED ON RIGOROUS SCIENCE AND
CLIMATE PROJECTIONS FRONT A
REALITY. AFFECTION DEFECTIVE
FUNCTIONAL FLOWS SHOULD INCLUDE
FIVE COMPONENTS. FALL PULSE
FLOWS TO ATTRACT ADULTS
UPSTREAM. WHAT SEASON PEAK FLOW
TO ENABLE REACHING TRIBUTARIES
FOR SPAWNING. WET SEASON BASE
FLOWS TO KEEP THOSE REDS WEDDED.
BRING RECESSION FLOW TO HELP
GET YOU THE NILES AND SMALTZ
OUT AND THEN TRY SEASON BASED
FOLK FOR THOSE SPECIES THAT
OVER SUMMER IN OUR WATER SAID
WE SPIN OUR WATERSHEDS SUCH AS
JUVENILE COHO SALMON. WE NEED
ADEQUATE ENFORCEMENT. WE
ENCOURAGE EFFECTIVE CURTAILING
THE WATER DIVERSIONS BOTH
SURFACE AND GROUNDWATER
WITHDRAWALS ON PRIVATE LANDS.
VOLUNTARY MEASURES ARE
IMPORTANT BUT INSUFFICIENT TO
ACHIEVE FUNCTIONAL FLOWS NEEDED
TO SUPPORT ALL LIFE CELLMARK
ALL LIFE STAGES OF SAMANIDS.
ADEQUATE ENFORCEMENT OF
EXISTING WATER RIGHTS REQUIRES
EXPANDING SUFFICIENT STREAM
GAUGING AND UPGRADING DATABASES
TO MEASURE THE EFFECTS OF THESE
FLOWS. AND TO ENSURE THAT
DEDICATED WATER ENDS UP IN
STREAMS. THIRD WE NEED TO
DROUGHT SECTION OF THE VISION
OF WATER RIGHTS. CALIFORNIA IS
THE ONLY WESTERN STATE TO NOT
HAVE A PERMANENT DROUGHT UNIT.
THE SALMON IS YOUR COALITION
COMPRISED OF TROUT UNLIMITED
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND CAL
TROUT AND URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO PERMANENTLY FUND A DEDICATED
DROUGHT SECTION TO SUPPORT REAL
TIME MANAGEMENT. AND PROCESSING
REGULATORY APPROVALS TO DROUGHT
RESPONSE. FOR FLEXIBILITY. WE
NEED BETTER INCENTIVES FOR
LANDOWNERS FOR SUFFICIENT LONG
TERM WATER LEASES AND
FLEXIBILITY IN FUNDING
APARTMENT FOR SECURING SHORT
TERM LEASES DURING DROUGHT
EMERGENCIES LIKE OR AND NOW. WE
NEED THIS FUNDING ALLOCATED
AGENCIES AND INTO THE POCKETS
OF LANDOWNERS BY SEPTEMBER
FIRST AND MUNCH TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE THIS SEASON. IF THIS
IS NOT POSSIBLE THIS MONEY
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED TOWARD
MANDATORY CURTAILMENT
ENFORCEMENT. AND FINALLY FIVE
ADDITIONAL DROUGHT FUNDING.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL NEED TO
BE WILL BE NEEDED FOR THE NEW
DROUGHT SECTION. PRIORITIZE
STREAM GAUGING AND DATABASE
UPGRADES. IMPLEMENTING AN
ENVIRONMENTAL FLOWS FRAMEWORK
BASED ON SCIENCE. RAMPING UP
ENFORCEMENT TARGETING NON
COMPLIANCE WITH CURTAILMENT.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASING
FUNDING FOR GRANTS UNDER THE
STREAMFLOW ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM
TO PROTECT SPECIAL WILDLIFE
DURING DROUGHT. WE HAVE
REQUESTED FUNDING FOR THESE
OBJECTIVES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE BUDGET. IN
CONCLUSION CAL TROUT STRONGLY
SUPPORTS STATEWIDE SCIENCE
BASED A SPECIAL DROUGHT
REGULATIONS SUCH AS THOSE THAT
SHASTA SCOTT FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND KLAMATH
WATERSHED SPECIAL TROUT
REGULATIONS. WE URGE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY EVERY
CALORIE PA TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE CONSERVATION
COMMUNITY. ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS.
COMMERCIAL RECREATIONAL ANGLERS
TRIBAL NATIONS AND OTHERS TO
PURSUE A PERMANENT DROUGHT
SOLUTIONS SO THE CALIFORNIA CAN
FULFILL ITS PUBLIC TRUST
OBLIGATIONS. AND ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA REMAINS THE SENATE
STATE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO IDENTIFY
AND IMPLEMENT SOLUTIONS TO
BALANCE THE NEEDS OF WILD FISH
AND PEOPLE. HERE AGAIN TO THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HOLDING SIR. THIS IS AMY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR GRATEFUL THAT
YOU ARE WITH US TODAY MISTER
SAM IS GONNA BE HANGING OUT
HERE UNTIL WE GO TO QUESTIONS.
IN COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA TROUT
WE'RE GRATEFUL ALL RIGHT LAYS
IN GERMAN WE ARE NOW GOING TO
TURN THE COMMITTEE OVER TO DON
MAC UNTIL HE SEE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE RUSSIAN
RIVERKEEPER. MISTER MAC AND
HELL IS GOING TO PROVIDE A
BRIEFING ABOUT HOW MANAGEMENT
OF THE VITAL WATER SYSTEMS THE
RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED IN BOTH
CINEMA AND MENDOCINO COUNTIES
HAVE GONE FROM EXTRAORDINARY
FLOOD. TO DEVASTATING DROUGHT
IN JUST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS- AND
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING TO MAKE
THE SYSTEM MORE RESILIENT FOR
FISH FOR AGRICULTURE IN THE
PEOPLE OF THE NORTH BAY IN
NORTH COAST. SO WITHOUT FURTHER
DO WE ARE GOING TO WELCOME MR
MACK IN HELL TO COMMITTEE THIS
AMERICAN HILL IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP SIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
WE'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT. WELCOME MR MECHANISM.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTER. CHAIRMAN
AND CO CHAIR STONE AND FELLOW
PANEL MEMBERS. THANK YOU BOTH
FOR THE INVITATION TO BE HERE
TODAY I'VE REALLY ENJOYED
HEARING ALL THE OTHER PANEL
MEMBERS AND CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH A LOT OF RECOMMENDATIONS
I'VE HEARD. A LOT OF HELP IS
NEEDED HERE- TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN SENATOR
MCGUIRE WE ARE SITTING IN YOUR
OFFICE AND NOT. TALKING ABOUT
THE HISTORIC FLOOD OCCURRING ON
THE RUSSIAN RIVER RIGHT DAN AND
HOW I WANTED TO BE BACK IN THE
WATER SHUT. AND TODAY AND
FORTUNATELY WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF YET ANOTHER DISASTER WITH
HISTORY- CLIMATE CHANGE IS HERE
RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE
EXPERIENCING A PARADIGM SHIFT
IN OUR WEATHER AND OUR
RAINFALL. WHAT'S NOT SHIFTING
IS THE CALIFORNIA WATER CODES
AND OTHER REGULATIONS GOVERNING
HOW WE ALLOCATE AND USE WATER
IN THIS STATE. AND WHAT WE
LEAVE BEHIND FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE WOULDN'T BE SO BRUTAL ON
OUR COMMUNITY IN THE RIVER. IF
THEY ARE REGULATORS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY AND THE TOOLS TO ACT
BEFORE THE WATER RUNS OUT. OF
WATER GOVERNANCE IS STUCK IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES AND TWENTY
FIFTY CLIMATE FUTURES ARE HERE
NOW SO WE MUST CHANGE. THIS
YEAR WILL BE VERY HARD AND I
COMMITTEE FOR HILLS BERGEN AND
CINEMA COUNTY BUSINESSES TO
HAVE TO CUT THEIR WATER USE BY
FORTY PERCENT. IT MEANS SERVING
LAST CUSTOMERS AND NOT REALLY
REBOUNDING AFTER CODE IT. EVER
AB SITTERS BARELY RECOVERING
FOR THE LAST SERIES OF DRY
YEAR. AND AGAIN HERE WE ARE
LOOKING AT ANOTHER ROUGH YEAR
ON OUR HUMAN POPULATION. SO
MANY PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
COMING HERE FOR GENERATIONS AND
GOING TO THE RIVER THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES. ARE TELLING ME THEY'RE
SICK AND TIRED DEGRADED WATER
QUALITY EVERY YEAR AND ONCE
AGAIN WE'VE GOT BE WHERE OF
TOXICOLOGY SIGNS OUT ON THE
LOWER RUSSIAN RIVER. OUR
STEELHEAD IN THE RIVER THIS
SUMMER ARE ALREADY FACING
TEMPERATURES IN THE- UPPER OF
CLOVERDALE REACH SAID IT'S
THREE DEGREES WARMER THAN LAST
YEAR AND IT'S STAYING IN THE
HOME HEALTHY RANGE FOR MUCH
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME.
EXTREMELY LOW FLOWS MEATS FISH
HAVE LESS ABILITY TO MOVE
AROUND AND RELOCATE. TO AREAS
WITH BETTER WATER QUALITY.
SIMPLY PUT TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
JUST HARD ON EVERYTHING IN THE
WATERSHED. BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE
AS WE SOUNDS FIRE ACCIDENTS IN
PREVIOUS DROUGHTS. ON WE HAVE
TENSION BETWEEN THE HUMAN NEED
FOR WATER AND FISH. THE FISH
ALWAYS COME LAST WE HAVE TO DO
A BETTER JOB. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REALLY REALLY DIDN'T HAVE TO BE
THIS WAY I AM NOT A
PROFESSIONAL HYDROLOGIST I'M
JUST A GUY WHO CHECKED ALL THE
RIVER GAUGES I'VE BEEN DOING IT
FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS. AND LAST
APRIL AND MAY I WAS GETTING SO
ALARMED AT WHERE WE WERE UP IN
LAKE MENDOCINO IN THE EFFORT
RUSSIAN RIVER WHERE IT'S
CHEATING IS. BAD IS ANYWHERE IN
THE RUSSIAN RIVER- COME IN
RIGHT ON THE HEELS OF THE
FLOWER- THE FLOOD IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. YOU KNOW WE WERE
REALLY ALARMED WE WROTE A-
PIECE IN THE PRESS DEMOCRAT
LAST JUNE. TWENTY TWENTY URGING
THE COMMUNITY CONSERVE WATER WE
SUBMITTED COMMENTS IN AUGUST OF
LAST YEAR TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD IN THAT YOU SEE KEEP
PROCESS ON THE RUSSIAN RIVER.
TO AND JUST SCREAM FOR
CONSERVATION WE NEED PROACTIVE
CONSERVATION TO AVOID A SECOND
DRIVE WINTER. AND HERE WE ARE
IF WE HAD TAKEN PROACTIVE
CONSERVATION STEPS WHEN WE ADD
WATER. WE COULD HAVE AN EXTRA
TEN THOUSAND ACRE FEET. OF
WATER BEHIND LAKE MAN YOU SEEN
OUR- IN TALKING TO THIS WATER
BOARD STAFF THEY ARE HARD
WORKING PEOPLE. THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
DO THEIR JOB. AND DO IT IN A
TIMELY FASHION- THEY UNDERSTOOD
OUR AGENCY LAST AUGUST AND
AGAIN IN JANUARY WHEN WE FILED
UNDER EMERGENCY COMMENTS AND
FILED EMERGENCY PETITIONS. AND
MAY. AND THEY TOLD US OUR
AUTHORITIES LIMITED UNTIL THE
GOVERNOR DID DECLARES A DROP
BOX MASON OR SOME WATER BURGESS
USED TO CLAIRE. AND THIS FORCES
US INTO AFTER THE FACT. YOU
KNOW CRISIS MANAGEMENT AND WE
JUST ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO OF ALL-
CERTAINLY WHAT WE SEE THE
BIGGEST NEED IS EVOLVING OUR
WATER RIGHTS REGULATORY
PROCESS. WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
INHERENTLY INEQUITABLE. AND
AVOID VIOLATIONS OF THE PUBLIC
TRUST DOCTRINE BY ALLOCATING
WATER TO FISH FIRST. AND THEN.
GOING FROM THERE IT'S ONE THING
TO SET MINIMUM FLOWS IT'S
ANOTHER TO HAVE WATER TO
BACK THAT UP. WE ALSO NEED TO
REQUIRE ALL WATER USERS TO
REPORT WATER USE IN REAL TIME
SO WE CAN BETTER COORDINATE USE
AND CANCER STORAGE. AND ALLOW
PEOPLE TO USE WATER. WE NEED TO
GET THE WATER BOARD NON
DISCRETIONARY AUTHORITY TO DO
THEIR JOB. FREE OF POLITICAL
INTERFERENCE AND ENSURE THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY ON THEIR OWN
TO REQUIRED DEMAND REDUCTIONS.
BEFORE OUR LAKES RUN OUT OF
WATER FOR THIS CALL WATER
LEVELS ARE DEPLETED. WE ALSO
NEED TO FUND THE WATER BOARD
DIVISION OF WATER RIGHTS AND I
LOVE THE IDEAS OF HAVING A
DROUGHT- UNIT AND EVERYTHING.
WE NEED TO CHANGE NOT ONLY HOW
WE DO OUR POLICY BUT HOW WE
FUND THIS AGENCY IT'S ON MEAGER
RATIONS BEING A FEE BASED
AGENCY. AND WATER USERS
CONSTANTLY DEMAND FURTHER
REDUCTION IN FEES AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH STAFF TO DO
THEIR JOB IN A TIMELY MANNER TO
RESPOND TO DROUGHTS ANY GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT IN OF WATER SO
CRITICAL TO OUR ECONOMY. BEYOND
THAT THE THINGS LIKE FIXING
JOBS AND THINGS IN THE SAMIC
ARMY OUR WHOLE ECONOMY IS BASED
ON WATER BEING AVAILABLE AND IF
WE MISS MANAGE IT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
EITHER PEOPLE OR FISH. SO WE
NEED TO INVEST IN BETTER WATER
RIGHTS MANAGEMENT. AND WE NEED
TO BACK THAT UP WITH SOME BOXES
RETAIN WATER SO IMPORTANT- I
THINK WE ALSO NEED TO BASE ALL
DECISIONS- YOU KNOW ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING. IN THE FUTURE- I
FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE WHEN I LOOK AT
CLASS. AND IT FEATURES RIGHT
NOW SO LOOKING BACKWARDS- IS
NOT GOING TO DO IT WE NEED TO
LOOK FOR WORDS. AND WE NEED TO
BRING OUR- WATER RIGHTS-
ALLOCATION AND MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS. INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. THIS AMERICAN L. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I'M VERY GRATEFUL
THAT IS OUR FINAL PANEL WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
ELECTED TO SEE MR BY SHARE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'D LIKE TO
START QUESTIONS WITH MR MACKIN
HILL. MR MACKIN HILLS. WHAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM CINEMA WATER
WHO IS A WHOLESALE WATER
PROVIDER TO OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOLKS AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THEY HAVE BEEN
SO FOCUSED AND IT'S A- FEATHER
IN THE CAP OF THE SIM CAN BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS ALLOWING MISTER
DAVIS GENERAL MANAGER. THAT
ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
WATER BASED OFF OF NEW RELEASE
RULES WITH THE ARMY CORPS- HAVE
BEEN HELD BACK DURING THIS
DROUGHT YEARS. BUT YOU BELIEVE
THAT WE COULD GO FURTHER WITH
LAKE MENDOCINO- WATER
MANAGEMENT WOULD LIKE YOU TO DO
A TWO MINUTE SIR. DEEP DIVE
INTO THAT YOUR HOUGHTS ON WHAT
CAN BE IMPROVED WHAT CAN BE
ENHANCED THAT WOULD RESULT IN A
MORE RESILIENT WATER SYSTEM
THERE ESPECIALLY. FOR THE
OPERATION MISTER MACHENAUD
RUSSIAN RIVERKEEPER. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT- WE'RE SO
BLESSED TO HAVE THIS NUMBER
COUNTY- CINEMA WATERS THEY CALL
THEMSELVES TODAY- THEY ARE
POURING A LOT OF RESOURCES AND
YOU REALLY ARE PERFORMING HOW
THEY MANAGE RESERVOIR RELEASES.
AND THEIR FORECAST INFORMED
RESERVOIR OPERATIONS. REALLY
DID PUT US IN A BETTER PLACE-
COMING OUT OF THAT FLOOD YEAR
AND GOING INTO TWENTY TWENTY-
WHAT OPPORTUNITY WE MISSED WAS
MORE BASED ON HOW THE STATE-
STATE REQUIREMENTS AND STATES
LOW MINIMUMS- THAT REQUIRED US
TO. RELEASE MORE WATER THAN WE
WERE USING. AND UNNECESSARILY
LET ESSENTIALLY IT WAS ABOUT
ELEVEN TWELVE MAY BE MORE
THOUSAND ACRE FEET BUT- WE WERE
LOOKING AT HOW MUCH WATER WAS
BEING RELEASED AND ACCESS- OF
WHAT WAS BEING USED AND HITTING
OUR FLOW MINIMUMS. AND BY
COMPRESSING THAT. OFFER WE CAN
REALLY DO A BETTER JOB AND A
BIG PART OF THAT IS THE WATER
AGENCY IS. RUNNING THIS
SOPHISTICATED SYSTEM COMPLETELY
BLIND. THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHICH
ONE OF THE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
PEOPLE WHO HAVE RIGHTS TO TAKE
WATER OR TAKE WATER FROM THE
RUSSIAN RIVER IS DOING IT WHEN.
SO THEY'RE DUMPING ALL THIS
WATER IN THE RIVER TRYING TO
MEET A FLOW COMPLIANCE POINT
NINETY MILES DOWNSTREAM I MEAN
THAT SEVENTY MILES DOWNSTREAM.
AND IS INCREDIBLY COMPLEX AND
THAT'S WHY REAL TIME REPORTING.
I HAVING EVERYONE WHO'S GOT A
CALL. FIRST ON THE RIVER OR THE
UNDER SLOW IN NEEDS TO BE
METERED MONITORED AND MANAGED.
IN REAL TIME- WE COULD SEE SAVE
A LOT MORE WATER. THE OTHER
THING IS- IN YEARS LAST YEAR
EVERYONE CONCERNED TWENTY
PERCENT. PEOPLE WOULDN'T BE
FACING OUTRIGHT CURTAILMENT AND
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THAT HIGH
TENSION. THINGS ARE BETTER FOR
THE FISH AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
DONEGAN HELD SECOND DIRECTOR
RUSSIAN RIVERKEEPER THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
TURN OUR ATTENTION TO MISS POOL
IN MR SAMUEL PLEASE I WOULD
LIKE TO. GO EAST NOW TO THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEMS
IN THE DELTA. MS POOLE FIRST TO
YOU THEN TO MR SAMUEL. BUT
THEY'VE BEEN IN A NEAR STATE A
DISASTER FOR YEARS NOW I'M-
TALK TO US ABOUT. WHAT
STABILITY LOOKS LIKE IN THOSE
SYSTEMS UP IN WHAT BALANCE
LOOKS LIKE. ONE FOUR FISH WHILE
STILL MEETING COMMITMENT TO AG
WHILE MEETING COMMITMENT TO
MUNICIPAL USERS THIS POOL TALK
TO US ABOUT WHAT STABILITY
LOOKS LIKE IN THE SYSTEM SO WE
DON'T HAVE A FRIGGIN FIRE ALARM
EVERY YEAR- WITHIN THE
WATERSHEDS IS FULL. THANK YOU
SENATOR SO- I WANT TO ECHO
MISTER MAC IN HOUSE CALL FOR
REAL TIME MONITORING AND
REPORTING THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WE- THE SAME AS THE
RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED IN THE
BAY DELTA WATERSHED- REGULATORS
HAD VERY LITTLE IDEA ABOUT WHAT
IS BEING WITHDRAWN LAND AND
THAT MAKES IT JUST. VERY
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE THE SYSTEM
WELL SECOND WE- OUR NEED TO
UPDATE OUTDATED STANDARDS WE
ARE RELYING ON YOU KNOW TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD STANDARDS THAT
WERE WRITTEN BEFORE THE
COLLAPSE OF THE BAY DELTA
ECOSYSTEM AND MANY OF ITS
NATIVE BASH AND THEY'RE JUST
MOSTLY OUT OF DATE AND THE
STATE BOARD HAS BEEN WORKING
ON- THE SCIENTIFIC BASIS FOR
OBTAINING THOSE STANDARDS AND
WE NEED TO LET THEM DO THEIR
JOB AND GET IT DONE QUICKLY
BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE.
WELL MODERN REQUIREMENTS FOR
WHAT THE ECOSYSTEM NEEDS TO
HEAL. I HEARD IT WE REALLY NEED
TO INVEST IN ALTERNATIVES TO
TAKING MORE WATER FROM OUR
RIVERS- YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL
SORT OF FOLLOWING THIS
TWENTIETH CENTURY PATTERN OF
THINKING THAT WE CAN JUST STICK
MORE STRAWSON AND TAKE MORE OUT
AND WE ARE WELL BEYOND THE
CARRYING CAPACITY OF OUR RIVERS
AND MANAGE THAT BUT THE GOOD
NEWS IS WE HAVE TREMENDOUS
CAPACITY TO RECYCLE MORE WATER
THAT'S CURRENTLY. TREATED AND
DUMPED INTO OUR OCEANS WE HAVE
TREMENDOUS CAPACITY STILL TO
IMPROVE AGRICULTURAL AND URBAN
WATER USE EFFICIENCY- YOU KNOW
MUCH OF THE DELIVERIES THAT ARE
GOING TO AGRIBUSINESS IN THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY THIS YEAR OR
TO FLOOD IRRIGATE LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF SQUARE MILES OF
RICE FARMS. WE SHOULD BE DOING
FLOOD IRRIGATION AND CERTAINLY
NOT IN A YEAR LIKE THIS ONE- WE
SHOULD GROW OTHER CROPS THAT
ARE JUST WATER THIRSTY AND- WE
CAN DO A LOT IN TERMS OF URBAN
STORM WATER CAPTURE AS WELL
THERE'S A REASON THAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS DOING MUCH
BETTER. IN THE STRUPP AND
REDDING CALIFORNIA AND IT'S NOT
BECAUSE THEY GOT A LOT MORE
RAIN IT'S BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SPENT THE LAST THREE DECADES
INVESTING IN THESE ALTERNATIVE.
REGIONAL WATER SUPPLIES TO
TAKING MORE OUT OF OUR RIVERS
AND WERE BEHIND UPSTATE AND WE
GOT TO CATCH UP AND WE NEED TO
INVEST QUICKLY AND HEAVILY AND
ALSO TURN INTO SUPPLIES. YOU SO
MUCH MISS POOL THAT'S- VERY
INSIGHTFUL LET'S KEEP POOL
SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR THE WATER
AND- NATURE PROGRAM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WE'RE
GONNA ASK THE SAME QUESTION
WHAT INSTABILITY LOOK LIKE IN
THE SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
SYSTEMS TO PATRICK SAMUEL HE IS
WITH CALIFORNIA TROUT MISTER
SAMIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU CHAIR. THERE ARE PROBABLY
OTHERS ON THIS CALL THAT ARE
BETTER QUALIFIED TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION YEAH ONE THING I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD IS. I THANK.
SEMINAR I SPECIES NOW IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE LIFECYCLE
OF ABOUT THREE YEARS THAT
WASN'T ALWAYS THE CASE THAT
USED TO BE MUCH MORE DIVERSITY
IN THE LIFE HISTORY. THANKS FOR
FIVE AND SIX YEARS OLD THE
REALLY LARGE FIX THE ROOF.
LARGELY LOST. NOW THEY'RE STUCK
WITH THESE FISH THEY'RE
ALTERING SAME THING IN THE
COMING BACK EVERY THREE YEARS.
THOSE FIRST LOST A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY. HOWEVER THEY
RETAIN THE POTENTIAL. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF REALLY GOOD YEARS
WHEN THERE ARE WAIT YEARS. WE
NEED TO ALLOW THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK INTO
HABITATS THAT ARE ONLY
ACCESSIBLE UNDER THOSE
CONDITIONS. THAT'S SORT OF HOW
THEY EVOLVE TO ADAPT TO THIS
CLIMATE IN CALIFORNIA.
THROUGHOUT THE MILLENNIA I
THINK WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTS ITSELF AS WE NEED TO
HAVE A WATER SYSTEM THAT WATER
RIGHTS BETTER FLEXIBLE ENOUGH
TO ALLOW THOSE FISH ACCESS BACK
INTO THOSE HABITATS. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE IT'S GOOD
YEARS. WHERE THERE IS
SUFFICIENT WATER TO GET
JUVENILES OUT TO SEA AND
SURVIVE IN HIGH NUMBERS TO THEN.
COME BACK IN AND CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE POPULATION. BIGELOW
THERE COULD BE MANY WAYS TO DO
THAT. ONE WAY IS ENSURING IT
DOES FISH OUT SUFFICIENT FLOW.
MANAGED WAY ACROSS THE VALLEY
TO GET OUT AND THAT COULD BE
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS
COORDINATING RELEASES FROM THE
DANCE. THE OTHER THING I NEED
IS FOOD. WE'RE LARGELY CUT OFF
ALL OF OUR FLOOD PLAINS FROM
OUR RIVER SYSTEMS THAT'S THE
PLACE WHERE THE FISH WERE
HISTORICALLY REAR GROW PUT ON
WEIGHT AND SIZE BEFORE
MIGRATING TO THE OCEAN. AND
IT'S KEY TO THEIR SURVIVAL. NOW
OUR LANDSCAPE IS LARGELY
DOMINATED BY AGRICULTURE AND
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES ARE FEW AND
FAR BETWEEN WE NEED TO TRY TO
EXPAND THE POSSIBILITIES. FOR
RECONCILIATION ECOLOGY TO GET
FISH OUT AND WATER OUT THE
LISTEN AWAY ONTO THE LANDSCAPE
ONTO THESE FLOOD PLAINS. TO
GIVE THEM FOODS THEY CAN GROW
IT SURVIVED. TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THOSE HIGH WATER YEARS
WHETHER SURVIVAL CAN. REALLY BE
MUCH HIGHER THAN THAT THESE LOW
BASELINES WE'VE BEEN SEEING THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. THANK YOU
SOME MISS SAMUEL MISAMIS WITH
CALIFORNIA TROUT VERY GRATEFUL
TO MS POOLE MRS SAMUEL WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE. HEADING OVER
TO MR BRANSON MR BRANSON IS THE
CEO OF THE KLAMATH RIVER
RENEWAL CORPORATION. I'M MISTER
BRANSON THERE HAVE BEEN UPS AND
DOWNS THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
AND YOU HAVE MOMENTUM ON YOUR
SIDE. THANKS TO THE INCREDIBLE
TENACITY HARD WORK IN INFUSION
OF DOLLARS ARE NOW AND IT THAT
SETTLEMENT- IS NOW MOVING
FORWARD. WHERE ARE YOUR
CONCERNS WHERE ARE YOUR WORRIES
AT B. BETWEEN NOW IN WHEN YOU
START SEEING THOSE DAMS COME
DOWN. TALK TO US ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR I APPRECIATE
THAT. THE BIGGEST CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE IN LIGHT OF THE CURRENT
CONDITIONS IS REGULATORY DELAY.
NOW WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
WITHIN OUR CONTROL. TO PROVIDE
REGULATORY AGENCIES WHO ARE
TAKING A CLOSE LOOK AT THE
PROJECT AND ITS POTENTIAL
IMPACTS. WITH SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION FOR THEM TO DO
THEIR ANALYSES AND MAKE A
RULING ONE WAY OR ANOTHER. AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WE ARE
HEAVILY DEPENDENT ON THE
FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION. TO NAVIGATE THE-
NEPA PROCESS AND THE OTHER
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS THAT I
MENTIONED INCLUDING BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS NATIONAL HISTORIC
PRESERVATION ACT RULING. I AND
SO ON TO ALLOW US TO STAY ON
SCHEDULE. I THINK THAT MANY OF
THE PANELISTS- HAVE MADE A
SIMILAR COMMENT AND THAT IS
SIMPLY THAT WE CANNOT AFFORD
FURTHER DELAY. SO THE KLAMATH
RIVER RENEWAL CORPORATION
CONTINUES TO WORK DILIGENTLY.
TO TRY TO POSITION US FOR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE DAM
REMOVAL- WE CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT
THE CONDITIONS MIGHT BE LIKE IF
WERE DELAYED YET ANOTHER YEAR-
AND I BELIEVE CHAIRMAN JAMES
FROM YUROK- IN SHERMAN
ADDERBURY. A REITERATED THAT
POINT THAT CONDITIONS ARE SUCH
THAT WE SIMPLY HAVE TO. MOVE
THIS PROJECT FORWARD AND THAT
WILL REQUIRE THE COMPLETION OF
ALL THE OUTSTANDING
AUTHORIZATIONS SO WE REMAIN
FOCUSED ON BEING RESPONSIVE TO
THE REGULATORY ENTITIES- THAT
ARE CONTINUING THEIR WORK IN AS
I SUGGESTED IN MY COMMENTS WERE
HOPEFUL. THAT THOSE AGENCIES
WILL CONTINUE TO PURSUE THOSE
AUTHORIZATIONS AGGRESSIVELY
ALSO THAT THERE IS NO QUESTION
BUT THAT WE CAN BEGIN THE EARLY
CONSTRUCTION WORK THE MIDDLE OF%
TWENTY TWENTY TO. DRAW THE
RESERVOIRS DOWN IN EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND COMPLET DAM
REMOVAL- IN THAT CALENDAR YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND THEN
GETS UNDERWAY IN EARNEST WITH
RESTORATION IN THE FOLLOWING
YEAR FOLLOWED BY COMPLIANCE
WITH OUR TERMS AND CONDITIONS
OF OUR PERMITS THE RELEASE
SCHEDULE. I IS WHAT REALLY
KEEPS ME AWAKE AT NIGHT. THAT'S
MARK BRANSON THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE CLAIM
AT THE RIVER RENEWAL
CORPORATION MR BRANSON THANK
YOU KATE POOL FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL THANK
YOU PATRICK SAMUEL. FROM
CALIFORNIA TROUT WE'RE GRATEFUL
YOU'RE WITH US TODAY AND DON
MACHENAUD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FROM A DEJECTED DIRECTOR OF THE
RUSSIAN RIVERKEEPER WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO THE FOUR OF YOU FOR
BEING WITH US IN CONTRIBUTING
SO MIGHTILY. TO THIS HEARING
TODAY WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
HARD WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN-
THAT WAS OUR FINAL PANEL FOR
THE DAY WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
OPENING UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT I
HAD SAID EARLIER THAT IT TO
SIXTY SECOND IT IS TWO MINUTE
PUBLIC COMMENT TOO MANY PER
SPEAKER. IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO JOIN US TODAY FOR OUR
HEARING WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU THE PHONE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
1-528-953-8776 NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH MADAME MODERATOR
BETTER MODERATOR WHAT YOU TELL
US HOW MANY FOLKS ARE IN THE
QUEUE. FOLKS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THE FLOOR IS YOURS AT
MADAME MODERATOR. THANK MISTER
CHAIR. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S HEARING YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. AND CURRENTLY WE
DO HAVE THREE PARTIES IN THE
COMMON Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TOMORROW NINE THIRTY NOT. AND
I'M SORRY WE HAVE ACTUALLY SIX
NOW AND ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY NINE GOOD AFTERNOON.
SHARE AND- MEMBERS. WAITING FOR
AN ARTICLE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
KALO APRIL NINETEENTH. DROUGHTS
ARE NATURE'S FAULT THEY ARE
NATURALLY OCCURRING WATER
SHORTAGES ARE THE FAULT OF
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SHORTAGES
FALL SQUARELY ON FORMER
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN AND- NOW
ON GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HASN'T
SIGNIFICANTLY INVESTED IN WATER
STORAGE SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WHEN JERRY BROWN WITH
GOVERNOR THE FIRST TIME AROUND
THIS IS AN ERA OF THE LIMIT AND
WE ALL HAD BETTER GET USED TO
IT BROWN SAID UPON BEING
ELECTED GOVERNOR IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND BRACING THE
SMALL IS BEAUTIFUL WAY OF
THINKING. THANK CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION HAS DOUBLED OUT OF
HABIT ENVIRONMENTAL DEMANDS AND
MORE THAN 50% OF THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES ARE ALLOWED TO
FLOW OUT TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY TO THE PACIFIC OCEAN.
WEATHER THAN BUILD THE
DESPERATELY NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
COLLECT AND STORE WATER DURING
THE WAIT YEARS GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A NEW WATER
CONSERVATION ACT THAT WILL
LIMIT EACH CITIZEN TO JUST.
FIFTY TO FIFTY FIVE GALLONS OF
WATER. PER DAY. PER PERSON BY
TWO FIFTH. THE TRUTH IS THAT
50% OF CALIFORNIA'S WATER
ALREADY GOES TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PURPOSES. OF THE WEST OF THE
WATER ONLY ABOUT 10% GOES TO
URBAN USES FOR HOMES AND
BUSINESSES. AND 40% IS USED BY
AGRICULTURE A FULL 50% OF THE
STATE WATER IS USED FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PURPOSES. OF
CALIFORNIA FARMER AND WATER
EXPERT CHRISTIE DINNER RECENTLY
EXPLAINED THE STATE HAS BEEN
LETTING WATER OUT OF RESERVOIRS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOR MONTHS
NOW THANK YOU SO MUCH AND IT'S
NOT GOING TO FARMERS AND-
RANCHERS. EARNINGS YOU. MET A
MODERATE ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
MODERATOR WERE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT I THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER AND META
MODERATED WE'RE GONNA ASK OUR
CALLERS PLEASE GIVE US THEIR
FIRST NAME IS WELL. BETTER
MODERATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND WE DO WANT TO LET FOLKS
KNOW WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT TWO
MINUTES FROM NOW WE MAY HAVE
TO. LIMIT TIME IS WE HAVE A
NOTHER COMMITTEE COMING IN IN
THE CHAMBERS WILL NEED TO BE
CLEANED PRIOR- BUT WE'LL KEEP
IT TWO MINUTES FOR NOW NOT A
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HOLDEN GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE REQUIRE AND GOOD
AFTERNOON- BUT BY SHERMAN MARK
STONE AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS A- LOG IN I'M A
COMMERCIAL FISHERMAN DURING THE
DAY THEY MIGHT ASK YOU SHORT.
IT IS REGARDING THE COMMERCIAL
FISHING INDUSTRY. BEING NAY DO
REAL TIME DATA MY HOPE IS THAT
WE WILL BE ABLE TO CREATE AN
AFFECTING IN SEASON MANAGEMENT
PLAN. THAT CAN ADAPT TO THE
EVER CHANGING SITUATIONS. IT'S
BEEN OUR FISHERY. I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND HOW EASY THAT IS TO
SAY AND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
IMPLEMENT. BUT WITH OUR PRESENT
INDUSTRY LEADERS I FIRMLY
BELIEVE A SOLUTION CAN BE
DEVELOPED. I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE MY- ABSOLUTE THANKS TO THE
TIRELESS EFFORTS OF JOHN
CAPTAIN GEORGE BRADSHAW
ESPECIALLY MIKE CONROY. WHOSE
KEPT ON TRACK. IN ARE THE
BACKBONE AND DRIVING FORCE OVER
SUPPORT AND SUPPORTING OUR
DIRECTION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK UP. YOU'RE MCGUIRE AND I
CERTAINLY THIS YOU KNOW VERY
THANK YOU STRONG IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MISTER AUG HAS
BEEN. JUST STEADFAST SUPPORT IS
A COMMERCIAL FISHERMAN. AND WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP SIR AND THANK YOU
FOR MENTIONING THE GOOD FOLKS
AT PC FFA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THAT A
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
LINE THIRTY FIVE. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S JOHN KAPLAN THE
COMMERCIAL PUTS SALMON
FISHERMEN FROM SANTA CRUZ BURKE
IS CURRENTLY HARBOURED AND
UPDATE THERE'S A CASE NUMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA COAST FOR THE
PAST THIRTY YEARS. I'M A MEMBER
OF THE SANTA CRUZ WHICH
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
THAT THE USER TO THE- MONTEREY
BAY FISHERIES TRUST. REMEMBER
ASSOCIATION PERCENT OF THIS
YEAR THAT IS A CORPORATE. AND
THE CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL TRULY
REPRESENTED TO THE PACIFIC
FISHERY MANAGEMENT COUNCIL.
HAMMOND ADVISORY. ANIL TO OF
COURSE IS IN PREVIOUS TESTIMONY
GIVE ALL THE ELEMENTS
DISCUSSING PRIORITY WILL BEGIN
WITH A WARNING THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BOOK LEADERS TEETERING ON
THE BRINK OF OBLIVION THREE
YEARS OF BRIDGES PRODUCTION
FROM GRABBING CONTINUE MR
SENTIMENT IN CALIFORNIA WATERS
MEANS CALIFORNIA'S GLOBAL
COMMERCIAL PLATE ASSIGNMENT
FINANCIALLY STRESSED. WE WANT.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE THE ATTACK
OF REDUCING TO FINISH- ANY
NORTH OF WORLD WILL SENIOR
CENTER SIMPLE REQUIRE BUT VERY
FEW COMMERCIAL BUSTLE. COMPARED
PRE NINETEEN NINETIES
ESPECIALLY SOUTH OF THE DAY.
THE PRAYER YOU CAN REGAIN.
SINCE COMMERCIAL FOR IS WATER.
THREE FORTY WATER FOR RETURNING
ADULTS AND WATER FROM OUT
MIGRATING BUT- PRODIGY REMEMBER
THE SACRAMENTO RIVER HAS A RUN
EVERY SEASON OF THE YEAR FALL
WINTER SPRING AND SUMMER. WATER
MANAGERS HAVE PRIORITIZE WHEN
RUN OVER SPRING RUN TO MEDIA
SAYING WINNER RUN LISTING
REQUIREMENTS INSOUCIANT GIVEN
SO THEY'VE KILLED A STORY CLEAN
MOST PRODUCTIVE LUNCH
SACRAMENTO RIVER THE SPRING
RENT WHICH THIS ISSUE WHILE
WE'RE COMMISSION CHARGED WITH
WITH THE THREATEN. CAN'T WATER
MANAGERS FIND WEIGH EVEN GOT
RIVER FLOWS WITHOUT BEING
THREATENED WITH LAWSUITS AND
STATE LEGISLATORS PASSING LAWS
WHERE IS THE COMMONSENSE IN
MANAGING A RESOURCE. LIBRARY
THANK YOU JOHN WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL I'M SO SORRY TO CUT
YOU OFF JOHN I REALLY
APPRECIATE REDUCE HAVING TO
KEEP IT TO TIME. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN DUE TO THE NUMBER OF
FOLKS WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
QUEUE WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE
AT A LIMIT PUBLIC TESTIMONY TO
ONE MINUTE AND I APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THAT WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING COMING IN AT ONE THIRTY
AND THEN DUE TO- CLEANING
PROTOCOLS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THEY'RE GONNA NEED
TO CLEAN THE CHAMBERS DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC FOR THAT SO LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER AND THINK
YOU CAN JOHN FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL. MATAMATA NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS AT THIS- WITH KILEY
TRUST MY HOME THE CLIMATE I UP
IN THE UPPER SACRAMENTO- IT.
IT'S IN OUR DNA HUMAN TO TRY TO
BLAME. FOR THE PROBLEMS ARE
FACING I'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
LEARNING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. BUT I THINK-
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
AGENCIES. THESE THE AUTHORITY
THEY HAVE RIGHT NOW THE WATER
BOARD COULD HAVE PREVENTED- THE
SALMON KILL IT IS COMING ON THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER- BACK HE SAID.
EXISTING LEGAL AUTHORITY- CDFW
IS MORE THAN EVER EXERCISING
ITS AUTHORITY BY SIMPLY
RECOMMENDING HOW MUCH WATER IS
EITHER ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF
THE RIVER THANK YOU IF YOU
HAVE. THAT W. FOR DOING THAT.
ABOUT TIME FOR THE WATER BOARD
TO ENFORCE THAT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- CHUCK BONHAM SAID
THERE'S A MILLION FOR QUOTE
MODIFYING. INSTREAM FLOW
REQUIREMENTS- HE HAS NOT YET.
HELP SET PERMANENT INSTREAM
FLOW REQUIREMENTS. ON MOST
RIVERS IN CALIFORNIA SO. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO BE EXPLICIT ABOUT WHEN
ALLOCATING MONEY THAT THAT'S
WHAT IT'S FOR IT THAT'S WHAT
YOU WANT- ALSO ALLOCATE MONEY
FOR ENFORCEMENT WITHOUT METERS
AND SATELLITES WE CAN ENFORCE
THESE THINGS REMOTELY LET'S
START DOING THAT- AND ON THE
VOLUNTARY SIDE. LET'S START
MEASURING OUT THE TECHNICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL WATER TRANSACTION
OPEN AT THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. RETIRED
THEY HAVE NOT- THANK YOU SO
MUCH CONRAD AND THEN WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL I DO
APOLOGIZE SIR I THINK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL. TODAY
OTHER YOU'RE GOING TO CUT
PEOPLE OFF I THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I SAW. UNDERMINE FOLKS- WE
ORIGINALLY TOO MANY. NOW ST ONE
MINUTE SO AGAIN I HAVE- AND
WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
JUST KEEP TRACK OF TIME FOR
YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS SO- YOU
HAVE SIXTY SECONDS TO BE A
PROVIDE WRITTEN COMMENTS THAT
BECAUSE THERE IS ANOTHER
HEARING AND WE'VE GOT A LITTLE
LATE AND THAT HEARINGS GOING
NEED TO SORT OF ONE THIRTY.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN JUST KNOW THAT WE
WANT TO HEAR YOU LONGER IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO PROVIDE
ANYTHING IN WRITING WE OF
COURSE WELCOME THAT AS WELL ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE- MINIMUM ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER AND
LINE FORTY TWO IS MINE WAS OPEN
AT THAT EARLY ONE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FORTY TWO YEAR IN
COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU THIS IS DAVID HELLO THE
FISHING VESSEL CORREGIDOR I
WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE THE JOINT
COMMITTEE DRAFT A LETTER TO THE
BUREAU OF RECLAMATION THAT'S
NUMBER TO DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT
A PILOT PROJECT TO INSTALL
SOLAR PANELS ON WHISKEYTOWN
RESERVOIR WITH AN AYE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO COOL THE
PLANET CREATE CLEAN ENERGY
CONSERVE WATER AND CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT FOR SUCCESSFUL
FAMILY SURVIVAL. J. REDUCES
WATER TEMPERATURE ROUGHLY
ELEVEN AFTER GREASE AND REDUCES
EVAPORATION 7295% BUT IF YOU
DON'T RESERVOIRS EIGHT THOUSAND
FOUR AND FIFTY TWO ACRE FEET OF
WATER TO GO OF APPARITION IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. A SHADED
RESERVOIR WOULD HAVE GENERATED
SIXTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF NEW
WATER INTO THE SYSTEM AND THEN
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF ELEVEN
AND A HALF DEGREES COOLER WE
KNOW THE HOT WATER DISCHARGE
WHISKEYTOWN RESERVOIR INTO THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER IS A FISH
KILLER. YOU HAVE A WHISKEYTOWN
OUT OF COVERAGE THAT SOLAR
PANELS THE TEMPERATURE WOULD
DROP ADDITIONAL ELECTRICITY
WOULD BE GENERATED AND
IMMEDIATELY INCONVENIENTLY
PLUGGED INTO THE GRID THE JUDGE
CAR POWERHOUSE WILL LEAD TO
OTHER DISLODGED FROM ADAMS OF
SOLAR PANELS THE RESULT
ELECTRICAL CURRENT EFFICIENCY
OF GENERATIONS INCREASES AN
INVERSE FUNCTION OF THE
TEMPERATURE. OF THE WATER COOLS
PANEL GENERATION INCREASES FOR
THE SAME AMOUNT OF SUNSHINE
WHISKEYTOWN RESERVOIR IS
CURRENTLY UP CREATED IN
SACRAMENTO RIVER OFTEN CREATING
LEGAL TEMPERATURES OUT
MIGRATING SALMON SMOLT AN ARRAY
OF SOLAR PANELS ON THE
RESERVOIR WOULD LOWER THE
TEMPERATURE SALMON SURVIVAL
LEVELS HE CAN REALLY PROVIDE
ELECTRICAL GENERATION TO THE
GRID AT TEMPERATURES I THINK
YOU SEE A HIGHER RATING
EFFICIENCY. AND SEVEN SURVIVAL
AND RETAIN CURRENTLY LOST WATER
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD THANK YOU
SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL- IN
HEARING ABOUT SOLAR PANELS AND
WHISKEYTOWN RESERVOIR IN HOW
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO KEEP
ADDITIONAL WATER IN THERE AND
HELP BLOCK THAT EVAPORATION
DAVID THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR REMARKS WERE GRATEFUL YOU
CALLED IN TODAY. BETTER
MODERATOR THIS GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MY TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS RICHARD HAGEL.
SAM TROLL A WHOLE PERMITS AND
ALL STATES AND I'VE BEEN
THROUGH FOR US FOR FIFTY YEAR.
AND YES I AWARE TO DEMISE OF
THE SALMON. BECAUSE OF THE
LIMITED TIME WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME WE HAVE A LOT
OF MANAGERS IN THE ROOM TODAY
AND- WE WERE GIVEN A THIRTY
EIGHT DAYS SEASON IN JUNE JULY
AND AUGUST. HOW DID THAT THIRTY
EIGHT DAYS NOW I'M JUST GOING
ON THE FLIGHT YOU'RE ON HOW
MANY DAYS YOU'RE GONNA LOSE
AUGUST AND WAS A FIVE. FULL OF
BLOOD LEVEN DAYS TO- WHAT WE
SAID. WHETHER OR NOT. BUT FISH
BOWL BUT DANGEROUS WEATHER YOU
CAN CATCH FISH AND- SO I'D LIKE
TO SAY AND SIX SAID SOME REAL
TIME- A MERCEDES AND A CHEER IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE SIX
DAYS IN JULY. PLEASE MOVE IT TO
WHERE THE WEATHER LOOKS GOOD
AND WE HAVE MODELS WE COULD
HAVE A GROUP OF FISHERMEN COULD
BE MANNING THE MODELS. AND IT
COULD WORK I LIVE OUT OF TOWN I
CAN BE A BIG ADVANCE SIX HOURS.
RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD BE PUSHING
IT WEATHER RIGHT NOW IT'S BEEN
FLAT FOR TWO DAYS THE FLAPPER
THREE BOARDING A START. ON THE
SEVENTEENTH OF AUGUST WE MIGHT
GET TWO DAYS IN AND THEN THE
MODEL SHOW MORE NGUYEN RICHARD
THANK YOU SOME OF IT IS. A
FACT- GRATEFUL THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA REMIND CO SIXTY TO A-
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU RICHARD.
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
ELOQUENT REMARKS WE APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING IN TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ALL MONEY IN THE
MARKET WITH FRIENDS OF THE
SHOPS THE RIVER- JOSH RIVERS
ONE OF FIVE PRIORITY STREAMS
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE IT IS THE
SPAWNING GROUND FOR AT THAT UP
250% OF THE FALL CHINOOK RUN IN
THE KLAMATH RIVER. THE LOW
FLOWS WHICH ARE THE NORM ON
SHASTA AND HAVE GOTTEN WORSE
THIS DROUGHT SEASON SO LOW
THAT- IT CAUSED US ALARM AND-
WE'RE REALLY. HAPPY TO SEE THE
ACTION BY THIS IS WILDLIFE TO
ENHANCE THE FLOWS MINIMUM FLOWS
BEEN NEEDED FOR A LONG TIME. ON
THE CHESTER RIVER. IT SUPPLIES
SO MANY FIRST THE KLAMATH THE
KLAMATH ALSO NEEDS WASHING
CLOTHES SO THAT THE FISH GET
PRODUCES COULD MAKE IT DOWN
RIVER. TO THE FOLKS THAT HAVE
DEPENDED ON IT FROM TIME
IMMEMORIAL. ARE YOU CAN'T
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH HOW LONG TERM
SOLUTION A PERMANENT MINIMUM
ORDER. THAT DEALS WITH THE
CONSTANT DROUGHT CONDITIONS
BECAUSE OF AGRICULTURAL OVER
DIVERGENT NEEDS TO HAPPEN ON
THE SHASTA RIVER FOR. THE EQUAL
JUSTICE OF ALL IT'S TIME TO
SHARE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU CALLED IN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER WHO HAS. SIXTY SECONDS
MATTER MODERATOR. ONE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
YOU HAVE SIXTY SECONDS SIR WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS DAN MCCANN IN I'M GOING
TO BE READING FROM- CALIFORNIA
GLOBE ARTICLE DATED APRIL
NINETEENTH. OF CALIFORNIA
FARMER IN WATER EXPERT CRISTINA
RECENTLY EXPLAINED THE STATE
HAS BEEN LETTING WATER OUT OF
RESERVOIRS A CAR ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FOR MONTHS NOW. AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO FARMERS
GROWERS RANCHERS URBAN USE.
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY SAYS THE
WATER FLOWS FROM WHETHER
RESERVOIRS ARE NECESSARY TO
PRODUCE A REBOUND OF ENDANGERED
DELTA SMELT AND CHINOOK SALMON
HOWEVER THESE POLICIES ARE A
FAILURE AND NEITHER SPECIES
HAVE BEEN COLLECTED IN ALL OF
THE LATEST TROLLING SURVEYS.
WHERE THEY SPENT SEVERAL DAYS A
MONTH SURGING IN MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED SPOTS BEST PRACTICE OF
RELEASING WATER AND HOPING
FISHING CREW HAS BEEN
UNSUCCESSFUL FOR NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS. BOTH SPECIES ARE CLOSE
TO EXTINCTION EXTINCTION. IF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DIDN'T
ALLOW BILLIONS OF GALLONS OF
FRESH WATER TO SPILL INTO THE
PACIFIC OCEAN EVERY YEAR. WE
WOULDN'T EVER FACE WATER
SHORTAGES. DEMOCRAT LAWMAKERS
AND FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATORS AUTHORIZED MORE THAN
EIGHTY ONE BILLION IN ORDER TO
CREATE OUT OF THE OCEAN THANK
YOU VERY THAT ARE BEING USED
FOR HIM. THANK YOU SO MUCH
TAMMY APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE
CALL TODAY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER NEXT CALLER YOU
HAVE SIXTY SECONDS MADAME
MODERATOR. ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ANGELINA COOK I
LIVE IN SISKIYOU COUNTY AND
I'VE BEEN WORKING TO PROTECT
MOUNT SHASTA SOURCE WATERSHEDS
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS. I'M GRATEFUL
TO HEAR COMMITTEE MEMBER
CONCERNS AND COMPREHENSION OF
THE DIRE SITUATION WE FACE. I
HOPE THAT YOUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE LEGISLATURE SHARE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING BUT HOW WE
RESPOND TO THIS DRUG CRISIS
WILL DETERMINE THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY OF THE GOLDEN STATE
FOR DECADES TO COME. LAST WEEK
I SUBMITTED WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
THE SHOT THAT GOT DROPPED
EMERGENCY DROUGHT REGULATIONS
URGING THE WATER BOARD TO
TARGET CURTAILMENT- COLD WATER
DIVERSION THE REPRESENT THE
MOST EGREGIOUS USES OF SURFACE
AND GROUNDWATER IN THE UPPER
SHASTA DRAINAGE SUCH AS CRYSTAL
GEYSER ROXANNE AND WE'D- AND
READ. AMERSON CATTLE RANCH IN
THE SHASTA RIVER WATERSHED. I
BELIEVE IT WAS MONTANA SHIVA HE
SAID. THERE'S ENOUGH WATER FOR
HUMAN NEED BUT NOT FOR HUMAN
GREED MAKE NO MISTAKE. THIS IS
CALIFORNIA'S WATER RECKONING
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
EMPOWER COMMUNITIES TO REDUCE
WASTE IMPROVE CONSERVATION
RESTORED ECOSYSTEMS THAT
PROVIDE OLD CLEAN WATER IN THE
FIRST PLACE. TIME FOR THIS TO
REVISIT OUR ANTIQUATED WATER
RIGHT SYSTEM THAT OVER ALLOCATE
WATER CONDONES UNLIMITED A NON
MONITORED GROUNDWATER PUMPING.
DENIED PUBLIC ACCESS TO
CRITICAL WATERSHED LENA AND
UNDERFUNDS EIGHT REALLY
GRATEFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANGELINA FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY IN CON IN FROM SHASTA WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
WHO HAS SIXTY SECONDS. NINE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY CRAIG THAT
NOW IS THE- WAGE DEFECT TRUTH
IF YOU'RE A SMOKER OR MAJEK IF
YOU WAIT- STOP. ALLOW MY NAME
IS ISAAC KENNY I'M A
BUSINESSMAN OF WATERSHED
REGENERATIVE VENTURES- FROM THE
COMPARABLE TO THE CLAMOR.
ATTENTION INTO RIVERS AND WHICH
BACK- REALLY CALLING TO URGE
NOW YOU CAN TO UP AND BE GOOD
AT BAD IS THE FINISH TO EACH
OTHER INTO OURSELVES- NOW IS
THE TIME TO YOU KNOW USE WATER
REALLY GOOD AND TO THE BOB.
GAGRA CULTURE AND THAT NEED FOR
GREED THAT I KEEP SEEING POP
UP. WE ALL HAVE CHOICES AND-
EVERYONE ON THE CALL THAT
DECISION MAKERS TAKE THE LEAD
FROM THE INDIGENOUS PEOPLES I
WOULD LIKE TO COULD TAKE YOU
NEED TO START DE FACTO- THE
FACT BECAUSE THE PANELS NEED TO
COME WITH THE NATIVES FIRST.
AND THEN THE CLIENT ALL OF THE
NEW SCIENCE THIS BILL PROFIT
YOUR THERE'S NO ECOLOGICAL
KNOWLEDGE AND THAT NEEDS TO BE
PRIORITIZED. AS WELL YOU CAN BE
SURE THAT HE- CAN YOU VERY
GREAT BECAUSE IN FROM IMPACT.
THING YOU SO MUCH. FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER OUR NEXT CALLER HAS
SIXTY SECONDS. MISTER TURNER
THAT WAS OUR LAST COMMENT IN Q.
ALL RIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO. EACH OF OUR PANELISTS
FOR THEIR PREACHING TO
PRESENTATIONS HERE TODAY WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OUR TO
DEPARTMENT HEADS. FROM THE
WATER BOARD AS WELL AS A
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE.
FOR BEING WITH US IN QUICKEN
ARE HEARING OFF AGAIN TURNED
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS MISTER VICE
CHAIR INFRASTRUCTURE YOU'VE
BEEN SO WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA AND KEEPING US.
ABSOLUTELY ON ON TRACK AND
FOCUSING ON CRITICAL ISSUES FOR
FISHERIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW WITH THE
CHANGING CLIMATE WITH DROUGHT.
A. N. HOW WATERSHEDS HAVE OR
HAVE NOT BEEN MANAGED OVER. THE
LAST GENERATION REALLY CRITICAL
AND ALL COMING TO A HEAD RIGHT
NOW. I THINK WE HAVE SOME
INTERESTING IDEAS. FROM A LOT
OF THE PANELISTS AS WELL AS A
REAL REALITY CHECK FROM THE
AGENCIES AND THOSE THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THIS ON. A DAILY
BASIS FOR WITH THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO BE LOOKING AT MOVING
FORWARD SO I APPRECIATE THIS
HEARING APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION. AND I JUST SAID WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF US
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR.
SO GRATEFUL FOR YOUR ADVOCATE
SENIOR PARTNERSHIP SIR WE WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR
TUNING IN TODAY WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO KNOW OPPENHEIM.
WHO HAS STEPPED IN. AS TIME WAS
SO IS TEMPORARILY OUT TO BE
ABLE TO BRING THIS HEARING
TOGETHER NO WHAT WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL WE WANNA SAY THANK YOU
TO MICHAEL KENNEDY. WHO IS WITH
US HERE TODAY WHO IS HAVE BEEN
AMAZING. ASSISTANCE IN GETTING
HIS HEARING THAT RULING TODAY
IS WELL TO MISTER OPPENHEIM
MISTER KENNEDY THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE ARE TRUE THE
APPRECIATIVE LOOK. OUR BOTTOM
LINE IS THIS. THIS YEAR IS
DIRE. IT'S GOING TO BE ONE OF
THE WORST ON RECORD FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC SALMON
FISHERY. WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO MITIGATE.
THE IMPACTS THAT THIS YEAR IS
GOING TO HAVE FOR YEARS TO COME
I AM WILL BE HOLDING A FOLLOW
UP HEARING THIS FALL. TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE THE TRUE NUMBERS
ON WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA'S WATERSHEDS WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
BASED OFF OF WATERSHED EXPERTS.
BIOLOGISTS AND SCIENTISTS THAT
THIS WILL BE THE MOST
CHALLENGING YEAR THE MOST DIRE
YEAR ON RECORD FOR ARCONIC ARE
ARCONIC SALMON FISHERY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED
JOINT COMMITTEE SENTRIES
HACKLES YOUR.